react is one of the most popular
front-end javascript frameworks and this
beginner's course is the perfect way for
you to learn how to use react
this course is unlike most of the other
react courses out there today instead of
just a single teacher we've brought
together an all-star lineup of
instructors to teach this course
these three instructors are some of the
most popular instructors on our channel
and have received well over 10 million
views on other tutorials
learning from a variety of perspectives
can help you solidify your understanding
of key react concepts this is a
project-based course and it focuses on
teaching you everything you need to know
to start creating your own react
applications
first gavin lawn will start from the
absolute beginning and teach you the
basics of react through building a
simple single page application to keep
track of team members
gavin has been a software developer for
over 20 years and he's great at passing
down the wisdom he's learned over the
years next you'll learn how to make a
meals app from john smilga john is one
of the most viewed instructors on our
entire channel so you're definitely in
good hands for this second project he'll
teach you how to fetch data from an
external api to use in this react
application finally you'll learn how to
create a simple stock trading app from
sanjeev thiagarajan
you'll use what you've learned so far
and apply it to an application that gets
data from an api and stores data to
local storage
among other things sanjeev previously
created one of the most popular and
comprehensive api development courses in
the world so he is the perfect person to
teach you more about using apis with
react and to follow along with this
course all you need is a web browser
every project in this course is
developed using the replit online ide
replit provided a grant that made this
course possible so we're about to get
started but let us know in the comments
what you think about courses with
multiple instructors
hi and welcome i'm gavin lon
i've been developing software
professionally for many years
and i'm really excited to bring you this
react for beginners course
i hope you enjoy it and i hope you
benefit from it
i've developed a very basic spa
application single page application
using react that we'll create in this
video
while we create this application we'll
cover basic concepts in react
let's take a brief look at the react
application that we are going to create
so let's say that we are a developer in
a software development company where a
lot of contract developers are employed
on a temporary basis
and assigned to their relevant teams
depending on the current projects being
developed by our organization
team members are moved between teams on
a fairly regular basis depending on the
current projects being developed by our
organization
so the team member agility as it were is
great but keeping track of who belongs
to what team
can be difficult for our development
manager at times
the development manager has asked us to
develop a basic spa application where he
is able to use the application to
allocate team members to their relevant
teams
and can use the application to keep
track of the teams and team members
on the home page you can see that at the
top here
we have a drop-down list that contains
the names of the teams in our
development department
below the drop-down list we have a
number of cards displayed in a tabular
format each card represents an employee
the cards that have a dark box shadow
surrounding them are the team members
that belong to the team currently
selected in the drop down list
you can see at the top of the page
status is presented to the user
displaying how many members the selected
team currently contains
the count of the relevance team members
in the selected team changes dynamically
and appropriately as the selected item
in the drop-down list is changed
the user is able to add a new member to
the selected team by simply clicking on
a card that does not have a dark box
shadow surrounding it
once the card is clicked a dark box
shadow appears around the relevant card
and this means the relevant employee
represented by the card is now a member
of the team selected in the drop down
list
as a new member is added to the team the
count of team members displayed to the
user and the status message at the top
changes accordingly
we have a navigation menu at the top of
the page we are currently on the home
page where we are able to add team
members to teams and remove team members
from teams
the user is able to navigate by clicking
the team's menu option in the top
navigation bar to a page that displays
the teams and team members in a
collapsible list the user is able to
click each team name represented as
headings in the collapsible list to
reveal the list of team members that
belong to the relevant team
when the user navigates back to the home
page
the team that was last clicked as it
were in the teams page will be the
selected team in the drop down list and
the user can then add or remove team
members from the selected team
when the user clicks a card on the home
page that already has a dark box shadow
meaning that this card represents an
employee that is part of the selected
team this action will remove the
employee from the selected team the
result of this action is represented on
the ui by removing the dark box shadow
from the relevant card
so the cards can be toggled whereby the
employee that the card represents is
added to the relevant team through a
click action and is also removed from
the relevant team with a click action
we are going to develop our spa
application using replit
replics is a popular free collaborative
in-browser ide where you are able to
code in 50 plus languages without
spending much time on setup
so in order to create our react
application using replit you'll need to
sign up for a free account with replit
it's a very simple process where you are
able to use your google github or
facebook account to sign up for your
free replit account or you can simply
provide a username email address and
password to sign up for your free replit
account
for details on how to create your free
replit account please navigate to this
url
so you can see here i've logged onto
replit
and you can see that i've created a few
rebels here rebel stands for read eval
print loop
in a bit i'll take you through a way in
which you can create a rebel through
raplet but for more details on ways in
which you are able to create a reply
using replit please navigate to this url
so before we create our repl
let me open a repel that i created
earlier that can be seen as the
prototype for the react application that
we'll create in this video the finished
code for this application is available
on github at this url
so before we leap into writing code what
is react
react which is sometimes referred to as
a front-end javascript framework is a
javascript library created by facebook
react is a tool for building ui user
interface components
how does react work
very basically react creates a virtual
dom document object model in memory
react is very fast react finds what
changes have been made and changes only
what needs to be changed
so let's create a repel for our react
application
to create a rebel we can click this
create button here
you can see in the drop down list we
have a number of programming languages
and developer platforms that we can
choose from
but we want the react js item
in the title field we can name our repo
whatever we choose i'm going to name my
reple team member allocation
then let's press the create rebel button
great and our environment is set up for
our ripple it's that simple
we can now build our react js spa
application
let's quickly create the traditional
hello world application
and look at that
when we change the output in the app.jsx
file it is immediately reflected in the
output of our application
before we get started building our
application let's remove the default css
code in the app.css file
this is the file where we will include
all of our css code for layout and
styling purposes
we are also going to use bootstrap 5 for
layout and styling purposes we'll look
at how we are able to integrate
bootstrap 5 into our application a
little bit later
so let's create three ui components
using react
these ui components are represented in
jsx files i'll explain what jsx is in
just a bit
so let's create a jsx file named
header.jsx like this
let's create a jsx file named
content.jsx
and let's create a jsx file named
footer.jsx
let's create the code for our header
component in this video i'm going to
teach you the modern way of developing a
react application
which uses functional components rather
than class components for more details
on class components and functional
components in react please navigate to
this url
i'll represent our functional components
using javascript arrow functions so for
example a javascript function can be
represented using this syntax
you can also represent the same function
as an arrow function using this syntax
if the function contains parameters the
arrow function representation of this
function would look like this
for more details on arrow functions
please navigate to this url
all the references to links in this
video can be found below in the
description of this video
so the code for the header component
simply outputs this html code to the
browser
we are now able to reference the header
component in our application
declaratively by appropriately including
a header element within the app.jsx file
we first need to import the header
component into the app.jsx component to
do this we can include this line of code
at the top of the app.jsx file like this
and now we can include the relevant
header element appropriately within our
app jsx file
great
let's take a quick pause and look at the
structure of our react application
if we open the index.html file you can
see that we have a div element with an
id of root
we also have a reference to the
index.jsx file
within the index.jsx file the container
const is referencing the root element
you can see here the render function is
being called to render the app component
within the root element
so let's create the code for our content
component to get the basic structure for
a functional react component let's copy
the code from the header component and
paste it into the content.jsx file and
appropriately change the code to suit
our content component
let's do the same for the footer
component
let's write code to import the content
component and the footer component into
the app component
let's appropriately include the content
element within our app component and
let's also appropriately include the
footer element within our app component
so as mentioned earlier we are going to
use bootstrap 5 for styling and layout
purposes in our application
we are easily able to install bootstrap
5.
so to do this let's click the icon here
representing packages let's search for
bootstrap
and this is the package that we want to
install to install this package let's
click the plus icon here
great
to have access to all the bootstrap 5
classes within our react application we
can include this import statement within
the index.jsx file like this
to double check that our bootstrap
package has been successfully installed
we can open the package.json file
great
to test that bootstrap is working as
expected let's include a few bootstrap
classes within our h1 element in our
header component
great
notice here that i've used the class
name property within the h1 element
rather than the class property in a
plain html web page you would use the
class property for this purpose
to reference a css class or classes
in a react application we must use the
class name property for this purpose
because the class keyword is used in
javascript class is a keyword in
javascript and jsx is an extension of
javascript
that's the principal reason why react
uses class name instead of class for
this purpose
so what exactly is jsx
jsx stands for javascript xml
jsx allows us to write html in react
jsx makes it easier to write and add
html in react
it is just an xml like extension that
allows us to write javascript that looks
like markup
and have it return from a component
so within the component we have here the
return keyword
the code that the component returns is
jsx code
that represents the markup that we are
returning from the component
it's important to note that jsx is not
valid javascript so browsers can't read
it directly
so what's known as a transpiler
translates it to react dot create
element calls
transpilers
a compiler that translates one form of
syntax to another like babel or
typescript compiles the jsx into
appropriate syntax that browsers can
understand
let's remove these bootstrap classes
here and start to develop the
functionality for our application
let's create a file named employees.jsx
let's copy the basic code structure for
a functional component created in our
header component and paste the code
within the employees.jsx file
so let's write code to import the use
state hook
into our employees component
we can do this with this line of code
i'll explain what a hook is in react and
the functionality made available through
the use of the used state hook in just a
bit
we are using the use state hook in this
case
so that react can track the state
of an array of objects that contain
details about our employees
so we can set a default value for our
use state hook by passing in an
appropriate argument to the hook here
so we want to pass an array of employee
objects
to speed things up a bit
we can copy the code for the relevant
employee array from this location on
github
and appropriately paste it into our code
here like this
so let's look at the code that we have
just created regarding the use state
hook
and let's understand the purpose of the
use state hook
if we navigate to this url
the react docs describe hooks as follows
hooks are a new addition in react 16.8
they let you use state and other react
features without writing a class
you can see here in an example where the
use state hook is used within a
functional component
the equivalent functionality can also be
achieved using classes but of course the
code is different when using class
components
when compared to how we write the code
using functional components
a hook is a special function that lets
you hook into react features for example
use state as a hook that lets you add
react state to functional components
so when would i use a hook
if you write a function component and
realize you need to add some state to it
previously you had to convert it to a
class
now you can use a hook inside the
existing function component
what does calling use state do
it declares
a state variable our variable is called
employees
but we could call it anything
this is a way to preserve some values
between function calls use state as a
new way to use the exact same
capabilities that this dot state
provides in a class
this javascript syntax is called array
destructuring
it means that we are making two new
variables employees and set employees
where employees is set to the first
value returned by use state and set
employees is the second
so basically the first item is the
employee data
the state of the employees data is
maintained in this item the second item
is a function reference
and is used wherever we need to change
the state of the employee's array stored
in the first item here
so basically the use state hook returns
a pair of values
the current state and a function that
updates it
when the state of the employees array
changes through a call to the set
employees method our employees component
is re-rendered to the user's browser
the markup jsx code that we'll write in
a bit denotes the html code that is
re-rendered to the browser
so i'm going to quickly demonstrate
writing code within the employees
component to output a list of each of
the employees full names to the screen
you don't need to follow along with this
part of the video as this is just to
demonstrate outputting
the relevant markup from our component
to the user's browser
let's write code to import the employees
component within the app component
let's replace the content element here
with the employees element
great
so we of course don't just want to
output a list of employee names to the
screen
we want to output the employee details
within cards to provide a better ux user
experience
before we create the code for this let's
upload two images that will be
appropriately displayed in our employee
cards
let's first create a folder named images
where we'll house our images that we are
about to upload
you are able to download the relevant
images from this location in github
you are then able to upload the images
like this
we can then drag and drop the images
into our images folder like this
great
let's write the code to output the
employee data as cards to the ui
firstly let's import the image files
like this into our employees component
notice how when returning jsx code
the markup related code must be
contained within one element
one element must be returned from jsx
code
if you wanted for example to return the
p element
and the image element without wrapping
these elements in for example a div
element
react allows you to wrap the relevant
elements in empty tags like this
in our case we are going to return
markup that is wrapped in one element
let's write code to return the relevant
markup from our employees component
note that we are using semantic html
here
so instead of just using a div element
here we are using a more descriptive
main element here
for layout purposes let's set our main
element's class name property to the
bootstrap container class
for layout purposes let's nest a div
element within the main element
let's then nest another div element
within the development that we have
nested within the main element
let's set the class name property of the
first div development
to a bootstrap class that denotes a new
row in our pages layout
let's set the class name property of the
div element we have nested within the
row development to a bootstrap class
that denotes a new column
so i'm using relevant bootstrap classes
for these div elements appropriately for
layout and styling purposes
i won't go into details of these
bootstrap classes in this video because
i want to focus on react please navigate
to this url for more details on the
bootstrap grid system
we are using javascript's map method to
map the data for each item in our
employees array to appropriate markup
code that will render a card for each
employee in the employees array
great our cards are displayed as
expected to the screen
let's center the cards using these
bootstrap classes here
great
i want three cards to be displayed per
line so i'm going to use the css grid
for this purpose
so let's wrap the cards in a development
let's set this development's classname
property to a class that we'll write in
just a bit named card dash collection
let's open the app.css class and include
the appropriate code for our card dash
collection css class
so we are setting the display property
to grid here
and then appropriately setting the grid
dash template dash columns property
so that each row of cards contains three
cards on the ui
excellent
let's use an appropriate bootstrap class
to create an appropriate amount of space
around each of our cards
this bootstrap class is simply
appropriately adjusting the margin
property of each of the cards
great that looks much better
we want the user's mouse pointer to turn
into a pointing hand icon when the user
hovers the user's mouse over a card
we can ensure that the appropriate style
of the user's cursor pointer is applied
by including this code within the
relevant div element that represents a
card note that because this is jsx code
and not typical html code we must set
the style property within the relevant
div element to an appropriate javascript
object that represents the appropriate
css code rather than the literal inline
css code that we would apply if we were
just writing html code
in the case of javascript objects like
this it can be confusing for react
beginners because you have two curly
braces one for the jsx and one for the
javascript object notation
one of the great things about jsx is
that we are able to include javascript
logic within expressions to determine
what markup code we want to render for
our components
so we can use curly brackets to tell
react as it were
that the code within the curly brackets
contains javascript logic
within the javascript logic we can
return html markup related code so let's
write a javascript expression that uses
a ternary operator to evaluate the
gender property of each employee based
on this property's value an appropriate
image element is returned from our
javascript logic
great
let's create code to output a drop down
list containing our teams
so for the sake of the example i'm just
hard coding the teams
in the real world you'd likely retrieve
the data from a database through a call
to for example a restful web api
component
great but the select list or drop-down
list could look a lot better
a really simple way to make our drop
down list look better is to use these
bootstrap classes
great
so whenever the user changes the
currently selected item in the drop-down
list
we want this to change the state of our
component
so to do this we are going to once again
use the use state hook
so here the selected team variable will
store whichever team is selected in the
drop down list the second item set team
is a function that we can use to change
the state of the selected team variable
when the set team function is used to
change the state of the selected team
variable our component will be
re-rendered
so when our component is first loaded
our component is rendered
when the user selects a new item in the
drop-down list our component will be
re-rendered
this is because whenever a user selects
a new item in the drop-down list our
component state has changed and
therefore a re-rendering of the
employee's component is triggered
we can pass in a specific team name as
our default value to the use state hook
let's pass in team b
so when our component is first rendered
team b will be the selected item in our
drop down list
so the next step is to set the value
property of the select element to the
selected team variable
so you can see how react is now able to
keep track of the state of our component
and render the component appropriately
in response to state changes
we need to use the set t method to
change the state of the selected team
variable
in order to know when to change the
state of the selected team variable our
component needs to know as it were when
the selected item in the drop down list
changes
we can use the javascript on change
event for this purpose
so let's appropriately wire up the
onchange event to a method that we'll
write in just a bit named handle team
selection change
let's write the handle team selection
change method
so we can use the event argument that is
passed into our handle team selection
change method by default to get the
value of the item selected in our
drop-down list we can then use the set
team method to change the state of the
selected team variable
this means that when the user changes
the selected list item in the drop down
list that this action changed the state
of our component and our component is
then re-rendered
let's write codes to log the new
selected items value to the console
window in our browsers
great
you can see that we have a few warning
messages logged to our console window
we'll address these issues as we develop
the application
i'm in a bit of a bad habit of using
class instead of class name
when applying css classes to elements
please note whenever i forget to use
class name and use class ignore me and
rather use class name to apply css
classes to the elements in your jsx code
so we want to add a box shadow around
our cards when a user clicks a card on
the ui
meaning that the user is adding the card
representing an employee
to the selected team in our drop down
list
so if the relevant card does not already
contain a box shadow around it a box
shadow will be added to the relevant
card
so if the card already has a box shadow
surrounding it when the user clicks this
card the box shadow will be removed from
the relevant card meaning
that the employee has been removed
from the relevant team selected in the
drop down list
so basically we want to write code so
that whenever a user clicks a card that
a box shadow effect is toggled for the
relevant card
so to do this let's use the on click
javascript event and wire up an event
handler method to this javascript event
named handle employee card click
we are going to call the map function on
the employees array to return a
transformed array where the relevant
employee item which in this case is
denoted by a card that has just been
clicked on the ui within the array is
changed in accordance with the team
selected in the drop down list
so for example if team a is selected in
the drop down list the employee item
represented by a card that has just been
clicked on the ui will change whereby
its team name property will be set to
the team selected in the drop down list
if an employee is already a member of
the selected team
the card representing the employee will
have a box shadow around it
when a card with a box shadow around it
is clicked the relevant employee items
team name property will be set to an
empty string
the box shadow will be removed from
around the relevant card on the ui
so the map function traverses the
employee items in the employees array
the ternary operator checks to see if
the employee represented by a card on
the ui matches the current evaluated
item in the employee's array
if a match is found the evaluated
employee item's team name property is
changed accordingly
so basically when a card is clicked if
the employee that the card represents is
already a member of the team this
functionality will cause that employee
to be removed from that team
if the employee however is not a member
of that team
that employee will be included within
that team
once all the employees have been
traversed by the map function the newly
transformed array is returned and
assigned to the const named transformed
employees
our code is then using the set employees
method
to change the state of the employee's
array
this state change then triggers the
employee's component to re-render
so how do we reflect the change in the
state of the employees array on the ui
we can add a css class that contains an
appropriate box shadow property to the
clicked card element
or remove the relevant css class if it
already contains the relevant css class
so we are essentially toggling the css
class to create this effect the effect
of adding and removing the box shadow
from the relevant card
so we can achieve this in code by
including an appropriate ternary
operator
that returns the appropriate css code to
the appropriate class name property
within the relevant div element that
represents a card
so if the employee's team name property
is equal to the team selected in the
drop down list
ensure that a css class named standout
which we'll write in a bit is referenced
in the relevant div element
else ensure that the standout css class
is not referenced in the relevant div
element i.e the development that
represents a card the card of course
represents an employee
so let's write the code for the standout
css class let's open the app.css file
let's add the standout.css class
let's include the box shadow property
within the standout css class and
provide the appropriate box shadow
settings
excellent
so we now want to output status
information from the header component
whereby when the selected item in the
drop-down list changes a count of how
many team members exist
in the selected team is presented from
within the header component
to make it easy to communicate state to
both the header component
and the employee component
we can include the state-related code
that currently resides within the
employees component in the app component
which is the parent component of both
the employees component and the header
component
so let's cut the state-related code
from within the employee's component
like this
and appropriately paste this code within
the app.jsx file like this
let's cut the code that imports the use
state hook into the employees component
and appropriately paste this code into
the app.jsx file
now in order for the employees
components to be able to effect state
and respond to state change
we need to pass down the state-related
items
to the employees component from within
the app component
we are able to do this in a react
application by passing the relevant
props
to a child component like this
prop drilling is an unofficial name for
passing props to a child component from
a parent component
let's take a moment to understand the
concept of props in react
let's navigate to this url
what are props in react
we use props in react to pass data from
one component to another from a parent
component to a child component or
components
props
is just a shorter way of saying
properties they are useful when you want
the flow of data in your app to be
dynamic
how to use props without destructuring
we are going to use destructuring but
let's first understand how to use props
without destructuring
to use props you have to include the
props parameter within your function
this is similar to passing arguments
into your regular javascript functions
here's an example
so you can see here the values for the
name prop and the tool prop
are being passed down to the tool child
component within the tool component
these prop values can be read through
the props object like this
so we are passing in our props values
from the app component to the employees
component in a similar way but we are
going to use destructuring to read the
relevant props values from within the
employees component
the next step is to include these props
within the function that denotes the
employee's component
so instead of the props object being
passed to our employees component
we are destructuring the object into its
individual property values
so through destructuring we don't have
to reference within our employees
component the relevant values with props
dot preceding the relevant properties
destructuring in a javascript expression
makes it possible to unpack values from
arrays or properties from objects into
distinct variables
so here we are unpacking values from
properties of a javascript object into
appropriate distinct variables
great
we can now use prop drilling to pass in
the selected team and count of the
number of members of the selected team
to the header component
we can use javascript destructuring to
unpack the relevant props
in the relevant object
into appropriate variables
let's change the header of our header
component appropriately
let's include code to output the count
of team members within the selected team
to the browser
excellent
let's use bootstrap to include
appropriate layout code for our header
component
great
let's write code in the app.css file
so that text within h1 h2 h3 h4 h5 and p
elements
are horizontally aligned centrally
let's include some basic code in the
footer component with some appropriate
layout code provided by the relevant
bootstrap classes
great
local storage
so every time the state changes for
either the employees array or the
selected team variable we want to save
their values to local storage in react
we are able to implement the use effect
hook to track state changes for specific
variables when a particular state change
occurs
code passed as a function to the use
effect hook can run that appropriately
saves our state to local storage
so let's see how we can do this in code
in the app component where we are
importing the use state hook let's also
provide code so that the use effect hook
is also imported from react
we can then pass in an arrow function as
an argument to the use effect hook
so the first argument denotes the code
that we want executed when a certain
event occurs for example the state of a
variable changes
the second argument denotes the event
that must occur to trigger the function
passed in as the first argument i.e the
function that we want executed
if however we passed in an empty array
like this as the second argument
the function passed in as the first
argument would only execute when the
component first loads
in this case we want the function passed
in as the first argument to the use
effect hook to run when the state of the
employees array changes
so this is when a user clicks on the
card and a team name for an object
within the employees array
changes
ie
when its team name property changes to
the selected item in the teams drop down
list
so to do this we can pass in the
employee's variable wrapped in square
brackets as the second argument
then we can appropriately call the local
storage dot set item function to save
the employee's array to local storage
so when the stage changes we are
updating the employees array in local
storage
we can use another use effect hook to
save the state changes to the selected
team variable to local storage like this
great
we can then use the
localstorage.getitem function
to get the value of the selected team
saved to local storage
rather than the hard-coded value we
currently have here that is currently
setting the state of the selected team
variable by default
so by default we are going to be setting
the value of the selected team variable
from local storage if it exists in local
storage if it doesn't exist in local
storage it will then be set to the
hard-coded value i.e team b
so if the relevant value exists in local
storage the relevant value in local
storage will be passed in to the use
state hook and set the selected team
variable by default to the appropriate
value saved to local storage
so we are using what's known as a short
circuit evaluation for the javascript
expression passed as an argument to the
use state hook here
what this means is that when javascript
evaluates an or expression if the first
operand is true javascript will short
circuit and not even look at the second
operand
so we can apply the same logic for the
employees array like this
so the state of our application will now
be persisted to our browser's local
storage
great
one thing i forgot to do
is to include an appropriate key
attribute within the div element that
represents a card that denotes an
employee object within a list of
employee objects
the key attribute helps react identify
changes within a list of elements
so whenever you have code displaying a
list of uniquely identifiable elements
it is a good idea to include a key
attribute and assign the key attribute
to a unique identifier in this case
the key is assigned the id
of the relevant employee object
just to get rid of some of the warning
messages i'm getting in the browser
console window i'm going to track down
where i'm using class instead of class
name
great
routing react router dom
the next step is to create functionality
so that we can navigate between two of
the main components within our react
application we have already created one
of the main components which is the
employees component we'll create the
other main component in just a bit which
will be named grouped team members
so we want to create functionality so
that a user through the use of a
navigation bar positioned at the top of
the web page can navigate between the
employees component and the grouped team
members component while the header and
footer components remain rendered to the
screen
so we are going to create a nav
component that will appear at the top of
our page
so that the user can speedily navigate
between the two main components
so let's start by installing the react
router dom package
let's click the package icon here
let's type
react-router-dom as search criteria here
this is the package we want to install
so let's click the relevant plus icon to
install the package
great and if we open the package.json
file
we can see that we have installed the
appropriate
react dash router dash dom package
within the app.jsx file let's import the
components that we need from the react
router dom package
let's wrap our header employees and
footer component within the router
element
each component that we want to navigate
to
will have its own root element so let's
create a root element for the employee's
component
we want only the employees component to
render along with the header and footer
components when the user first loads the
application so the employee's component
renders between the header and footer
components when the url does not contain
any path information
then we must include an element property
within the relevant root element and set
this to our employees element like this
then let's include a root element
pertaining to the navigation to the
grouped team members component let's set
its path property to forward slash
grouped team members this is the path to
a component that we are going to create
in just a bit
this component can be seen as the other
main component of our application
the two main components are the
employees component and the grouped team
members component
let's appropriately set the element
property to the grouped team members
element like this
so basically if the browser contains the
path to the grouped team members
component then the header component the
grouped team members component and the
footer component will be rendered to the
ui
the employees component will not be
rendered to the ui
if no path is provided along with the
url of our application i.e no particular
path is provided to a specific component
then the header component the employees
component and the footer component will
be rendered to the ui
and the grouped team members component
will not be rendered to the ui
so let's create the grouped team members
component with minimal functionality at
this point
we'll create the appropriate
functionality for the grouped team
members component once we have written
the code for the navigation
functionality
let's import the grouped team members
component into our app component
if we type in the path
to the grouped team members component in
our browser you can see that this
component is appropriately rendered to
our ui along with the header and footer
components great
if we remove this path
the header employees and footer
components are rendered to the screen
excellent
let's create a file for our nav
component named nav.jsx
let's write codes to import the link
component from within the react router
dom package
the code for the nav component will
basically rely on bootstrap classes for
layout and styling purposes
so within the first unordered list item
let's include a link element that
navigates the user to the home page
within the second unordered list item
let's include a link element that
contains the path to the grouped team
members component
let's import our nav component into the
app component
let's appropriately include the nav
element within our app.jsx file
we now have a navigation menu presented
to us at the top of our page
our navigation functionality is working
as expected but we want the navigation
links to be displayed next to each other
rather than on top of each other like
this
oh and the problem is that this class
should be expand rather than expanded
great
that looks much better
so if the user types in an invalid path
we can include a route to handle this
to do this we can include a root element
below the existing root elements here
we can set its path property to a wild
card character which will act as a catch
all for urls that don't match the paths
declared in the root elements above this
root element
so let's set its element property to a
component that we'll create in just a
bit named not found
so let's create the not found component
this component merely outputs a message
to the screen stating that the requested
page could not be found
great
the next step is to write the code for
the grouped team members component let's
open the grouped teammembers.jsx file
let's import the use statehook
let's include javascript destructuring
code to destructure the props that we
want passed into our grouped team
members component into appropriate
individual variables let's go to the app
component and write code to pass in the
relevant props to the grouped team
members component
let's go back to the grouped team
members.jsx file
as stated earlier the use state hook
returns a pair of values
the current state and a function that
updates it
the set group data function will be used
for changing the state of the grouped
employees array
let's pass in a call to a function named
group team members to the use state hook
that will return the default value of
the grouped employees array
each object in the grouped employees
array
will contain one property that stores
the team name a property that stores the
employee data for employees that are
part of the relevant team and a property
named collapsed the collapsed property
will store the state for a list item in
the collapsible list
that we are going to return from the
grouped team members component
when a user clicks a team in the
collapsible list as it were the
collapsed property for the corresponding
object will be set to the opposite
boolean value currently stored in the
relevant collapsed property
this state change will cause the
component to re-render and the relevant
list item will either be in a state of
collapsed or expanded
we'll write code in a bit to return the
appropriate ui markup from this
component so that this state change will
be appropriately reflected on the ui
so
the collapsed property facilitates
toggle functionality whereby a list item
in a list of teams can be collapsed or
expanded by clicking on the relevant
list item when the list is expanded a
list of the relevant teams team members
are presented directly below the team
list item
when an expanded list item is
subsequently clicked the relevant list
item will be collapsed whereby the
relevance team member data will be
hidden
we are passing a function named group
team members to our use state hook here
this function will return an array of
objects that will be the default state
stored in the grouped employees array
so let's write the code for the group
team members function
this function simply returns an array of
objects where each object stores a team
name a list of team members and a
boolean property named collapsed the
collapsed property denotes whether a
team list item displayed on the ui is in
a collapsed or expanded state
please note that i would not write code
like a code i'm about to write for the
group team members function in the real
world and the relevant code is only
meant to set up relevant grouped data
for this example
we are going to flagrantly violate the
principle of dry don't repeat yourself
in this code so the purpose of this
function is to transform the list of
employee objects stored in the employees
array
and group the employees into their
appropriate teams based on the team name
property value for each employee object
so let's declare an empty array at the
top of our method named teams
let's use the javascript filter function
to return the team members for team a
using the filter function called on the
employees array
let's create the object that contains
the team name for team a
the employee objects representing the
members of team a
and then let's include a property named
collapsed
let's use a ternary operator to
initialize the value of the collapsed
property if the selected value in the
drop down list is team a
then we want this list item to be
expanded and display team a's team
members so in this case we set the
collapsed property to false else the
collapsed property is set to true
meaning the list item is collapsed and
the relevant team members for team a are
not displayed on the ui
let's write code to add the relevant
object to the team's array
let's repeat the same logic for the
other teams
let's write code to return the
appropriate ui related code from our
component
so to do this let's map the data stored
within the grouped employees array to
the appropriate collapsible list of
teams
so to handle the event where a user
clicks on a team list item let's wire up
an on click event within the appropriate
div element to a method that we'll
create named handle team click
let's write the handle team click event
handler method
in this code we are using the map
function to traverse the items in the
grouped employees array
if team name matches the id
of the clicked item
then our code knows as it were which
team list item was clicked and which
items collapsed property value to
appropriately change in the array
so our code changes the relevant
collapsed property to its opposite value
of course the collapsed property is a
boolean value either true or false
this is to create the desired toggle
effect for our team list presented on
the ui
the map function returns the transformed
array
we can then write code to change the
state for the grouped employees array by
appropriately calling the set grouped
data function
we can also call the set team function
that has been passed in with the props
from the app component to set the
selected item in the drop-down list on
the employee's component appropriately
we are able to change the state for the
employees component through the relevant
props passed into the grouped team
members component
so this has facilitated dynamic
communication if you like between the
grouped team members component
and the employees component
so appropriate changes made in either of
these components the employees component
or the grouped team members component
will appropriately be reflected in the
other component
so the collapse functionality is
currently not working
the reason for this is that i've used a
class named collapsed to create the
collapse effect in our list
this class doesn't exist in our
application a class that i meant to
reference here is a bootstrap class
named collapse
when this class is present in the
relevant div element a list of team
members will not be displayed for the
relevant team when the collapse class is
not present within the relevant
development the list of team members
will be displayed directly
below the relevant team item
let's just quickly fix a small issue
here where there is only one member in a
team and we want our ui to reflect one
team member rather than one team members
lastly let's neaten up our code a bit by
appropriately abstracting certain
functionality into their own components
so for example we can abstract this code
within the employees component that
renders the drop-down list to the ui
into its own component
so let's do this please feel free to
reference the relevant code at this
location on github if you get stuck at
this point
let's abstract the code that traverses
the employees array into a component
named team members
a component named team member card is
called from within the team members
component
we can include the code that resides
within the employees component that
renders the cards to the ui within the
team member card component
so let's create a component named team
member card that renders each card
appropriately to the ui
the code is now much neater great
let's include a media query within our
app.css file
so that on small screen sizes each card
is presented in a new line
so by doing this we are making our spa
application responsive
excellent note that i've created two
versions of this application that can be
found on github the version that we
created in this video can be found at
this location
as an added bonus i created another
version of our application on github
that can be found at this location in
this version of the application
i have implemented code for abstracting
the management for passing data between
components through the use of context
let's navigate to this url and read a
bit about context
context provides a way to pass data
through the component tree without
having to pass props down manually at
every level so by using context we can
avoid prop drilling
in a typical react application data is
passed top down parent to child via
props
but such usage can become cumbersome for
certain types of props eg local
preferences ui theme that are required
by many components within our
application context provides a way to
share values like these between
components without having to explicitly
pass props through every level of the
tree
the application that we have created is
small and fairly basic when an
application grows
it may be better to use context so that
the code used to share values between
components is neater and easier to
maintain
please check out this version of the
code on github to see how i have
implemented context for the purpose of
sharing values between components
without using prop drilling
with react you can break down an
interface into reusable components that
allow you to build dynamic user
interfaces react can be described as a
mature javascript framework and it has
an enormous community supporting it
the performance that react provides
makes it an excellent choice for the
implementation of front-end user
interactive functionality
i highly recommend learning this
technology
now that you've learned the basics of
react with gavin it's time for you to
apply that knowledge to a more complex
application
john smilga is your instructor for this
next section
hey what's up it's john from youtube
channel codingaddict and welcome to our
next react project
the meals application
and before i showcase the app let's
quickly discuss
the main objectives of the project
and essentially there are two of them
first in this project we'll learn how to
fetch data
from external api
and as a signal during the project we'll
utilize the meal db api as our external
data resource and our second objective
is to get familiar with app level state
and more specifically context api
since it's something you simply can't
avoid when building more complex
applications
if you want to take the project for test
drive just navigate to this url
mealsapplication.johnsmailga.repple.co
again the url is dub dub dub
meals application dot johns milga
dot reply dot co and as far as the
functionality using this application
user can search
for the recipes so when the application
loads we display some default recipes
and if the user is interested in the
cooking instructions he or she can click
on recipe and here we display the image
the title cooking instructions as well
as original
resource effectively this is where the
original recipe is coming from and also
we can close the model
now user also has a option to search
for recipes based on a search term so
for example if i go here and type a
now i'm going to get all the recipes
where in the title there's a letter a
now also user can get some random ones
if he or she clicks on the surprise me
notice now we're getting the random
recipes and also there's an option to
add
recipe to the favorites
so if let's say i like this recipe i can
add it to the favorite now we also have
an option to remove from the favorites
and we can also
take a look at the favorite recipe again
in the model
now the favorite recipes will be
persisted in the local storage and
therefore
even
if you leave the application
and come back later you'll still have
the recipes that you saved in the
favorites so it's not just going to be
the local state but also will implement
the local storage
for this project i also created a readme
file and in there you'll find useful
external resources
code snippets and all the steps we're
going to take to build the application
i like such approach since it saves you
time on taking notes essentially all the
important stuff is already documented
and more importantly it allows you to
work on a project independently
once i'm done explaining the step
if you feel like working on it
independently
just pause the video and try to solve
the challenge on your own
and resume it once you're ready to see
my solution
lastly i will share the url basically
where you can find the source code with
the readme file in the following videos
just remember that you can always find
both urls for the complete app which we
covered in the last video and for the
source code in the video description
below
okay and we're going to start our
journey by creating a new project in the
replit so assuming that you've logged in
or registered
go to your dashboard and look for create
button
in there
look for react template
and at least i'm gonna go with default
name but
of course you can come up with whatever
name you want for your application
and once all the dependencies have been
installed just click on run
so we can see our project in the browser
and then at the very end of the video
i'll just change the title in the
index.html and basically this is what we
see in the browser tab
so since i have logged in let me just
navigate here
to a dashboard and like i said we're
looking for create if you want to see
all your projects
they're going to be down here
so let's go for create we're looking for
a react template and i'm going to go
with this
default name
that they offer and now we want to go
with create repel
we'll just have to wait a little bit
for the dependencies to be installed and
once everything is ready to go we just
want to go with the run so effectively
this is going to open up our application
in the browser tab here
on the right hand side
and once i can see my application
in action
let me just showcase that
all the way in left hand side
these are going to be our files
then in the middle we'll have our code
and in my case i'm going to keep it
between 200 zoomed in and 250. so
hopefully that way you can see clearly
my code and i'll also change the size
from time to time of the browser tab
just so i have
a bit more real estate here in the
middle all the way in the bottom we have
the console which for the most part
we're not going to use and what's really
cool that for our little browser window
we also have the devtools
so if you click on these ones notice
here we can also
see
all the errors warnings and of course
our console log and rest of the stuff
now we also have this cool option of
opening this one up in the new browser
tab
and
as a result we get a bigger canvas so
from time to time yes i'll switch
actually from this small one
to a bigger one because it's going to be
easier to showcase the devtools and all
that cool stuff and at the very end of
the video i just want to change here
what we see
in the page so let me just go here with
meals and app and i'll do the same thing
in the index.html
so let me navigate to index.html here
where we have the title we can change
the name so let's go with meals app let
me save it and of course we can see the
result in both places in the small
browser window as well as the big one
okay and now let's grab some assets from
the complete
project
so first what i want you to do is
navigate to this url
and again the url is following we're
looking for replic.com at johnsmilga
and
meals application now here of course it
adds that hashtag readme because that's
the file where i'm at but the main url
is again replic.com johnsmilga meals
application i want you to navigate there
and more specifically navigate to
app.css and then we'll talk about what
we want to get from there
as well as
why i suggest copying readme so first
let me just showcase
the url
so copy and paste everything that i have
right now now just remove that readme
now if you have a different view
of the application again it doesn't
change the files that you're looking for
so navigate to the source folder you're
looking for app css and at this point
you have two options
if you don't
want to type css together
just take the whole thing
so just copy it and set it up in your
project
now if you do want to type the css and
i'll sign up yes i'll make the css video
separate so that way if you don't want
to
type the css together you can just skip
it or if you do want to build it
together then just grab everything
up to the
end of global styles which is going to
be my case of course since we'll type
the css together again this is a
somewhat of a
hot button topic because some people
prefer typing css some don't
so in this case you have an option if
you want to type out the css together
then just grab everything up to the end
of global styles if you don't want to
type the css then just take the whole
thing hopefully i made myself clear and
like i said in my case i'm going to take
everything up to the global style since
of course
i will write the css for the upcoming
components
now i'll cover
the global styles in a little bit more
detail in one of the upcoming videos for
now just take the css you want to
get from this file navigate back to your
application
look for source look for app.css
remove all the code that you have right
now
save it
and you should
see different result on the screen now
when it comes to readme
i just think that it's better if you
have those steps
in your application now you don't have
to copy the contents i mean you don't
even have to follow along as far as
these steps
but i think it makes more sense if you
want to work on the project
independently and therefore in my case
i'm just going to take all the code
that again i have in the complete
project readme and i'll just navigate
back to the project that we just started
building again i'll remove all the code
that is currently there and copy and
paste
and successfully we have acquired all
the assets that we needed from the
complete application so at this point i
can actually close it and from now on of
course
we'll be doing all of our work
in the application we just created and
when it comes to global styles
essentially you'll just find
some settings for typography
a reset
css variables
for example for colors
as well as the bore radiuses
box shadows
and then just some general styles
including some classes that i use
somewhat often for example button and as
i know this is something that i use
not only in react projects but pretty
much
in every project that i make because
in the long run it saves me a bunch of
time
since i have some preset values and that
way i don't have to reinvent the wheel
each and every time awesome we're pretty
much done with the general info
so now let's start coding and the first
thing that i want to do is to set up a
structure for our project
and in order to do that
i want you to create a components folder
in the source
and there are
four files effectively these are going
to be our components
in microsoft i'm going to go with
favorites meals modal and search all of
them will have that jsx extension and in
there we want to create a component and
in my case i'll set it up as a arrow
function
now i want you to set up a basic return
in my case i'm going to go with
component name but of course you can
type whatever you want in the return as
long as we can see something on the
screen now my personal favorite is shake
and bake but of course you can for
example go with heading one and dude
where is my car as long as you can see
something on the screen we are good to
go now we do need to remember to export
this as default
and then in the app js we'll import all
of them and set them up
one by one
so effectively
the component is going to look something
like this for example search one again i
have the function i have some kind of
basic return and i'm exporting as a
default
then we want to import all of them in
app.js and set up the following
structure so notice these are all the
imports for our components and then
inside of the main we want to go with
search
favorite
meals and model and if you can see
all the returns on the screen you're
good to go
and last thing that i will do at least
in my case is to comment out search
favorites and model why well because
we'll start working in the meals
and
even though i do want to see
that the component has been set up
correctly
so essentially
in the beginning i do want to see some
kind of return
i just think it's going to be easier at
least for me as i'm developing and
showcasing stuff
just to have the component that we're
actually working in so this is how i'm
going to set up the structure for the
application however i'm going to do that
in the following video
so if you want to work on this
independently
then once this video ends
just try
to set it up yourself and if you want to
see my solution
i'll cover it in next video
okay so let's get cracking
first we need to create a components
folder so let's go with add folder in
the source and i'm going to go with
components now there we want to add some
files
yep that's correct and of course we can
see the list of files we need to create
so one by one let's just set them up i
think i'm going to set up the files
first and then
i'll set up one return copy and paste
and just change some values so first let
me add those files we're looking for
meals
jsx
then we also want to set up
a modals
jsx
and then lastly we have the search one
so let's go with add file and we're
looking for the search jsx
so let's start i guess with the
favorites
where we want to go
with our arrow function so const
and in my case i'm going to pretty much
name it
same as the file so favorites here it's
going to be my arrow function and as far
as return i'm just going to go with
heading 1 and i'll write
favorites and then the component
component and like i said we want to
export that as default so export default
and
i think i actually want to
get it in the app just right away
so before i copy and paste anything let
me just go to app
just
and we want to import that from
components so favorites
from
and then we want to go with components
and more specifically favorites file
and then where we have the main one why
don't we change this around and let's
just say favorites so that's our
component and if everything is correct
this is what we should see on the screen
and since i can see that that's the case
now let me just go here and i'll copy
these values so i'm looking for a meals
one i'll copy and paste then i'll select
all the instances with the command d at
least that's
the shortcut on a mac and then we'll
change it around two meals we want to do
the same thing here in the modal
and copy and paste
i'll just write modal
and then the last one is going to be a
search one so again let's select
everything
all the instances are favorites and
let's go with search let's save it
then we want to navigate back to
app
we want to copy and paste and
we'll just set up a few cursors here
so the
second one
is going to be meals
then we'll be looking
for the model i believe
so let me type here model actually
messed it up here a little bit
so let me go with the forward slash and
then lastly
we also have the search one i believe so
let me remove all of them
and then let's go with search
now as far as the structure we'll start
with search favorites meals and model
so let's go here search
then we'll have
the meals
and also have the
model so model
over here
and if you can see
four heading ones displayed on the
screen we're in good shape basically
we're moving in the right direction
and once everything is good to go then
one by one i'll just comment them out
like i said
it's easier a way for me to showcase
which component we're actually working
in otherwise you
might be
confused by all of the heading ones that
we can see on the screen now the way we
can set up a comment in the hsx is
actually in a following way so let me
showcase that notice so we go with
curly's and then inside of the curlies
we go with forward slash and then star
and then star and forward slash and then
whatever we place here
is going to be commented out again
eventually we'll use those components
but for now
what i'm going to do is back in the app
just like i said you want to set up the
curlys here then we want to go with
forward slash and then star
then star forward slash and i'll copy
and paste right away
and i'll set up one for search
one for favorites and one for model
because we'll start working in the meal
so one by one let's place them there
so you cannot see the search anymore you
cannot see the favorites and also you
cannot see the model and now let me move
this sucker down we have meals ready to
go so now we can
move on to our next step okay and now
let's talk about the app level state and
essentially it's a decision we need to
make
of how we're going to handle the props
in our application because one thing we
need to keep in mind that in react we
can only pass the props down
so for example in our application we're
going to have
favorite meals and then once we click on
a meal we actually open up a modal
so there's going to be a communication
between the favorites component
and the modal component
and as you can see it's not like we can
just directly pass from one to another
one
effectively
we can either set up all the
functionality here in the app.js since
that's the root component again we can
only pass the props down we can go with
context api
something that we're actually going to
do and therefore i'm not going to go
into more detail since
we'll cover all of that in the upcoming
videos and also we can go with
third-party state management library for
example redux or redux toolkit and then
of course there's
million more
now
honestly in this case in this particular
application
we actually can go with app.js approach
since there's not that many levels that
we need to pass
however again we need to keep in mind
that all the logic is going to be here
in the app.js
since this is a root component
and then from the app we pass to a
separate component
now the problem is going to start as
your app grows more complex and if you
have more nested structure for example
you have more components inside of
these components
then effectively becomes a pain and it's
not an official name for that but it's
referenced as a prop drilling where
basically you pass the props down to one
component then
it has some nested components so we keep
passing down and down and down and one
of the solutions for that is using
context api
now
once you get to really complex apps
then it makes sense
to use redux redux toolkit my personal
favorite at the moment
and some other choices that are out
there
so in this application i didn't see the
point of actually using redux or redux
toolkit
and therefore the choice was really
between the app.js and context api and
even though
in this scenario
we can set up all the logic here in
app.js i decided that this is going to
be an awesome introduction
to the context api all right and now
let's talk about the context api
and before we go any further let me just
mention two things first if
you
don't find my explanations good enough i
can always suggest this article by free
code camp where they cover context api
in a great detail
now the second thing that i want to
mention
even though yes context api is an
awesome approach
still keep in mind
that it has its limitations
yes it's good enough for this project
and it's way better than just passing
down props
from one component to the next one let's
say seven levels deep however
once your app grows
and becomes really complex
essentially you'll hit two roadblocks
first
there's less structure
than for example tools like redux and
redux toolkit and that becomes
especially important
if
there's a team working on a project
and the second roadblock you'll most
likely hit
is the fact that it's somewhat clunky to
communicate between
multiple contexts
so
when it comes to really complex
application most likely you'll not only
have one context api you'll have
multiple
and at least in my experience
it's way easier to communicate between
these functionalities when using the
third party state management library
like i keep saying redux toolkit because
that at the moment is my favorite
now as far as the setup for the context
api again
effectively it's a way for us
to have all our logic in one place and
instead of prop drilling where we pass
the props from one component to the next
one again let's say seven levels deep we
can set up all the logic in one place
and then that specific
component can just cherry pick
what data
is necessary and if at the moment you're
somewhat fuzzy on that don't worry once
we set up the actual example it's going
to become clear so first we want to
create a context jsx file somewhere in
our root now technically you can create
the components and all that but i always
prefer setting it up in the root now
when i say root of course i'm talking
about the source
then we want to import react and use
context something we're going to
use a little bit later
from react
and we want to come up with a variable
name now i always like to go with app
context or some meaningful name that
references the context that i'm creating
but again shaken bake is
also a good choice then we want to go
with react dot and create context so we
have this method that creates the
context and once we invoke create
context effectively we get back two
things we get back the provider
and we get back the consumer now let's
not worry about the consumer right now
let's just worry about how we can pass
the data down and we do that with this
component of provider now notice here
though how we will set up a brand new
component
and i'll talk about the children
once we actually set this one up but in
here in the return we go with that
provider so this is what we're getting
back from that create context and then
in the value prop whatever we'll pass in
at the moment is just a low we can
access
pretty much anywhere in our application
and then
the last thing that we need to do as far
as the provider we need to export it and
we'll also export this app context and
this is going to make
sense a little bit later so in here i'm
talking about the main item that we're
getting back from create context
and then we want to wrap
our entire application
in the app provider
so the component
that we're creating over here
so we want to import that since we're
exporting from the context and we want
to wrap our application
now while we're still in the index.js i
want to mention that because of react
strict mode
while in development you'll notice
multiple logs so if you're wondering hey
why
while i'm developing i'm getting
quite a few console logs it's because of
the react strict mode that's just
basically a setup in development and
once i've covered the general concept
now let me set up the
context api in our application
okay so now let's set up the context in
our application
like i said i prefer setting up in the
source
so let me create a new file i'm going to
go with context
js
and here we want to look for react
and we also want to right away get huge
context now we'll set this one up later
we use contextual but we might as well
import it right now then we want to go
with the name in my case that is going
to be the app
context and that one is equal to
react
and then the method name is create
context we invoke it and again we get
back those two components
now
since i want to return provider
from the component that i'm going to be
wrapping the application i need to first
create that component
naming is up to you in my case i'm going
to go with provider again this is a
separate component that will wrap our
application and from this component
we're going to return app context dot
provider
very important distinction so in here
we'll access children
and
i'll showcase that once we actually wrap
the application because it's going to be
easier to
understand that way
so let me go with return here
return and we want to go with app
dot context dot
and then we're looking for provider like
i said we get back two things the
consumer and provider
but with the arrival of use context we
actually don't need to export it from
the context.js so that's why we just
need provider and then it has the value
prop whatever we'll set here
in the beginning is just going to be
string but eventually it's going to be
more complex data structure
that one will be passed down to all the
components and as a result we won't need
to do that prop drilling now we do want
to display the children against
something i'm going to cover in a sec
once we can actually access everything
and now let's export from this file
so for now we want to export
the app context as well as the
app provider both of them are named
exports as you can see
so let's save it if nothing breaks we're
in good shape now let's navigate to
index jsx we want to grab the provider
so import app
provider now that one is coming from and
then of course we're looking for the
context
and then we want to go where we have our
application
and we want to basically wrap it in the
app provider like so
so let's wrap it
again if everything still works if there
are no issues
then we are in good shape and it looks
like i have an error and actually it's
because of the name
the extension should be here
js6
my bad
once i fix
the extension everything should work as
expected let me
restart
and yep i can see
the meals component
now the reason why we want to
grab the children pop and set it up here
in return because this is our
application so essentially in react
children
is a special prop
and that represents pretty much
whatever
we have inside of the component so in
our case what we have inside of the
component is the app one so in the app
provider we have app
and in our function that is represented
with this children again this is a
special prop that's why you go here with
curly braces we structure it
we grab the children and we pass it here
if you won't do that basically you won't
see your application notice how nothing
is displayed so that's why it's
important for us to grab the special
children prop and then pass it down
because this is our entire application
and once we have set up the provider now
let's see how we can access
the data in any of our components
beautiful
we were able to set up the provider
so now let's see how we can consume the
data
now before we proceed i actually want to
make some changes in the workspace
so first i noticed since i used that
default name
i actually don't see the working
application in the dashboard essentially
it's under unnamed
and i've said that i'll actually change
that so let me navigate here
and in order to do that i just need to
click on this icon and then
let me go with
meals
meals app and then let me add temp or
you know what i'll start with temp
i'll go temp meals app so that way i
know that this is just temporary while
i'm recording okay so that's done
and then the second thing that i want to
change
essentially is
the workspace
where
it's nice to have that browser window
but the more code we're going to write
it's actually more important for me
that you can see clearly
all the code and readme
that i'm providing and that's why i'll
actually
open
a new one the browser one and that's the
one that i'm going to
use to display the results so in here we
can simply close the webview then we'll
have the console not technically you
don't even have to close i believe the
webview you can just simply push it to
the side
and
finally i'll
zoom in and hopefully
it's going to be easier to
see the actual code
now
as far as the
consuming data what do we need to do
well once we have set up the provider we
can go to any of our components and
again the magic here is following
that it's not just these components in
the components folder
it can be any components
that are sitting inside of these
components and that's truly powerful
because again we don't have to pass
those props
seven levels down
and in order to consume that data we
need to go with used context so we need
to go to any of the components where we
want to consume the data
in our case it's going to be meals since
that's the only one that's rendered
because i don't want to get use context
hook from react we want to get the app
context from the context so remember
when we're setting up the context this
is what we're exporting correct we're
exporting the app provider so the
component of that wraps and from there
we return the app context provider and
we also exported the entire context
so now in the meals we want to access
that
entire context so let me go back to
readme
and not only that
but we want to invoke the used context
and pass in the app context so import
both things
passing app context into use context and
then we'll get back what will get back
that value so whatever we place in the
value prop in the provider and then for
time being i'll just cancel log it
and we should see the hello
in the browser devtools so let's
navigate to the meals here
then we want to
go on the top and import both things so
import then use context that is coming
from the react and then we also want to
get the app context so import
app context
and we want to go with
from and of course we're looking for the
context so this is going to be
right outside of the directory the
components one and then let's grab the
used context invoke it and pass in the
app context so const this is going to be
the result we're getting back so that is
equal to use
context and we pass in the app context
and now let's simply log
and i know it's probably not a big deal
to see the hello
but once i show you something
you'll see why this is so powerful
so let me navigate to the browser i'm
going to open up the devtools and that
is also something why i want to use
the big browser window because it's
going to be easier to see
actually our console so let me refresh
and yep now we have the hello
and now you're probably wondering okay
what's the big deal well the big deal is
that we can turn hello
into something more meaningful so if i
navigate back to the context
it's a prop the value one and at the
moment i'm just passing the string
however we can change this around and we
can say that it's going to be an object
so first we need to set up the curly
braces effectively that means okay we're
going back to the javascript line so
either we can set up some kind of
expression here for example variable or
i can just simply pass in the object and
i can go with
name and then john
and also let's add a roll
and we'll set it equal to a student
let's say that
and now in the meals this is what we
should see
so let me again refresh
and we have name john and then a role
student and now we can put two and two
together if we can pass in the object
that means that instead of the app
provider we can set a bunch of
functionality which effectively is
something we're going to do so we'll set
up some functions then we'll pass down
we'll set up some state variables that
will pass down and effectively
any of the components in our application
will be able to access it
just by grabbing use context as well as
the app context and again i know i've
said this
10 million times already but this is
extremely extremely powerful concept
because it saves us a lot of mental
energy
because we can set up the code in one
place and then import it in any of our
components all right and before we
start talking about the data fetching
and react now let me also show you how
we can save on one import
in the components that are going to
consume our data
so if you remember the previous video we
needed to import two things the use
context and app context in the component
and then passing the app context in the
use context
what also we can do is set up a
custom hook now
let me just make it very clear the
previous
example is not
incorrect there's just
a better way where we can have one line
of code
and in order to set up we need to create
a custom hook which is also something
that we can do we just need to make sure
that the
name of the hook starts with use
now the name is really up to you in my
case i'm going to go with use global
context and as you can see we're setting
that up in the context.js and we're
exporting this right away so we go to
export const
then whatever is the name of the hook
and now notice the functionality we
return from this hook
from this function what we return
use context we invoke it and we pass it
in the app context
now where did we see that one before
over here
so we grab both of those things
in the context.jsx and remember that
both of them are already present we
imported the use context and we set up
the app context in the context.js
and then we just go with use context app
context and we're returning from that
hook now as a result we can import the
custom hook instead in any of our
components and then invoke it again
the setup is almost the same we're just
saving one line of code which in the
long run if you have let's say 100
components
makes a lot of sense so let's try this
one out i'm gonna navigate back to the
context one let's scroll up and it
doesn't really matter where you set it
up but i always prefer doing that right
before the export here
and now let's go with that custom hook
again remember we already imported the
used context from react so that is not a
custom hook that's the one that comes
with react which allows us to access the
context
and let's go with export
const
and then use global context and say not
of course you can pass it here as well
it's just i prefer this way and then
it's going to be a function and then
from this function what we simply want
to do is go with return
use context and then pass in the app
context
now let's try it out
in the meals so let me navigate back
and then instead of these two suckers
we'll remove the first one and we'll
change what we're getting from the
context we'll simply go use
global online context
and now let's invoke
so use
global context
context let's invoke that and again the
result in the
devtools should be exactly the same
so i'm going to navigate back again i do
need to refresh and check it out
we still have the object with the
properties of name and raw
and with this in place
we have successfully set up the
structure to consume our data
from the context.js and what that means
is that we'll just have to set up the
entire logic in the context.js and then
each and every time
we want to
get
the data again we're talking about the
state variables or functions that we
want to invoke we'll just use use global
context and we'll cherry pick
which info we want to get from the
context jsx which again is extremely
extremely powerful concept
because it saves us time and mental
energy in the long run and now let's
talk about another
extremely important topic
and that is data fetching in react and
let's start with the most pressing
questions first
where and how
so essentially we can fetch data in any
of our components
however in our case
since we'll pass this down
we want to do that in the context
but yes
if you want to set up
some data fetching in search component
you can do it the same way as i'm about
to show you in the context.js and the
same goes for any component you
create so hopefully that is clear
now how we fetch data in react well we
want to use use effect
hook because it allows us to control
when
we're actually going to fetch data
so if you remember from the previous
videos
use effect is a hook that runs after
every render by default so by default it
runs after every render however
it also has this cool feature
called the pen and zero
which we pass right after the callback
function
so
when it comes to use effect effectively
we invoke the hook we pass in the
callback function and then this callback
function whatever code is in there is
going to be invoked
after
every render
again that is by default if we pass this
dependency array
and if we leave it empty then it's just
going to run that callback function
when the component mounts or in the
other words when the component
loads
now we do need to understand that when
it comes to context
essentially it's only going to load once
because it's in the root of our
application take a look at the index one
notice so we have this app provider
that's the one that we're exporting from
the context and therefore this is going
to load
once we open up the application again
i'm not talking about the re-renders
that possibly
might
happen after that i'm just talking about
that initial load and that's the one
that we actually get
from this empty dependency array
so when we set up
the empty dependency array in the use
effect essentially that means it's only
going to run when that component in our
case app provider
loads or mounts
now
we can also pass here
some values and then it's going to run
every time
the value changes but let's not worry
about it
i just want to make it very clear that
when it comes to data fetching
we for sure need to pass in that
dependency array and i'll show you in a
few videos
what essentially is going to be result
if we don't do that let's not worry
about it right now and you can start
simply by setting up some kind of
console log in there
so go to context.jsx
import use effect
then invoke it pass in the callback
function set up the empty dependency all
right and then in my case i'm just going
to say aph data here now once that is
done then i'll cover one more gotcha
that we need to remember about this
callback function and then i'll lay out
the steps that i'm about to take in next
video
so first let me navigate to context.jsx
i want to get the use effect
and i want to
actually invoke it as well
so in here we want to go with use effect
so that's the hook that's coming from
react
then we want to invoke it right away so
let's say use effect
let's set up the callback function like
i said empty dependency array
and then in here let's just say
console log and
fetch data here let's save that and now
let me navigate to the browser
and check it out now of course i have
the console log here
now
what is the gotcha that i was
referencing before well it's following
when it comes to this callback function
it cannot return a promise so you cannot
turn this into a sync function because
if you remember by default the moment
you set up
a function to be async it returns a
promise and react is not okay with that
so we cannot turn this into a sync
function now why am i saying that well
because when it comes to fetching data
effectively we have two approaches we
can use dot then or we can use async
await
so when it comes to that then if that's
the approach that you
prefer you can easily set up the code
right here instead of the callback
function you can for example go with
fetch api so you go to fetch
let me write here fetch then the url
then we go here with that then and then
you know the rest so you can definitely
do it here now if you want to go with
async await essentially you have two
options
you can set up the function here
inside of this callback function and
then invoke it
or you can set up the function outside
and then invoke it
again
the reason why we need to do that is
because we cannot turn this one into a
sync function and then call await so we
need to set up a separate function so
hopefully we are clear on this and now
let me show you the challenge that i
have for you so now that we know that
we'll use used effect
to fetch our data
i want you to try fetch data now
you can use fetch api or axios that is
really up to you that is irrelevant
first i'll show you the fetch api
approach since that is built in
and then i'll switch to axios and this
is
another hot button issue because every
time in tutorial i use fetch api i get
comments why i'm not using axios and
then once i switch the axios i get
people asking why we're not using fetch
api
look
just pick the one that you use and
you'll be good to go
there are not going to be that many
differences so pick either fetch api or
axios just remember that with axios we
do need to install it and this is
something that of course i'm going to do
in a few videos
and you can use any url that's why i
have here from any url in the use effect
callback function so again you just need
to remember that if you're using that
then it's one approach if you're using
async await then it's going to be
another approach and for time being just
log the result
just log it you don't have to do
anything complex just log the result try
to set it up and in the following video
i'll show you my solution
and before we continue let me just
mention that in this video i'll use
fetch api
and if you're not familiar with fetch
api or you just need to
jog your memory
in the readme i shared a awesome
article by free code camp
and basically i'm going to use the
random user api and the way it works
this is the url
and then
essentially just returns a random user
again the structure here is not
particularly important since that's not
what we're going to use in project i
just ended up using this url because
it's pretty short
and straightforward
and then the way i set up the logic like
i said in the use effect i set up the
fetch data function because again i know
i've said this before already but we
cannot turn the callback function into h
sync since i want to use a weight that's
why i created a sync function so fetch
data a sync function and then since
we're working with asynchronous requests
i just set up the try catch as well just
keep in mind that when it comes to fetch
api
this doesn't really
worry about the errors unless they're
network errors and that's one of the
differences between the fetch api and
axios which effectively we're going to
use in the following videos
so in here i went with response await
fetch then passing the url
and then we need to turn this into a
json so i waited for response.json
got back to data and then logged in and
also just in case logged the error and
right below where i set up the function
i invoked it as well and once i set up
the function
in the app provider also showcase how we
can
move it outside of the callback function
because essentially that is going to be
our approach
in the upcoming videos so now let me
navigate to the context
and then for now i just have this
console log here let me remove it let's
go with const fetch
data is equal to async
that's our function
now fetch api is built into the browser
so we don't need to import anything we
want to go with try and catch let's come
up with const
response is equal to a weight
fetch now let me grab the url
and then let me set it up as a string of
course
now we have a weight okay that's
beautiful then const data is equal to
await and then response json let's
invoke it again and now let's just log
it so console
console
and then log and then let's pass in the
data now let's do the same thing in the
error we just want to change what we're
logging
over here and we have the function
that's awesome
but of course
for anything to work we also need to
invoke it
so we go with fetch data here now again
let me navigate to the browser and check
it out and here i have this giant object
again
we're not really concerned
what we're getting back the idea is just
to showcase how we fetch data so that's
the first step after that we'll set up
the state variables and all that and now
let me also showcase how we can move the
functionality outside of the callback
function so this is definitely one
approach that you can use
but in our case
we're actually going to set it up
outside and then we'll invoke it inside
of the use effect
effectively i just prefer this approach
better now there are times when you want
to do that and use effect but
again in this case it doesn't really
matter so let me take this outside
so again i'm talking about the
function the fetch data function
um now let's see whether everything
still works yep i still get back the
results so we are in good shape okay and
once we're familiar how we can fetch
data react
now let's take a look at the api we're
going to use for this project
and before i show you
the documentation as well as the urls i
actually have a challenge for you
so either you can follow this link
or just go to your search engine and
type mealsdb
regardless you will hit this link and
then get familiar with docs so try to
understand on your own
what the api offers
and more importantly get two urls
get the one
that allows us to search meal by name
as well as the random one now here's the
hint
in the docs
this part is missing
so either you'll have to add it manually
and you'll see why in a second
or just take
the url
place it in the browser and then copy it
so again you have two approaches i
usually prefer the second one i just
find it faster than typing and then in
the context jsx
set up two variables now in my case i'm
going to call them all meals url and
random meal url and assign the
corresponding values
so as you can see
in here
we're searching meals by name and this
is going to be our all meals url at
least in my case and then the random
meal url
is going to have this value again this
is the challenge go to docs get the urls
get familiar with documentation
and in next video we'll do it together
okay and as far as the api we'll use
this one
so i believe the official name is the
meal db
and effectively we just want to navigate
to the documentation
and as you can see they just provide a
bunch of urls
so some of them
you need to be a patron and some of them
are for free so these are the two that
we're going to use we're going to go
with search meal by name and we also use
this one look up full meal or no sorry
look up a single random meal
got carried away over here and just to
showcase what we're getting back let me
just copy this one
let me go to the browser and check it
out so effectively we'll get back the
object in there there's going to be an
array by the name of meals and then each
meal
is essentially a object itself with
bunch of properties now of course this
is already a full name
if let's say we change this around and
just go with a
we'll get more items so now as you can
see we have more meals that are again
objects in that array and then we've got
an id we've got a image and as you can
see
a bunch of other stuff as well
so that is as far as the
search meals by the name
now another option that we have is look
up a single random meal and what's
really cool that actually they send back
that one random meal but it's still
structured as an array and for somebody
who built the application that is
actually very nifty because you don't
have to change anything as far as the
logic on the front end so if i copy and
paste notice i still get back that one
meal correct but the structure is still
the same
and
if you have been setting up applications
with api and front end you know that
it makes things easier if you don't have
to restructure your application based on
the urls coming from the same api now
again there's multiple variations of
course there's cases where it's not
possible to always have pretty much the
same structure but in this case this is
super nifty
so now we just want to take those two
urls and set it up in the context so now
let me navigate back to our project
and then i'm gonna go to context.js i'll
take a look
um most likely i'll just do it above
here where we have the context
and then let's come up with those two
variables so
my case is going to be
all
meals
url
and then the value will be this one over
here so that's the one where we'll pass
in the search value and for now i'll
just leave it as a of course eventually
it's going to be dynamic and the second
one will be that random one
so let me navigate here
and then again let's come up with that
variable name in my case it's going to
be random
meal and then url and then let's pass in
the value
all right add up next we want to
refactor our fetch data function where
first we want to switch to the axios
library and as i know if you're not
familiar with the library or
you just need to jog your memory here's
an awesome article
by free code camp and also we want to
switch the url to the get meals by name
one remember it was stored in the url
variable
and the steps are following we want to
install axios
so we can do it over here where we have
the packages
then we want to import it in the
context.jsx
and as far as refactoring i'm going to
change the name
of the function
i will switch from fetch api to axios
then i'll add the url parameter
because
we will invoke the same function
multiple times with a different url
eventually so we might as well do that
right now and i'll pass in
the all meals url so we'll switch to all
meals url and lastly just log the
response if you get stuck feel free to
take a peek at my solution below so
let's refactor our fetch data so the
first step is going to be installing
axios
i'm going to navigate to this tab and
then let's type the name of the library
of course it is axios we want to install
and as far as the brief intro axios
effectively is a http library that makes
our life easier especially as your
project grows and you have more complex
requests
and we want to import that in the
context.jsx and then i'll show you how
basically our factor the application so
let's start here
by navigating to the context jsx
and then we want to import the axios
import axios from and then we're looking
for the axios library and then as far as
refactor
let's take a look at the readme
essentially
we want to switch
from the
fetch api to the axios and i also want
to change
right away the name
so instead of fetch data i'm going to go
with fetch meals
i'll pass in the url so instead of hard
coding the url i'll pass it as a
parameter and again the reason for that
is because we'll invoke the fetch meals
multiple times and based on the
conditional pass in the url
and in here we just go with a weight and
axios so we don't need to turn this into
a json and we just log the response now
axios does have a kind of more complex
response so we'll actually have to pull
out the data but let's not worry about
it right now we want to invoke fetch
meals and then we want to actually pass
in the
all
meals url now of course in your readme
it's going to be already there and once
we do that we should be in good shape
so let's try this out in the context i
already have the axios okay so that is
done now let me find my fetch data
i'm going to call this fetch
meals
then i'll pass in the url that's going
to be name of my parameter
and instead of console logging the data
we'll take a look at the response
and then instead of fetch we're going to
go with axios
and here we'll pass in the url so
instead of hard coding this
like we did previously
we'll pass in the url then let's keep on
moving and now we want to pass in the
all meals
url let's save it
and let's take a look at the browser so
in here there's a complaint that import
from axios blah blah let's see whether
refresh is going to help
and nope
that's weird maybe i was just too busy
talking and i actually didn't install
the library so let me double check
i have dev dependencies okay and then
yeah i have nothing here so let me go
back to
the installer and let me look for axios
one more time that's what happens when
you talk too much so let me install the
package and now everything should work
as expected
so now let's take a look at the browser
let me refresh
and then if everything is correct and of
course fetch data is not
defined because i forgot to change the
name my bad so let me navigate back to
my context
and then here of course
i
change the name so it should be fetch
meals instead of
fetch data
let me save for the third time yep and
now everything works
now when it comes to actuators like i
said the response is more complex
so in here
we actually get the config we've got
data as you can see it's a giant object
now what we're interested is this data
property
so
if we are successful
then data that we're getting back from
the api from the server is going to be
located in the data property
now like we covered already before
the way the api sends back the data
there's a meals array so that doesn't
change it's just going to be located
in the data property and at this point
we have multiple options
either we can just destructure it or we
can go with response and then data now
keep in mind though
the value is in the meals
so still have to access that property
but i'm just showing multiple ways how
we can access it now i always actually
prefer
the the structure route where i just
type data and now i directly access the
data again let me say one more time and
now we should see again that meals array
which is an array off object and lastly
let me just showcase how we can access
error in the axiorys so i'm going to go
back to my fetch meals we're looking for
error object and more specifically we're
looking for
error dot response so that's where we
can access the error and in order to
showcase that i'm just going to go to
the all meals one i'm just gonna type
some gibberish here
and then if you take a look at the
console notice you'll have the error
and in this case you can take a look at
the error response as well so that
should do it for the axios
and now we can proceed to the next step
okay and up next let's set up the meals
state variable and just render something
in the meals component now before i
continue let me just mention that if you
did also
change the value in the url in the
previous video just to see the error
please make sure that it's back to the
original url otherwise the functionality
is not going to work as far as the setup
we want to go with import use statehook
in the context
then we want to set up the state
variable
at least in my case i'm going to go with
meals and remember that it returns an
array with two values the meals value
and the
function that controls that and then we
wanna set the state variable
from our fetch meals function remember
we're getting the meals from the api and
remember the structure of the response
and we want to use set meals
to set our state variable equal to that
data
then we want to pass the meals down to
our entire application and remember we
do that in the value prop and we want to
structure the meals in the meals
component lastly we want to iterate over
the meals
log each meal
and then render something on screen
again it doesn't really matter what you
render
as long as we can see that we're getting
the data we are correctly iterating over
and
we have something on screen we're in
good shape as always if you get stuck
feel free to peek at my solution below
all right and as far as my solution i'll
start by importing use state in my
context jsx
so let me add this over here
then i'll set up that state variable by
the name of meals and remember we get
back the array we write away the
structure
this is going to be the value and this
is the function that controls that value
initially the value will be empty array
and then in the fetch meals
remember
the array is actually in the meals
property
so there's a
data object
in there
we have the meals property and in there
we have the array
so
we run set meals this is going to set
our meals state variable and we want to
pass it down to the entire application
that's why in the value
instead of the name and
whatever it was the role i believe we'll
pass down the meals and then in the
meals component we'll destructure it
remember the setup is already in place
we just need to change what we're
looking for since we're passing down the
meals instead of the name and the roll
now of course we're looking
for that property in the emails
component and then lastly let's set up
the return where i'm going to go with
section
now technically you don't have to add
section we'll worry about the css in the
following videos but i'll write away
gold section since that's what i'm going
to use but you can also use div of
course
then we'll iterate over the array
and then for every
item
in my case i'm going to call it single
meal that's going to be that object i
want to log it i want to see the proper
issue that we get back
since we'll have to destructure them
and
at least in my case i'm going to return
a heading 4. so if everything is correct
i should get i believe 25 heading 4s
on the screen so let's try this out
first i want to go to context
jsx
i will look for
use state
then i'll set up that state variable so
meals
and then set meals so that's the
function of course that controls it use
state and i'll start with empty array
because
remember we'll be iterating over
and initially if you'll set it equal to
null then the functionality is not going
to work because it takes time to fetch
those meals and i'll talk about the
loading
and also if we get back nothing from the
api
what to do then so we'll cover those
conditions but just remember that yes we
do need to start with empty array
then
let's use the set meals and then pass in
data
and then meals that's where the emails
are located and now i believe we can
just
remove the console log then instead of
these two suckers
we want to pass down the state variable
let's save it and then lastly
in the meals component
first i want to grab it
so instead of this context i'm going to
destructure meals and now let's iterate
over where first we want to go with
section
then inside of the section
we'll iterate over the list so let's go
with meals dot map
and we pass in the callback function
and i'll reference
each and every item there the object as
a single meal and what i'm returning
from this map function well for now i'm
just going to go with heading 4
and single
meal and then let's also log it since
we'll use those values in the following
lecture so let's go with single meal
let's save it and like i said if
everything is correct
i should see a bunch of single meals on
the screen
and we do and also
notice over here yes there are some
warnings about the key prop and all that
we'll worry about it in a second for now
i just want to showcase that these are
the values
that we get back for every object and
they should match what
they should match this correct so this
is also what we can see in the browser
and if you have the same result now we
can move on to the next step okay up
next let's display a nice card
for every meal that we have in the array
and the way it's going to look like
so i'll add right away classes for css
but like i said
i'll do the styling in a separate video
so if you already copied
these styles
you're good to go
if you didn't then don't worry if it
looks somewhat ugly in the beginning
we'll worry about the
css
in the following videos so first
i want to grab the properties from the
single meal now how do i know that those
properties are there well because we
logged them
in the last video correct
and we can also of course see them in
the browser if we just provide the url
and the properties that i'm interested
are
id meal
which is going to be the meal id
then i also want to get the title
and notice how i'll pull out the
property but i'll right away give it an
alias just so it's easier for me
to work with the value now do you have
to know of course you can still use the
property name that comes from the api
and also i want to get the image the
property for the image is this one
and yes i'll give it an alias of image
so i'll set up the section center for
the entire section but like i said you
can also set up a div if you want and as
far as the return i'm going to return a
article and then when it comes to react
since it wants to keep the track
of all the changes that are taking place
we do need to provide a key prop
which needs to be a unique value now
technically you can get away by grabbing
the index over here if you're familiar
with map you know that the second
parameter we get by default is the index
so you can also pass it here but it's
not suggested if
the data is going to be changing so if
you're going to be
making some kind of manipulations with
the data so therefore
it's always suggested to have something
unique and in our case that something
unique is the id
then we want to add a class name of a
single meal and i'm not going to repeat
the whole deal about the css
and we want to display the image now
with the image for now i'll just go with
this style
and width 200 so effectively we're
setting up the inline styles here
simply because otherwise those images
are going to be massive
so yes the css is coming up so for now
this is just temporary
now again if you have the entire css you
don't need to worry about it just add
the class name of img and then right
after the image we have the footer where
it will display the title and also the
like button now the icon for the like
button will set up in the following
videos for now let's just right click me
and then if everything is correct we
should see some images some titles
and all that cool stuff
so let's start working on that where
first
navigate back to the meals here
and
i'm not going to switch back to the
browser and showcase where i'm getting
the properties again i believe i
showcased that quite a few times so
first i want to pull them out out of the
single meal and yes each object has them
then we want to go with string meal and
yes the names are a little bit funky but
we'll just live with that we'll just
give it an alias and
we'll move on and then the last one is
the
string meal
and then i believe it's thumbnail and
that is equal to a image at least that's
my alias so i'm going to set it equal to
single meal now we nicely destructured
it and now let's worry about the return
and i'll say not i forgot to add here
the class name not class
i'm going to go with class name that is
equal to section
center and then in here it's not going
to be a heading 4 will actually go with
a article
and then another thing that's not giving
me auto complete so
let me type it here article as well
we do want to add a class i believe here
and the class will be
single meal
so class name is equal to single
and then meal and let's also add that
key
prop that
basically is looking for
the unique value in our case that is
going to be id
meal and then once we have this one in
place inside of the article we want to
go with img
so let's set up the image let's set up
the source and
insert it equal to the image to the
alias
that we gave to the string meal and then
the thumbnail
and then let's also add the class name
right away as well and we're gonna go
with img let's close it and then right
below
image we're gonna go with footer
and then inside of the footer let's set
up a heading five
setting five and then in here we wanna
display the title and right next to it
we'll have a button
and in here let's set up again a class
name it's going to be a like btn and
then for now it's going to be clicking
but eventually we'll set up a nice icon
as well
and now let's see what we have as far as
the result in the browser and of course
as i was setting up i forgot that i need
to add essentially inline style so let
me go with style
and in here i want to
go with with and we need to remember
that since it's javascript this needs to
basically be a string and now let me go
back and yep now it's more manageable
again it's not pretty
but at least we can see some images
titles
as well as the like button and with this
in place now we can move on to the next
step okay and now let's worry about the
styles
now like i already said
i believe ten thousand times if you have
the styles you can just skip this video
if you don't then we'll type these
styles together and first let's just
start by navigating to app.css
and i want to set up the comments so
usually what i do is
i set up the css in the order that i
have my components so eventually we'll
have the search web favorites will have
the meals and we'll also have the model
and therefore
i'll do the same thing in the app css
where essentially i want to start with
search then it's going to be
favorites
and then we want to go with meals
and lastly there's going to be a model
so
the search and favorites
are coming up
for now we'll just worry about the
emails and we'll start by setting up
that section center and you know what
also i think it's going to be easier if
i just place
the tab over here so that way we can
right away see what we are doing so
start with that section center class and
you know what
i'll just make it here for now of course
eventually i'll set it back to what it
was start with section center we do want
to add some padding here
and i'm going to go with three rem stop
bottom and zero left and right then we
want to go with with and this is the
case where i'm going to use
my
css variable which is i believe set to
90 view widths
so essentially the
percent of the screen
and again the reason why i prefer this
is variables because that way
effectively i can just set up the value
in one place reuse it in multiple places
and if i ever want to change something
well then i need to change it in one
place then i'll also set up the max
width so this is for the big screen
essentially i don't want any of these
components spanning the entire screen i
want to set up some kind of max width
which i believe
again if you want to double check that
just navigate up to the css variables i
just don't want to do that since i know
that some people find it annoying but i
believe it was like 11 20 pixels or
something along those lines again we're
looking for the variable
max with and now we just want to place
it in the center so we're going to go
here with margin 0 and then although you
know what
these warnings are
a little annoying so check it out now of
course our
container is always going to have the
width of
90 of the screen
but it's never going to be bigger than
the 1120 so it's always going to stay
like this and then we'll write from the
get go set it to display grid
and i'll add some kind of gap and it's
actually going to be the same
for the rows and columns and i'm going
to go with two rems i just always prefer
pretty much that type of setup
and since we're on a roll when we also
right away
set up
the column layout
for the bigger screens and we'll do that
with the media
query and we'll go with media screen and
let's go with min width and i'm going to
choose the value
776 pixels
and then
in order to speed this up a little bit
i'll copy and paste that's going to be
my section center and then we're looking
for the property grid template and then
columns we'll set it equal to one
fraction and one fraction so once we get
to 776
we should have a two column layout
and
as you can see
that is clearly the result and then we
also want to add one for the bigger
screen which most likely
i'll showcase right away as well so in
this case it's going to be 992
and now we're looking for a three column
layout now as i know i'm fully aware
that we can
change the syntax here to let's say
repeat but i just think that for this
project it's good enough if we just
repeat those fraction values so now let
me make it bigger and notice we have a
three column layout and now let's worry
about that single meal
we are pretty much done with the
container now we want to go with single
meal and of course we're talking about
that
card
we'll start with the background property
and we'll use again the css variable
with the value of white and yes pretty
much the actual value is also the white
color then we want to add the text color
and this is going to be for the button
so
heading already should have the text
color set in css but since i want to
have the same color for the button i'm
going to go here with color then var and
then we're looking for
text color so that's the easiest
variable then let's add some border
radius
or radius
and this one will set it equal to again
css variable so far and then we're
looking for border and then radius
like so and then we'll add a little box
shadow a transition both of them see if
there's variables and then once we have
already single meal we'll just change
that box shadow so let's start here the
box shadow and let me scroll up just so
it's easier for you to see so we're
looking for a box shadow property that
one will be equal to a
shadow
to css variable and then we also want to
add a transition simply because we want
that change to happen over time and
therefore we'll go with var and then
transition like so and then
let's select again that single meal and
let's set up that hover effect so single
meal
and then as we're hovering
we want to change that box shadow over
here and once we save it we should
notice that as we're hovering
effectively we're getting that
darker
box shadow
now one thing that i want to mention
remember in the previous
video we added that class of image
now notice that this is a global class
which adds a width of hundred percent a
this block block as well as object fit
so now once we have
the structure in place as far as the
columns and everything we can actually
remove that inline style so now let me
navigate back to the meals and you know
what let me just minimize this for now
and then remember we added this style
and i said that it's going to be
temporary so now once we have the
columns of course we can set it back and
you'll notice that of course the
image is spanning all across and this is
exactly what we wanted
so now let me navigate back to app css
make this one smaller and maybe this one
also a little bit smaller just so we
have a little bit more real estate
and then we actually want to style the
image right away so we have that global
class yes that's awesome but we also
want to add some additional styles and
therefore i'm just going to go with img
so effectively i'm targeting that
element first i'm going to set up some
kind of height which in my case is going
to be 15 rem and now let's talk about
the border radius notice here
how we set the border radius for the
entire card
but we also need to set it for the image
now i don't want the border radius
for
every corner i actually only want for
the top left and top right in order to
do that we just need to go with border
radius and we need to add
top and then left
and yes you guessed it in order to set
up the right one we just need to change
this value around and now we should
notice that the top
left and top right corners
are actually around it and then lastly
as far as the
image we just want to add cursor pointer
because
in the final application we'll be able
to click on image and then we will
actually display it in the model then
let's style a heading 5 here so single
hyphen meal and we're looking for the
heading 5 and in here let's add a
padding 0 margin zero because there is
some default
uh margin padding as far as the
typography let's save and then let's
worry about the footer so single
meal
and we're looking for the footer
in here let's add a padding right away
so padding is going to be one rem's 1.5
rms then we'll display it as flex
so display equals flex we want to align
the items in the center
so say align items center we want to go
with justify content and space between
so this effectively is just going to
push them as far as possible from each
other
so let's say here's space
between and then lastly we also want to
go with flex wrap and wrap so if there's
not enough space we just want to wrap it
to the next line so flex
wrap
and equals to wrap and even though we
don't have the icon we might as well
style the button since we're working
with the css so let's say here
like button that was the class name and
then we're looking for the background we
want to go with
transparent
and we want to add the border also
transparent so take this value here
copy and paste and then after that let's
increase the font size again for text
it probably won't look that good but
once we set up the icon it's going to be
good enough we're going to go with 1.5
rems so increase that then cursor
pointer and again the transition so
cursor pointer and for transition just
so i can save a little bit on typing
i'll just grab the value from the single
meal and set it here and as we're
hovering what do we want to do
well
let's add some transition so like button
hover
and then as we're hovering
essentially
we wanna
change the color to red
so color is going to be equal to a css
variable and the value is red dark and
also we want to transform so let's go
transform and let's translate
in the y direction and since i want to
lift it up like two pixels i'll say
negative two pixels so now check it out
as we hover over the like button
we actually lift the text up a little
bit and essentially that is the css
for
our meals component
and while we're still on a topic let's
also knock out the icon
and effectively for my project i prefer
react icons library for a variety of
reasons first of all it offers tons of
options and second it's very easy to
work with library because you get back
the component the react component
and as a result you can add the class
you can style it directly and all kinds
of cool things
so if you want to utilize the search
engine just look for react icons or you
can just follow the link that i provided
in the readme
and once you
get there you'll see this documentations
page like i said uh you have tons of
options so these are all the libraries
that
you
can work with and if you want to search
for specific icons so let's say in our
case if we're looking for
thumbs up icon
just type here in the search box and i
believe i used this one over here
now don't quote me on that
essentially i will showcase that in a
second but
i believe that's the one that i used and
just keep in mind that
once you choose the icon you also need
to remember which library is it from
because when you import
the icon
and as i say not the syntax is following
where you go with the name you also need
to provide the library
otherwise
essentially you'll get the error so now
let me try it out in our application
where first i want to go and install the
package
i believe the package name was a react
icons and i should get the suggestion
hopefully yep there is that's the
package we want to install
then we want to navigate of course to
the meals that's where we are setting up
that icon
so meals over here and now let me grab
right away the value so again let me
search for it
and that's the one that i want to use
notice
the name was copied
to our clipboard and then we want to go
with import
get the icon from and then we're looking
for react icons but very important you
need to add the library in my case that
is bootstrap and then where we have the
like button instead of just click me i'm
just going to go with this component and
since i want to save a little bit of
time on typing i'll just copy and paste
the component
now let's save it and take a look at the
result in the browser
and now check it out instead of the text
we have a nice icon from the bootstrap
library beautiful and once we're done
with our meals component well almost
done there is
a little bit of functionality coming up
but the
main
setup is done
before we continue i also want to
showcase why we want to use a user
effect and feel free
to just watch the video
i mean you don't have to follow along
because i will purposely set up the
infinite loop
just to kind of underscore the point
that i was making previously so if i
navigate to
context js
and if i decide to be a rebel and then
instead of
using
the dependency array and for now leaving
it empty basically
invoking this callback function only
when the initial load happens only when
the component mounts i will actually get
a infinite loop so let me showcase that
let me remove that dependency array let
me save it let's navigate to the browser
and then more specifically we're looking
for the network tab
and notice over here
notice the amount of requests
that are we making
so why is that happening well first let
me go back and actually add here a
empty array
let's save it and then
the reason why is that happening is
because
we need to remember that when it comes
to use state every time we change the
value of the year state we trigger
re-render
so now let's go step by step
when it comes to
our fetch functionality
on the initial render when the component
mounts
we invoke use effect correct now instead
of that use effect
the callback function we fetch data and
change their values for the meals
so there is initial render
and instead of the fetch meals we
change the
value for the meals
state value
now what happens when we change the
value we trigger another
render we trigger re-render
now what happens in that next render
well we repeat the steps
essentially we repeat the steps
2 and 3 in here
so
since we triggered that re-render inside
of the
fetch data we go back to the step 2 and
then step 3. that's why you'll have so
many requests and eventually the browser
will run out of those requests and
effectively crash
because you have infinite loop
since we
trigger rerender when we change the
value of the state variable that's why
we need to be very careful
when we set up the use effect and
refresh data keep in mind if you just
have simply console log then of course
it's not going to happen because you're
not triggering that re-render
but if inside of
the fetch data or fetch meals whatever
fetch function you have if inside of
that function you change the state value
which is our case of course
then yes you need to make sure that
there is a dependency array and if
you're placing any values inside of it
you need to have a clear idea
when this callback function is going to
be
invoked otherwise you're risking setting
up the infinite loop and then like i
said eventually your browser will crash
and the same goes if you'll invoke the
function inside of the use effect so
this is the question that i get quite
often where
students say hey but why do we need use
effect why we can't just move fetch
meals outside of the use effect well
let's see you'll pretty much see the
same result again let me save and let me
navigate back and notice again we get
tons and tons and tons of requests
because we have infinite loop that's why
you always always want to fetch data
as of now of course things might change
but at the moment in react you always
always want to fetch data inside of the
user
and you want to make sure
that you start at least with the empty
dependency array and then eventually as
you add values that you have a good
understanding when this
callback function
is going to be invoked because remember
once we start adding values over here
we'll invoke this
callback function and all the code
inside of it
once the values
that we add there change and while we're
still working with the meals
let's also set up a loading check
as well as empty meals
effectively if we don't get any data
back from the api
first i guess let's start with loading
you see when it comes to data fetching
effectively
it doesn't happen instantly because it
is a synchronous operation now of course
it happens fast meaning in the human
time it's fast but it still
takes a little bit time
in the computer time and we can clearly
see that if we navigate to a network tab
and if we slow down the network so in my
case i'm going to go with fast 3g and
you'll notice that
initially there's nothing on the screen
we just have that empty array
and only after time we actually display
those meals
now in my opinion a better setup is if
we have some kind of loading condition
where essentially
we display something on the screen and
to showcase that i'm going to navigate
to a complete project and you'll notice
there that we'll have this loading dot
dot dot so effectively while we're
getting the data
we're just displaying to a user that hey
we're loading it and then once we get
the data then we display the emails
and the steps in order to set it up are
following first set up a
state variable by the name of loading at
least that's going to be my name and
default value is going to be false now
in the fetch meals
the first thing you want to do is set
loading to true
so as we start fetching meals we set
loading to true
then the last thing that we want to do
in the fetch meals is set loading to
false so once we're done fetching data
regardless whether we get back the data
or there's an error we want to set
loading to false
and then we want to add that loading
state variable to a value prop basically
we want to pass it down to our
application
in the meals jsx we want to grab the
loading variable and we want to set up
the condition
now it needs to be before our current
return so if loading is true then we
want to return loading dot dot
and then
once the loading is set back to false
then essentially we display
the array of meals and as far as my
solution
it's going to look something like this
or like i said there's going to be a
state variable in my case i'm going to
call this loading and of course there's
also going to be a set lowering function
the initial value
is going to be false and the notice in
the fetch meals the first thing that i
do will set loading to true
so that's when we start loading the data
and regardless whether we're successful
or there's an error we sit loading back
to false
we pass down loading to the entire
application so essentially we add it to
a value prop and then in the meals
i destructure it i say hey grab me
loading
and right before our current return
i go
if loading is true
so while we're loading what we want to
display we want to display section and
yes we do need to add a little bit of
style so i'm going to set it up as class
name section in there i'll set up a
heading 4
with the text of loading and essentially
that's it
and of course after that we have our
return
so the idea is that while we're loading
this is what we display
on the screen
so now let me set this one up or first
in the context i want to create that
state value and i'll purposely set it up
before meals that's just my preference
so const
and then loading
then we also want to go with set loading
now the initial value is use state and
we want to set it equal to
false
then in the fetch meals
let me call it so set loading
is equal to true
now let's copy and paste
and then at the very end of the logic
let me just set it up here as false so
we're done with the loading then we want
to pass this one down
so let's pass in the loading as well
and then in the meals we wanted to
structure it
so let me navigate back
to the meals jsx
and before or after the meals it doesn't
really matter i want to grab the loading
and before i return the array of items
before i return my cards that have
the
info about the meal i also want to set
up the
condition for loading so if i'm loading
there's going to be a different return
and as a result we'll have that loading
displayed while we're fetching the data
so near like i said there's going to be
a section with the class name of section
so we'll have to add a little bit of css
as well so let's go here with return
then section
let's add a class name right away in
this case the class name will be section
and then inside of it we're going to go
with a heading 4
and the text of loading data
so this is true
this return will be displayed and then
once this one is set to false
then we'll render
the array of meals
so let's try this out
where first i'm going to navigate to a
browser let me refresh and if everything
is correct we should see that loading
displayed on the screen
now we still do need to add css so let
me just see whether the functionality
works and
if everything is correct then we'll
proceed to css yep i can see the loading
displayed and i'll let me navigate back
to our application
we want to look for app css
and we'll have to grab some styles from
the section center
so that's already a modal i want to look
for section center and before the
section center i'll create a section
class and we'll grab some values here
from the section center so we want to
take padding with
max width as well as the margin
and
effectively there are two ways how you
can set it up so you can just copy and
paste the styles or there's another
approach if you want to save some lines
of code
so if you
are interested in the other setup we can
also add a comma here go with
section
and center so now we're reusing these
styles for both of these classes and
then when it comes to section center
we just add the extra styles that are
not included over here so that's another
way how we can set up the logic the
result is going to be exactly the same
where now we'll have a proper section
and in there we'll have that loading
condition
so before we display
the array of meals we'll also display
the heading 4 with the text of
data.loading and as i said we'll use an
extremely
similar setup
for the condition
if we get back no data from the api and
i think at this point we can just go
back to no throttling and up next let's
handle the case if
we don't get back any items from the api
and i think the easiest way to showcase
that is just by navigating to
and notice at the moment we're using
this all meals url
and since we have a search time of a of
course it returns
some data but what if i type some
gibberish over here let's say i'm going
to go with five a's let me save it and
then if we take a look at the meals app
i mean don't see anything on the screen
why well because we don't get back any
data and the reason for that is because
if we take a look at the
api we can see that yes if the search
matches some results we get back meals
array but
if
the search that we type
doesn't match any of the meals then we
get back meals as now and if you want to
see that just navigate to the api
copy
the url and just add some gibberish
after the text they provided so if i
just add s you'll notice that we have
here meals no
and we need to handle that case
especially because eventually there will
be a
search input so the user will be able to
type the search term and we want to
display if
the search term did not match any of the
meals in the api
as far as the setup
let me find the readme here
it's gonna go like this
again i'll have to scroll down a little
bit
we want to go with fetch meals
and
in the case of success so in the try
block we want to check if data meals is
truthy basically if it's an array it's
going to be evaluated to true in the if
condition
if it's equal to null then of course
it's going to be false if it returns a
true basically if it has some value
only then we want to
go with set meals and then data meals
so at the moment we're setting pretty
much
our state variable regardless
but we want to change it we want to set
up if else condition and only if
data meals
returns true then we want to set the
state meals as data meals otherwise we
want to set it equal to an empty array
in the state and then in the meals gsx
we want to check
if the length is less than one
meaning we're checking for empty array
and if that's the case again we want to
return a section
and in there i'll just type some error
text
now we want to place them in between the
loading and the current return again
this is very important because we start
with loading
then we want to display the error if
it's there and then we want to return
the
list off cards and as far as my solution
in the try block
i'm going to set up if else
in here i'll check if data means returns
true if it's evaluated to true if that's
the case then i'm going to go with set
and data meals
and if it's false then i'm going to go
with set meals and then pass in empty
array
and then we don't need to pass anything
down we're already passing down the
meals
in the value
but in the meals gsx we want to add
another condition where we're checking
length of the meals if it's less than
one same deal we want to return a
section
and in there we just want to provide
some error code and most likely i'll
copy this one since i'm too lazy to type
it from the scratch but i'm going to
worry about it once we get there so
first let me showcase how we can also
work with multiple files so if we click
on this plus we can pick which file we
want to display in my case i'm going to
go with context and i also want to
display
of the emails one because that's the
current file
that we're working in and then back in
the context like i said we just want to
set up the if and else condition we're
doing that in the try block so
technically it's not going to be an hour
since the api returns a status code of
200 which means that the request was
successful
it's just there's no data to return
so in here let's go with if and then
data meals
if it's true then we'll set our
state variable equal to that if not
then we'll go with set meals
and we'll just
set it as a empty array
then let's keep on moving
and we want to go to the meals of course
and here let's add that second condition
we'll say if
and then
meals length
is less than one what do we want to do
well we want to basically
return a text we just want to change the
value over here
so let me quickly
run back to the
readme and i'll grab these values so in
here
in the meals this is what we want to
return so copy and paste and we are good
to go so now let's try it out
where i'm going to navigate to the
application and if everything is correct
if you didn't change the search term
back to something that returned some
items we should see this error message
on the screen so now i want to navigate
back to the
context one
and here let's just fix it where i'm
going to go back to a now eventually
this will be dynamic again that is
going to be the case once we add the
search input so at the moment once we
fix yep everything is correct again we
have an array of meals and up next let's
work on the search component so in here
user will be able to type the search
term and if the term
matches any meals in the database of
course
they will be rendered on the screen and
also there's this option of clicking on
surprise me where we fetch a random meal
from the api and we'll start with the
structure
so first let's just get something on the
screen and then we'll worry about the
functionality so in the search component
the search jsx import use state and use
global context now please keep in mind
they're not coming from the same place
so one is coming from react and the
second one is coming from our context
then we want to set up a return and
don't worry about the css yes it's not
going to look pretty but
we'll go with header we'll add a class
of search container which of course
eventually will style in the header
there's going to be a form
and inside of the form we'll have the
input with form
input class type text
and then two buttons so right after the
input we'll have two buttons one with
class of btn
and type of submit and the second one
with the classes of ptm btn hipster and
type btn the last thing that i actually
forgot to mention over here
in the app
jsx
we want to
uncomment this correct
so
in the app.jsx
display
search
component and once you're ready to see
my solution proceed to the next video
okay
and i think i'm going to start actually
with the last step
so first
i want to go to app.jsx and i want to
remove that comment
so let me just remove the code and now
we should see
a search component yep
awesome then in the search let's start
by importing both of those things the
use state and use global context so
first let's start with import use
state
and that one is equal to react so
basically it's coming from react then
the second one is use global
context which is coming from our own
context so dot or i'm sorry two dots and
then we're setting up the context and
then like i said as far as the return
we're gonna go with header we'll add
right away a class of search container
so search
container and then inside of it we want
to go with the forum
so
as you can see this is an error it
should be header here
then let's set up that form component
sorry element i guess more properly
it's not going to have a class
but we will have the input inside of it
we'll set the type text
and i'll also right away add the
placeholder now technically you don't
have to but i'm going to go with type
then favorite
and meal
and also we want to add a class name
and this is going to be
form
input let's close it and then we want to
set up those two buttons so let's go
here with button
then type will be submit
and as far as the text i'm just going to
go here with search and also i want to
add a class
and it's going to be btn now copy and
paste and i'm just going to add
btn
hipster
the type will be
good old button
so go here with button and as far as the
text i think we're gonna go here with
surprise me so that should do it for the
general structure now let me take a look
yep and as you can see we've got a input
with two buttons now don't worry we'll
work on styles in the next video
and the reason why the buttons are
styled because
the
btn classes are already in the global
css
all right and up next let's style the
search component since we have
the structure in place and i guess i'm
going to start by just changing these
files around where first i want to open
up a new one
and
this is going to be app css and then
instead of the meals of course this will
be a search
since this is where we'll do all of our
work
so as far as the app css
we have the mono okay that's good
we already styled the meals we're not
gonna work with favorites we'll work
with search and this is the case where
again i'll move this sucker here just so
we can see what we're doing and let me
close
files for now
and also maybe let's make this one a
little bit smaller
and then let's start by just styling the
search container so let me grab the
class here
then i'll add some kind of height it's
going to be 5 rems after that we want to
go with background which will be equal
to the state variable of white
then we want to go with display flex
so essentially we're setting this up as
a flex box and we want to align all of
them in the center so we go with align
center and or i'm sorry align items
line items and that will be equal to a
center
then we want to
also place them
in the center horizontally so we'll go
with justify
and content
and that will be equal to a center so
once this is saved
we want to work with a form
so basically now we styled the
parent container now let's work with the
form now it doesn't have a clash so just
go with search
container and look for the form element
in here we'll add a width and you know
what since the values will be exactly
the same over here i'll just grab these
two so this is going to be the width of
container and the max width of container
let's save this and then we'll make a
form to be a flex parent as well so
display flex
and let's add a little bit of gap in
between the items so 0.5 rms and then
also let's go with flex wrap and then
that one is equal to a wrap so if
the size of the window gets smaller then
of course we wrap it to the next line if
you want to check it out
just make it smaller and you'll see how
we nicely wrap to a next line then we
want to style the form input so let's go
with search container then class of
form input
and here effectively
we want to set up some kind of max with
so this is not going to be bigger
than in my case 200 pixels we also want
to add a little bit of padding so let's
go here with padding and then let's set
it to
0.375 rms and then 0.75
rem's left and right so top bottom and
then left and right let's add a border
radius
or radius
and then
this will be again a state variable so
border radius and i also want to add the
background as well as deep border so
let's go with background that will be
equal again to a state variable
with a background color so this will
match whatever i have for the body
whatever gray color i have for the body
it will be the same and then lastly we
have a border here
where we're going to go with one pixel
solid and now i'm looking for one of the
gray colors so far
iphone hyphen gray
and 200 like so so save it
and then let's style the button
and the placeholder so
i mean we can i just style the
placeholder first
so in here let's say font family equals
to inherit
so now we're essentially inheriting the
value and also let's add a different
color so in this case it's going to be
equal to bar
and i think i'm going to go with gray
400 so just different shade of gray and
then lastly let's style the button so
we're going to go with search container
and then class of btn
and let's add a font size a little bit
smaller so i'm going to go with font
size and then
0.75 rams let's save it
and we're pretty much done with the css
so now we can jump back to the logic so
let me just add a tab in a proper place
and we'll continue
with the handle submit and handle change
logic okay so at the moment we have a
good looking search component with the
input as well as two buttons but there's
no functionality and first i want to add
handle change to the input so there's
going to be a state value that is
persisted between the renders and also i
want to handle submit because at the
moment you'll notice that once we click
on the submit effectively we
restart the entire application because
that is the default behavior for the
form
and here are the steps that i'm going to
take first create a
text state
variable
and then
we also want to set up two functions
handle change and handle submit in the
handle change we want to grab the
event.target.value
and please remember that
by default it gets the event as a
parameter and then we want to set that
to a new text value so this one will
have the set function and of course we
want to pass whatever we get back over
here into that set function
now once we're done with that we want to
add on change to the input and set it
equal to
the handle change
and then when it comes to handle submit
again we'll get back the object as a
parameter
and we'll just set up event prevent
default otherwise again we'll have that
default behavior where every time we'll
click on submit we'll just refresh the
application since the default behavior
of the form is sending a post request
and then we want to add on submit
to a form element and set it equal to
handle submit
okay and as far as my solution so i've
got text and set text the state value
the initial value is equal to an empty
string
then i created handle change passed in
the event since that's the parameter we
get by default settext event.target
value and the same deal with handle
submit where event comes as a parameter
and here i have event prevent default
now i forgot to mention in the previous
video that also for the input not only
we want to set on change
equals to a handle change but we also
want to pass in the value so value prop
and that is equal to a text
so as a result we get the controlled
input
where every time we'll pass something in
input the state will be updated and then
as a result between the renders will
also persist the state value and when it
comes to the form we want to go on
submit and pass the handle submit at the
moment we don't have more logic but it
will prevent that default behavior
so let's
set this one up where first i want to of
course navigate back to the search
component and then let's set up that
state value so we're going to go here
with const that's the whole purpose why
we grab the use state so we're going to
go here with text
and set
text
and then that one will be equal to use
state and we pass in the empty string
then let's set up those two functions so
const
and i'm looking for the handle
change
now i'll grab the event object
and then as far as the functionality
every time we'll type something in input
we're gonna go with set text
and we'll pass in the event dot target
dot value
and also let's set up the handle submit
so const handle
submit
and then same deal we grab the event
object now the deal here is to prevent
the default servant prevent
and then default let's invoke it and now
we just want to set up both functions so
let's start i guess with a handle submit
and we have a special prop for that we
go with on submit is equal to a
handle
and submit the same deal here
but we just need to add
a value prop as well so let's start here
with values equal to a text so now we're
grabbing the state value and then on
change so every time we'll type
something
in the
input we'll also update the state value
since we have the handle change so let's
go with on change
is equal to a
handle change like so let's save it and
let's take a look at the application so
first let's check the
submit notice now when we're submitting
we're not performing a default action
so we're not sending that post request
so that's already a good start since
we're not refreshing the application now
the second thing is as we're typing
we're actually persisting value in the
state and if you don't believe me just
navigate to the components and then if
we navigate to a search component notice
the state value and essentially as i'm
going to be
deleting
the gibberish from the input i'll have
the same result as my state value okay
and now let's set up the search logic or
essentially we can type something in the
input click on submit and if there are
no meals display will display error
remember that's the one that we set up
in the previous videos but if
there are some meals that are matching
the search term we nicely display them
so now connect the
search
input with the meals that we are
fetching
and in order to do that in the
context.js
first we'll need to create a new state
variable
in my case i'm going to call this search
term and the default value will be empty
string
then we right away want to combine
the
all meals url with the search term
so
prior to this we're all the time using
all meals url but remember this is a
hard-coded url so now i want you to
remove
that hard-coded value i believe it's a
and then when we invoke fetch meals in
the use effect i want you to combine all
meals url with a search term
then we also want to add search term to
a use effect dependency array so every
time that value changes we fetch
new set of meals every single time
then we want to pass the set search term
because once we create the
state value we also have the function
that controls it and we want to pass
this one down to
entire application now of course in our
case we'll grab it in the
search jsx so grab this function and
then in the handle submit if there's any
text
in the input then we want to set it as a
value
for the search term now optionally you
can also set text back to empty value
but that really comes down to the
personal preference
as far as my solution i created set
search term and search term so that's
the state value and that's the function
that controls it and then in the use
effect
i passed in
the
template literal
and i combined all meals url with the
search term now keep in mind again we
need to remove that hard-coded value of
a in the all meals url and i also added
search term to the dependency array so
every time we'll change the value of the
search term we'll perform a new fetch
request and the new value of the search
term is going to be used then we also
want to pass set search term
down to entire application so we need to
add it to a value prop and then in the
search jsx we wanted to structure it
we already have use global context so we
just grab it from use global context and
then in the handle submit i want to
check what is the value for the text
if it's empty
we're not going to do anything however
if it has some value we can just go with
set search term and pass in the text
like i said optionally you can set it
back to a empty string when it comes to
the text but
that really comes down to the preference
so let's start in the context.jsx first
i guess i want to remove that hard-coded
value here in the all meals url so
instead of a it's just going to be an
empty value
then we want to go with a
search term
search term and then comma
set search term set
search term and that was equal to a use
state and we pass in a empty string then
let's keep on moving we're not going to
change anything in the fetch meals
but we do want to refactor this one so
like i said we're going to go
with a template literal since now we'll
combine both values all meals url with
the search term so first let's access
all meals url and second let's grab that
search term
search
and term then we want to pass down the
function that controls it so let's go
with set
search term and now let's navigate to
the search jsx
first we want to grab it
so we're going to go here with const
we're getting back the object and we'll
invoke use
global context
and let's go here with set
search term and now let's set up that
condition so if there's any value in the
text
then we want to go with set
search term and we want to pass in the
text and optionally like i said i'll set
back the text to a empty value so now
let's navigate to the application and
see what is the result so first let me
refresh and let's take a look at the
network so notice here how we're
basically fetching
without any kind of value for search and
what's really cool that they do return
some default meals that is already a
awesome start and now let's try to
submit the form so i have here the input
i'm typing something and now i click on
search now i can see that we set it back
to an empty text so
technically our functionality works but
we're not performing a new request so
let me quickly take a look here at the
app provider
and i can see that i have the value in
the search term so now let's see why
we're not invoking new fetch request
and i think i know why so back in the
context
i didn't add the search term so this is
what happens if we don't add this to a
dependency array this will only run
the first time on the initial render now
in this case though if we add search
term then we're good to go
because now every time we'll change this
value the state value
will perform a new request now of course
in this case we didn't get anything back
so now let me go here and now notice
these are going to be all the values
with a and then if i type a b
these are the values that we're going to
get back
now
as i'm looking at it i think i rather
just
leave that
text
the state value for the input so let me
quickly now get back over here and okay
so this is optional this is up to you
and i'm just going to remove it so in
this case
every time we type and we search for
something we'll actually see
what
we just wrote
and we'll be able to make basically
modifications so in this case if i go
with ad
check it out these are the values
that i'm getting back and successfully
we have set up the search functionality
okay and up next let's work on fetch
random meal functionality so once the
user
clicks on the button surprisingly
we want to fetch the random meal and
here's my solution so in the context jsx
i'm going to create fetch random meal
and there there's going to be a
fetch meals so the same function we
already used before
we just passed all meals url plus the
search term in this case i'll just pass
in the random meal url and then i'll
pass it down to your entire application
effectively i'll set it up in a value
and then in the search
jsx i will destructure it
and for now
so change this around actually in the
following video because there's gonna be
some bugs but for now i simply wanna
invoke it
once we click on a button
so i'm going to set up a on click and
i'll pass in
fetch random meal and as far as the
result it's going to look something like
this notice we have all the meals and
then once we click
check it out we get our random meal
so let's set this one up we're in the
context.js
let me keep on scrolling
so i have my use effect
um
i think i'm gonna do it before the use
effect
and in here we'll just create that
function now the name is really up to
you in my case i'm going to go with
fetch
random
meal
that's a function and inside of it let's
just go with fetch meals and then pass
in
random
meal
and url let's save it
let's pass it down to the application so
fetch
random
meal
let's save that and then in the search
we wanted to structure it so fetch
random meal
and probably at this point just copy and
paste
since it's gonna be faster
and then where i have the surprise me
button
i'll add on click
and we'll pass in the fetch random meal
and now let's try it out
so i'm gonna go here to the application
click and yep we're getting the random
meal and again the cool thing
is that
when it comes to the api
the structure is the same yes we're
getting only one meal
but since it's set up in array we don't
need to change anything here in the
function in the
fetch meals function we still get back
to data
and in there we have meals array and now
we just set that meals right that one
random meal equal to our meals state
variable and then eventually of course
we
display it on a screen now there are
some bugs
and we'll fix them in next video but the
general structure works yes we can fetch
random meals once we click on the
surprise me button so our basic
functionality works as expected however
like i mentioned at the end of the
previous video
we actually have a bug in our code and i
think it's going to be easier to
showcase it because i actually didn't
pay attention that in the search jsx
i
still have the code to basically wipe
the value and effectively the bug is
following search term you know the one
that we're using
to pass it into the all meals url
actually has the value
and i actually want to wipe it so let me
showcase the bug first let's imagine the
user comes to application and we serve
the meals that we get back if the search
term is empty and let's say he or she
searches for the meals
with the search term of d okay awesome
and then we go with surprise me so
technically functionality works but if i
take a look at the developer tools more
specifically i'm looking for components
and then the app provider notice here
the value of d so that value is still
here and that might be misleading since
if the user comes here and types d
notice nothing is changing why well
because
we only fetch new meals if the value
changes and in our case we already have
this d
and let me just double check the name
so we're looking for this search term so
that's the one that's not changing now
how we can fix that well
what we could do in the search jsx we
could set up a new function
we can create handle random mule and in
there we'll set this one
to empty remember that's the one that
we're using over here
and we'll also set the set text to be
empty
and lastly
we'll
invoke the fetcher in the mill now
there's gonna be another bug
but first let's fix this and then we'll
worry about that one
so now i want to go to search
jsx
and like i said first
i want to set up that handle random
so before the return let's create
another function so const handle
random meal that's my function and here
let's invoke a few things now in order
to speed this up i'll just copy and
paste so we have search term that one i
want to set equal to an empty string
the settext also is going to set it
equal to an empty string and now i want
to go with fetch and i believe it was
random meal let's invoke this but now we
want to change this around where
it's not going to be fetch random meal
we'll actually look for handle
random meal let's pause that one and now
notice that yes we nicely wipe out all
the values but the problem is going to
be that
we set up another request and let me
showcase that so again let's start from
the scratch
i'll just wipe it clean then i'll type d
okay so we search for the meals then we
go
with the
run the meal and technically everything
works but i don't see the random meal
now why is that well if we take a look
at the network
we can see that we're making two
requests right now
we have one for random and one for
search now why is that well let's take a
look at our code
what are we doing here
we're setting the search term
back to nothing
now why is that important well because
we invoke this use effect every time
this value changes
so we fetch the random meal
it's over here in the function
but we also perform another fetch meals
with the all meals url
and here's the fix so first
you want to set up another use effect
in the context.jsx so this is going to
serve the moment application loads
at the moment application loads we get
all males url with empty search them
that's going to be again only
when the application loads that's it
now after that we'll set up another use
effect and this is a good side note
where you can have as many use effects
as you want in your application you're
not limited to one that's why i
purposely fixed bug this way because i
want to showcase that yes you can have
multiple use effects
now in the second use effect i actually
want to check hey
is there a value in the search term if
not then just return what does that mean
well
that means that this functionality is
not going to run
now why is that important because if i'm
not going to have this
second use effect the first one
then initially we're not going to get
any meals because remember this is an
empty value however now
we fix both issues initially we get
all meals url and then second every time
we change the value we still check
what is that search term if it's empty
then nothing so that fixes our random
meal bug so let's try this one out where
in the context.jsx i have my first use
effect and
that's awesome we'll still have to add a
little bit of code over there for now
what we want to do is create another one
and you know in order to speed this up
i'm just going to copy and paste like so
and here let's just remove the search
term
and rest of the functionality stays the
same
i mean
technically we can actually remove the
search term
there's no need
we can just go with all
meals url and just to reiterate the
value for the search term is empty but
the cool thing is that the api still
returns the emails and then in the
second one we want to set up the
condition where we want to go if there
is no
search term
then we want to go with return
and otherwise we want to call this and
lastly in the search jsx i actually want
to remove
this one
i want to leave the text
that
currently is displayed basically i want
to display the search term so the user
can see
so let me navigate back again let me
refresh notice how on the initial load
we still display
nicely all the meals okay that's awesome
then let's say we're gonna go
for the search term of f
so we get the meals okay beautiful but
once we click on surprise me first of
all we get that one meal
second if we take a look
at the provider we'll see that this is
empty so that actually matches whatever
we have in input and lastly if we take a
look at the network now we only
have one request now we have only the
random one
awesome and with this in place now we
can move on to the next step all right
next let's work on the modal component
and in the complete application it's
going to look something like this where
we can click
on the image
on one of the meals that we display
effectively in the emails component
check it out now we have that one
specific meal
and also we can click on one of the
favorites one
um it's also going to be displayed in
modal and for now we'll just worry about
rendering something on the screen
because
as we can see
we don't even have the component
and first
i want to set up a
return in the model jsx
and yes we'll style these classes right
away and you'll see in a second why
because they are effectively responsible
for
most of the css features
so the dark background and then the
white color and all that so yes we'll
basically style them first
then i want to set up a state
variable in the context.jsx i'm going to
call this show model and set show model
and the initial value is going to be
false
now yes
eventually
we'll control this once we click
on the image here or on the image in the
favorites but for now i just want to
showcase how the logic is going to work
and we want to pass this down the show
model one
and then in the app jsx remember we're
not even rendering the model yet but we
want to right away grab the show model
now don't worry about the favorites
actually this is an extra which
shouldn't be in your readme so that one
is coming up but in here we want to grab
show model and of course we
first need to import the use global
context invoke it get the show model and
display model only only if the value is
true and for now we'll just toggle it
manually just so you can see
the basic functionality so first let me
go to a search
and let me change this around to a modal
and then as far as the return like i
said i'm gonna go with few classes that
will
style first
and you know what also let's grab that
use context let me see over here
this sucker over here since we'll use it
in multiple places
we might as well copy it here
so copy and paste so use global context
eventually
we will actually invoke it but not for
now
and let's go with aside
then let's add a class name
last name now will be equal to modal
overlay as a signal that's the dark
background that you see
in the complete application and there's
also tiny bug over here this should be a
side
and then
inside of this element we're going to go
with div
and then
we'll have a class name of
modal container
model container so that's
the div with the white background where
we'll see the image and all of the data
about the meal and for now let's just
say here a roll container or you know
temporarily i'll add a heading 1 and
i'll say modal container just so we can
see it better
all right so let's save this
and then
we want to go to the context we want to
create that state variable
i guess i'm going to do it right after
the search term over here so const
we're looking for show model
then set show model so this is the
function that we use to call it
programmatically and as far as the
initial value you know it eventually it
will be false but since i want to
showcase
the modal i'll set it temporarily
equal to true let's keep on moving
then we want to pass down the show
show model and we want to jump back to
app jsx
first we want to get
the global one and again this is going
to be the case where i'll just copy and
paste i don't want to type it from the
scratch so
model here we just need to change the
path of course so
app jsx import and then
it's in the same folder so it's only one
dot
then we want to grab the value the show
model here so const
show model and then that one is equal to
huge
global
context let's invoke that and then where
we have the modal at the moment we have
comment around
so we want to uncomment that but we will
right away want to set up the condition
we want to say only if show modal is
true
then
so that's the end operator then we
display the model so let me place it
here and now let's see what we have
since the value
is true
we should
see right away model and now let me
switch back to the context because
that's the file where we'll be setting
up most of the logic let me go back over
here
notice i have the model container why
well because the value is true
if i change this around in the context
and if i set it equal to false
where it is where it is over here if i
set it equal to false
bam we cannot see the modal nothing
so we don't display the model so that's
the basic structure for the model where
we have the
boolean state
true or false and depending on that
value
we display or hide the model okay and up
next let's work on the css
so our modal
actually looks
more
like this
than what we have right now so at the
moment we just have a heading one and
yes i know i've said this already twenty
thousand times but let me repeat
one more where if you copied
the entire css you don't need to do
anything you can switch to a next video
in my case i'm going to open up a new
file
and
somewhere here i'm actually looking
for the css one and the app.css is not
coming up in my reset ones but
we can always search for it like so and
then let's keep on moving
and if i remember correctly modal was
the last one so let's work on those two
classes
and let me set it side by side right
away
like so
and here let's first worry about the
modal overlay so that's that dark
background that we have
the class is modal over
lay
and here let's set up position first of
all
fixed
so it's going to be taken out of the
normal flow then we right away need to
add the coordinates in my case i'm gonna
go with top
zero and left
zero so it's going to be
all the way on the top on the left hand
side then i want to set it width to be
100 and height to be 100 so effectively
i want to take it up all of the screen
with
100
and
height also 100
and then we want to go with some kind of
background so that's where we'll set up
that dark background bang on property
and i'm just going to go with rgba
because
the opacity value is a cool one that
allows us to control how dark it is so
for example in your case if you want it
lighter then just change the last value
the opacity in my case i'm going to go
with 0.85
let me add here a colon so that's our
modal
and then effectively
when it comes to
the overlay i want to set it as css grid
and place
the items meaning
our container in the center
so i want my overlay to take up
all of the screen but the items i want
in the center that's why right after the
background we'll set it up as display
grid
we'll also use the place items and
center and as you know this is a cool
property that allows us to combine align
items as well as the justify content
so instead of writing two lines of code
you can write one then transition and i
guess we'll have to write it here so
transition that just can signals that
the change is going to happen over time
and we're going to go with var and then
transition
just this variable and then lastly we
want to add the z index just in case
there's some other elements that are
taken out of the flow
and we just want to place it on top of
them so arbitrarily i'm just gonna go
with hundred and now let's work on that
model container and as you can see we
already have the text technically in the
center so
this should give us a good idea how it's
going to look like now let me select the
class model container
i'm going to go with
width of 80 percent of the screen width
and you know what let me add right away
a background because it's going to be
easier to see and we're going to go with
the white
so now we should see our model container
then right after the width i'm going to
go with max width so on a small screen
it's always going to be 80 percent
of the screen width now i don't want
that model to be bigger than
800 pixels as far as the width now
height always is going to be
80 view widths i'm sorry view height
that's more proper so view height and
then i know that
the content
is actually going to overflow
i mean again if we take a look at this
notice in here technically it didn't but
if we take a look at the big mac notice
so there is an image on the top and
there's also
the cooking instructions
so now for sure that
the content inside of it will
overflow and that's why we need to go
with overflow and just decide how we
want to deal with that in my case i'm
going to go with scroll and lastly let's
go with that border radius just so we
can have those nice rounded corners so
border
radius and we'll set it equal to var and
then css variable
with the value of poor radiators and
we're pretty much good to go we have set
our basic styles so now we can continue
with the functionality beautiful and up
next let's decide how we can pass the
meal
into the
model so at the moment we just have a
dummy content
but of course
eventually we'll have the functionality
where once we click
on any of the meals that we have here or
any of the meals that we have in the
favorite
the data about the meal is going to be
passed into a model and will correctly
display and as far as the setup
first
i will create a selected meal and set
selected meal
in the context.js so again we're
creating new state variable and initial
value is going to be no
then we want to set up a function
that is going to be looking for two
things
the miele and also is it a favorite meal
now we don't need to worry about this
parameter for now
we don't have the logic for it yet but
eventually yes we need to keep in mind
that we have two places where we have
meals
we have the favorites and also we have
just a regular list so yes there's going
to be a flag whether it's coming from
favorites or is just a regular meal
and then we want to
look for the meal using the find method
and we want to look where in all the
meals
in our state variable so if we remember
here we have meals and then once we
fetch those meals
we set meals equal to whatever
is the array we're getting back
from the api correct
so now we want to grab the
meal id
then we want to use it to get
the meal in the array
and we want to set it equal
to our selected meal
state variable and also
we want to showcase the model
now what was the
function that was set show model then we
want to make the select meal and
selected meal available to rest of the
application so we want to pass it into a
value
and then back in the meals
we want to grab select meal so that's
the function over here the select meal
and then we want to invoke it
once we click on the image so we want to
add on click and pass in the id
and i'll talk about why we need over
here this arrow function again
few things state variable the function
we want to pass both of those values
down so selected meal so this is what
we're going to use in the model and
select meal
which we'll invoke
in the meals so
let's go step by step first let's create
that state
variable
and in my case i'm going to call this
selected
meal so effectively what meal we have
selected
set selected
meal now that is equal to use state
and by default let's set it equal to no
so by default it's not going to have any
value but i also want to change this one
around where it's going to be false
so by default we're not going to display
the model
let's come up with that function
and i think i'm going to do it right
after the random one so let's create it
const select meal
and here the function is looking for two
things for id meal effectively that is
the meal id i'm just using the same
property name as it comes from the api
because that way it's going to be easier
to understand at least in my opinion
then we want to go with favorite meal
which is a boolean value but at the
moment we don't really care about it
and we're going to go with let meal so
initially it's nothing that value
but we want to go with meal and then
meals fine now why we're going the long
way because there's going to be an if
condition so for now yes there's only
one possibility where essentially we'll
just use this id meal and we'll get the
meal from our array again we'll get the
meal from our meals array
so let's go with find method
and
pass in the callback function i'll
reference each and every meal there as
meal and i'll say get me the meal
whose id
matches
the id meal basically whose property is
exactly the same so id meal is equal to
id meal that we're passing in and then
let's set up two more functions first
let's go with set
selected meal
so this is the meal display in a modal
that's where we pass this value and
second
we want to open the model correct so set
show model and let's set it equal to
true
let's save that and now we want to pass
down two things
we want to pass down the selected meal
and we want to pass down the select meal
so let's look for the value
selected
selected meal
and we also want to go with select
meal and now we want to navigate to
bum bum bum bum
css
even though we will use it later
we want to navigate to the meals we want
to
grab
select
meal
and then let's look for the image
now let's shall we destructure the
idemill correct when we iterate over our
so now we can just grab this value and
pass it into a function now let me first
showcase
what is going to happen
essentially
if
we don't pass in the callback function
because this is the question that i
pretty much get all the time as far as
react so let's go over here and let's
say
select
meal
and let's pass in the id
meal like so
let me save it and you know what for
time being
let me just add a console log just so we
can see that we have called this
function
because effectively it's going to be
invoked right away and that's not what
we want we want to invoke it only when
we click on email so let me try here
uh hello let's see let me save the
application which you'll notice
that first of all we'll open up the
model right from the get go because
that's the logic and also we'll have
these
25
meals
now why do we have that
well
simply because like i keep saying
if
we set up the function this way we
invoke it right away so the moment
application loads the moment we display
the meals we invoke it but that's not
what we want to do we want to invoke it
only once we have clicked on it and the
solution for that is following where we
want to go with a arrow function and
then we want to set up this function as
the return from the arrow function
and as a result you'll notice that
everything works as expected so we get
our array of meals
and only once we click on it we shut
that selected meal again the reason why
i'm spending so much time on this
because this is
probably
top three questions i get why
we set up this arrow function simply
because if you don't have the arrow
function you invoke it
right away and that's not what you want
to do you want to set this one up as a
return from the arrow function so
initially this arrow function runs
returns this function and then we invoke
select meal passing the id only
only
once we click on the image let me also
do one more log in this case i'm going
to go with
id email just so we can see that we're
passing in that value so let me go back
to my application first of all you'll
notice that
we'll display
the modal because remember we go with
set
show model and we set it equal to true
so bam check it out we right away
display them all and also
we'll have here the id now we don't have
a way how we can close the model so
that's why i mean it's just going to be
sitting there right now but lastly in
this video i just want to showcase that
if you go to components
you should also see
this one
what is this that's the meal that we
selected how do i know that well because
the idea is exactly the same
so that's the state value the selected
meal one initially it was no and now
it's actually equal
to the meal
that we selected
all right and up next let's render the
meal
that we have selected
and also let's set up the close model
functionality
now
dcss will add in the following video so
if it looks somewhat ugly during this
video
i mean it is what it is the most
important thing
uh is to get
the data
on the screen so i want to showcase
which meal we have selected and i also
want to close the model and then we'll
worry about the styles so first in the
context.jsx and for some reason i
have context
and most likely i'll have to fix it in
multiple places but again that's my
problem
we want to create close model and in
here we'll go with set show model and
we'll set it equal to
false now we'll pass it down to a
application so add that
into the value and then in the modal we
want to grab two things
we want to grab selected meal like i
mentioned in the previous video
so select meal we
utilized it in the meals
now selected meal
will utilize it in a modal
so grab both of those things close model
and selected meal we'll destructure
again a bunch of properties out of it so
image
title instructions as well as the
original source
and then we'll work on our return
and all the way in the bottom there's
going to be a button
that allows us to close the model so
let's start working on that one
i guess
first let's go to a context one
and we want to create
the closed model function
so again i'm going to do it before use
effects
and it's really up to you where you want
to do it so close model
and as i said yes of course you can pass
in set show model but
i always prefer just setting up the
function
makes a bit more sense to me so set
show
model we want to pass in as false
of course because we're closing the
model let's add a comma
close model
and
we're already passing rest of the stuff
so we don't need to worry about it after
that we want to go to a model
and we want to invoke that use global
context and we want to grab two things
we want to get the selected meal again
this is the meal that we want to display
this is the meal that we set once we
click on those images and second we want
to grab close
and modal and that is equal to use
global context let's invoke that and
we're good to go
then let's destructure it
because we actually want to display it
and you know what let me just mess
around a little bit let's set up a
button here just so we can close it
let's write closed and let's set up on
click now in this case we don't need to
invoke it meaning as a arrow function we
can simply go with close model since
this is a reference again we're not
invoking when you're invoking that's
when you need to set it up as an arrow
function now we don't invoke we pass it
as a reference and then
you know what let me just display the
title just so we can see that we're
getting that exact meal and this is also
something that i suggest doing when
you're building the application
try to do it step by step
um if you'll set a bunch of logic and
then it turns out that you have a bug
somewhere else this is going to be very
painful to go and pack so that's why i
always like to do it step by step
where
first i just display the title see that
i'm actually getting the correct meals
and then i proceed to the structure of
more properties so in here i simply want
to go with selected meal so for time
being i'm not going to structure it i'm
just going to look for the entire object
and we're going to go with dot and i
believe the
value is
sdr meal and now let's try it out what
do we have
let me refresh just so everything is up
to date yep that's the meal that i
selected i can clearly see that and i
can close the model and the next one
next one
and i can clearly see that my initial
functionality works so now it's just an
easy part
where we wanted to structure it
and that is coming from
selected
meal
and then one by one let's grab those
properties again we do want to get the
image so this one is that annoying one
thumbnail that is equal to an image now
sdr meal equals to title in my case
then instructions and as i say not again
if you want to
see all the properties that are there in
the object either you can log it here in
the model
or you can simply go to developer tools
more specifically
to
our components and analyze it so let's
go here with instructions
set it equal to text and then lastly
source
and effectively this is the original
uh kind of resource
so let's
keep moving
we're not gonna have the heading one
here and actually button
[Music]
the button is going to be
another div
so for now let's just leave it the way
it is
so first in the container we want to set
up a image
so let's go with img source
and then image and i'll say not yes i
know that i'm not setting up the
alternative attributes and maybe you
know let's change it let's pass here the
title
and you can also do that in the meals
my apologies i forgot when i was setting
up the meals
so let's go here with a class names
and we want to set up img and modal img
so this is the global class and this is
the class which we're going to style
in the following video then right after
the image we want to set up another div
with a class name of modal content
modal content and we want to place that
button inside of it
yes it's going to be all the way on the
bottom but
different div
then let's go with heading 4
we're going to look for the title
after that we want to go with a
paragraph and we're just going to say
cooking instructions and then let's set
up another paragraph with a text
so let's look for the text over here and
lastly we have that original source so
for that we're going to go with an href
attribute we'll pass in source
and i also want to open it up in a new
browser tab so therefore i'm going to go
with target and then underscore
black again this
is effectively a html attribute so let's
pass here
the value for our link
and that is going to be original source
and let's see how bad the css looks let
me navigate here
again i'm going to refresh
so
everything is up to date and then let me
click on this one and there is a issue
okay so select meal is not defined
okay that's interesting so select meal
is not defined modal jsx
probably i just messed it up as far as
the name so let me go here and yeah of
course
it's selected meal my bad see how easy
it is to make
a silly mistake let's try one more time
and yeah i mean it looks ugly correct
but as long as we can see all of the
items so the image the title the cooking
instructions as well as the original
source we're good to go
because we'll set up the styles in the
following video and as far as that
target blank check it out once we click
on it
we navigate to
the original resource essentially where
the
recipe is coming from
not i also noticed that in a context i
still have that log so let me remove
that sucker and just like that we're
done with the functionality of
displaying the selected meal as well as
closing the model
so up next let's style our model
so it looks a bit more presentable okay
and up next let's work on the styles
so at the moment
we have all the functionality but
it definitely
can look better
and
i'm going to start by navigating to the
app css
yep over here we're looking for the
model which i believe was the last one
and
we want to style the image first then
let me grab it here just so we can see
right away the result and i'm going to
start by targeting the image the modal
img and i want to add some kind of
height so it's always going to be 15
rams now
of course that is up to you you can make
it smaller bigger
uh that is essentially irrelevant
then we want to add the borders for the
image
because at the moment we just have for
the container
so in my case i'm going to look for
those properties here
so board top left and border top right
let's copy and paste that
essentially it's going to be faster then
for a modal
content
first let's select the class then let's
add
a padding one rem's top bottom and then
1.5
left and right
then for the content effectively for
those paragraphs i want to add the great
color
model content and then paragraph
and that is going to be gray 600 that's
the value color var
css variable gray
and then
we're looking for 600
after that we want to style the link
so this one over here the original
source and also the close button and you
know what i think
i think
there's a button missing
and yep so it's actually btn b10 hipster
and close model i didn't add those
classes my apologies
so let me navigate back so class name
we're gonna go with btn btn
hipster and then we'll add close
and btn let's save that
that should do it let me click
yep that's the button right now
and then back in the css
we want to target
the button
you want to look for that closed model i
believe or close btn
the one that i basically just set
up and
we want to add the background color
different
so let's go with close btn
and we're going to go with background
and we're going to set it as a red
hyphen and dark and then after that
let's go with color
and we're going to set it equal to a
white one
all right so that should do it for the
button and then lastly let's worry about
that link
so that's going to be under modal
content and link
in here let's go with display block
because i want to start in the new line
i want to set some kind of color in my
case i'm going to go with primary and
500
then we want to add a little bit of
margin in the bottom
so my case i think i'm going to go with
1rms
margin bottom equals to 1 rm
then we have text decoration which will
set it equal to the underline
text
decoration and that's equal to a
underline let's save it
yep looks about right and then lastly we
just want to add a little bit of
transition since there's going to be a
hover effect as well
so first let me select here let me add
hover
so as we're hovering we want to set the
color
equal to a black and then let's add that
transition and that one will be equal to
a css variable with the same name
transition
and once we set the styles we're pretty
much done with the model and up next
we're going to work on the favorites
component and as far as the favorites we
want to start in the context jsx we want
to set up a new state variable by the
name of favorites we also have a
function
set favorite and for timing is going to
be empty array eventually we'll set up
the local storage
so once the application loads we'll
check the local storage first
but for now let's not worry about it
we will set up two functions one is
going to be add to favorites which again
will look for
id meal
basically the email id
then we'll use that id to find a meal in
the meals array
after that check
whether it's already in the favorites
so essentially if i have that meal and a
favorite i don't want to add it one more
time
and if that's the case then we'll just
return so nothing is going to happen
if not
if it's not in the favorites
then we'll spread out the current values
the favorites one
and we'll add that extra meal
so we create a new array we spread out
the existing values and we add that
extra meal and then we use the set
function
to actually
add
the new array as our value so we have
the current value and this is the new
one
and while we're on topic right away
let's also create a remove from
favorites
so this one again is going to be looking
for id meal and we'll invoke it from the
favorites
same deal however in this case we right
away look in the favorites and we just
say
look return only the meals
whose id does not match the id meal that
we're passing
and again
we go with updated favorites
so now we use set favorites and again we
pass in the updated favorites so all the
time we just change the values in the
array and we set that array as our new
state variable we want to pass both of
them down to your entire application so
pass both of them in the value
and for now in this video we'll just
worry about
adding to the favorites so we'll have to
destructure it in the meals
and then notice how it's exactly the
same as select meal why because again
we're passing in the id meal
so hopefully you remember why we're
setting up that arrow function so here
we have that like button and every time
i click on that button we'll add meal
to the favorite
and i guess i'm going to start by
setting up that state variable i believe
that's going to be actually our last one
if i'm not mistaken so favorites
then set favorites
and we'll use use state then like i said
before for now it's just going to be
empty array let's keep on
moving and i'll set up both of these
functions here
const add two
favorites
it's going to be a function and it's
going to be looking for one thing and
one thing only the meal id which i'm
going to
name
id meal just because that's the name of
the property
so i think it's less confusing copy and
paste and we want to go with the remove
remove
from favorites
after that let's
set up the logic so like i said first we
want to get that meal from the meals
state variables const
meal and that one is equal to meals find
and let's pass in the callback function
i'll reference each and every meal
as a meal parameter and i'll say if meal
id meal matches
the id
so the parameter we're passing in
if it matches
the meal at the property then good then
get me that
after that we want to
check if it's already in the favorites
so const and then
already
favorite and that will be equal to
favorites
and we're gonna go with find
check for meal
and same deal
basically if the id matches
then this is going to be true
so in here we can kind of cheat a little
bit where i'm going to grab the logic
again it's the same deal
keep in mind that
once we get this meal and we pass it
into array the structure is going to be
exactly the same that's why we can do
that uh now let's set up the condition
if it's true
if already favorite evaluates to true in
this case then i want to return why
because like i mentioned i don't want to
add it
multiple times to a favorites
i mean if it's already there then i'm
good to go so that's why we can click
all day long and nothing is going to
happen that's exactly the result i'm
looking for
and then lastly
if that's not the case then javascript
is going to keep on reading the code and
therefore we'll
create this array update
favorites and now will be equal to a new
array let's spread out all the values in
the state in the state variable let's
add that meal
sucker over here
and then
let's go with set
favorites and let's pass in update
favorites now eventually yes there's
going to be a local storage but for now
we're not gonna worry about it so we're
gonna go with
updated
you know what i need to actually fix
this updated
and then favorites
all right that's good so now let's set
up the logic where we remove from the
favorites
and we'll do that by again creating a
new variable updated
and then favorites
and we're gonna go with favorite state
value
and we will use the filter method
and we'll check if the item
id mail property
does not match the id that we're passing
then we'll return it into our new array
so essentially we'll just exclude
the item whose id matches
and as a result we'll be able to remove
the meals from the favorites area like
so we click and we're good to go and
this is going to be the case where again
we want to pass in the callback function
and we want to go with meal and as i
said i need to set it up here as a param
meal and if meal
id meal
does not so this is the case where we're
looking for the items whose id
does not match what we're passing
then we return in that new array and now
we want to do the same thing over here
we want to go with set favorites and
then passing updated
favorites
and then let's pass both those things
down
so it was add
to
favorites and it was also removed
from
favorite
and once we have this one in place we
just want to go to
meals
and then we want to structure it of
course
so say add
to
favorites and now let's keep on moving
and we're looking for the light button
so here we want to add again on click
and yes i'll repeat one more time
since we invoked a function
basically there's no other way
for us to get the id email we just have
to pass it in and since we invoke it yes
we need to set up
the arrow function
so let's go here
let's say on click
um
set up the arrow function first
let's see i think i have a mistake here
and then we will
invoke add
to
favorites
and then let's pass in the id meal and
if everything is correct
uh we'll definitely see that in the
components
essentially in our developer tools but
if you want to double check that you can
always console.log so let me go back to
the context let me find this one and
i'll just log for time being and i'm
going to pass in id
meal
so let's try it out i'm going to
navigate to my application
um i mean you can pick any
of the meals and then just click on like
button
and we should see in the console some
logs and also like i said if we check
the dev tools
either in the app provider
we should see yep notice over here so
that's the
favorites array
effectively every time we'll click on it
we'll add the item so let me try here
notice now i have three of them
then this one is already here i guess
that's why i don't see it and then
notice
every time we click on the item we add
it to the favorites all right and now we
just need to worry about how we can
render it on the screen and as a quick
sign up
if you want to make your code more
performant
you can refactor meal below the return
so essentially if you move the meal
below the return
now you'll see that we only search for
the meal twice in the favorites and in
the meals
if we already know that is not in the
favorites since we know that if the meal
is in favorites we return regardless
so if it's not in the favorites yes then
we go to meals we get the meal and then
we add it to the updated and you know
the rest all right next let's worry
about rendering the favorites
and the first thing we want to do in the
app
jsx we want to grab the favorite state
variable and we want to check the length
and i only want to render favorites
if the length is bigger than zero
it's an array
so we can always check the length and
only if it's bigger than zero then we
render the favorites
and effectively the result is going to
be following if i have no items in the
favorites then we're not rendering the
component all together
and once we have that set up in place
essentially we want to
grab favorites select meal and remove
from favorites
in the favorites component so this is an
array that we're going to render
so if i add it here norrish that's going
to be our component that's our array
and then we want to grab the select meal
because like i mentioned previously yes
we'll be able to open up a model from
the favorites as well now there is a
gotcha but we'll worry about it later
now we just want to grab this select
meal and then we want to also grab
remove from favorites so that's the
remove button that we can invoke over
here
um for now we'll just set up the return
where we'll have some heading 5 as well
as we'll iterate over the items
and then
in the following video i'll worry about
the css again
the result after this video probably is
going to be somewhat ugly
so let's start cracking
and
i think i'm going to
go to app jsx first
and i want to grab the favorites as well
again that's my array and i want to
check the length and only if i have some
items in there then i want to render the
favorites component let me go
favorites and as i say not keep in mind
that every time you refresh it we'll
start from zero from empty array simply
because we are not we're not using the
local storage yet so let's go here with
favorites
and then let's check the length right
away
length
and if it's bigger than zero then we
want to render the favorites
so let me add the component in the
expression and we're good to go and we
can actually quickly test it so let me
go to my application refresh
and it looks like i have an error
it says here that we cannot read the
properties of undefined
and i think it's because i didn't pass
it down in the previous video my band so
let me go here
in the context jsx let me add the
favorites array so we also want to pass
that one down and now once we refresh we
should be good to go so at the moment we
don't see anything again it is empty
array
but
once we click on the like button we
should see the favorites component
because now we have some kind of value
in there and
let me go back to my context.jsx
i think i'll remove this one for now the
id
and then we want to navigate to the
favorites
that's the component then i guess i'm
just going to start by again grabbing
that use global context
so let me look for favorites
i mean here let's set it up since we'll
grab a bunch of values from
the context
and we'll start by setting up the
structure so const we're looking for
favorites
then we also want to grab the select
meal again that is coming up for now
we're not going to worry about it and we
want to remove
from favorites hopefully that one i
added to the context.jsx so use global
context let's invoke that and now let's
set up the return it's going to be a
section
we'll add a class name of
favorites
last name and set up equal to my
favorites then we want to rename the
closing tag so this is going to be a
section
inside of the section let's go with div
so
let's set up the div
and in here let's add a class of class
name
first of all and then we're gonna go
with favorites
and content
then inside of the div let's go with
heading five
and we're gonna go with favorites
and then let's iterate over that list
however we'll place it in the div so
they have class name and we're going to
go with favorites
and container
and instead of div let's iterate over
that array so favorites array then we'll
call the map and we'll set up the
callback function i'll reference each
meal as an item and then as far as the
return
um we want to go with constant we wanted
the structure again how do i know that
it's there because we're passing that
entire object
to array so i know that the structure is
going to be exactly the same again what
we're looking for we want to get the
meal and we want to get the image that's
all
so in this component it's not much and
in this case i'll
rename it to an image and that is equal
to an item then we want to return
and we're going to go with div we need
to pass in the key prop and in that case
it's going to be equal to id meal then
we want to set up a class name here
class name and that one will be equal to
a favorite
item
item and then
instead of this dividend by the way i
need to add the closing one inside of
this div we first want to display the
image and then we want to go with the
button that removes that item from the
array
so let's start with img source
will go with image again
that's the alias that we just set up
then let's add a class name
class name and that one is equal to
a favorites
and then
img and also img so global image class
and then the favorite image class
and lastly let's set up that button
we'll add a class name and that one will
be equal to a remove btn so this is the
case we're not going to add that global
class we'll just set up a
class 4d favorites
and then inside of the button let's just
type remove
and we need to add
the functionality correct so again we go
with on click
and this time i'm not going to repeat
why we use the arrow function
please we'll watch the previous videos
where we initially set it up so let's go
here we remove and then
favorites
so let me set up the proper name here
remove from favorites and let's pass in
that id meal and once we're done typing
out the return we can take a look at the
application again i can guarantee you
it's going to be somewhat ugly so let me
click here and notice that's our giant
image and then we also have that removed
so if we add another one then yep it's
exactly the same thing and now if we
click on remove we can remove from the
favorites so our next step is going to
be
to set up the styles so it looks more
presentable like this and as far as the
css let's navigate to your app css and
all the way
no actually no not in the bottom
i have model in the bottom
we want to set it up here between the
meals and search
first we want to
grab the main container
and let me set up the files here as well
and we're gonna go with favorites
let's add a background and we're gonna
go with black one now of course keep in
mind that we're not gonna be able to see
so
maybe
um you know what
either we can add
a favorite just so we can see something
or we can remove that condition i think
i'm just going to add that meal and
we should be good to go let's add a
color here
that one will be equal to white one then
we want to go with batting
one rem's top bottom left and right is
going to be equal to zero we'll set up
the favorites content
and essentially i want to set up the
width
similarly
to how we did for a search
so let's go with favorites
and content and
i'm going to go somewhere and find the
values essentially this is what i'm
looking for so with max with
as well as the
margin 0 which in this case i don't have
i'll have to add it so copy and paste
and let's add margin
zero auto so now we're placing nicely
the content in the center
then we want to work with the container
so in this case we're looking for
favorites and container noun will be
equal to display
flex
and then gap so set up a little bit of
distance in between the items and also
go with flex wrap equals to wrap let's
say that
and as a result let me refresh
it should look better
and
nope it's still quite big ah because of
the image yeah my apologies we're not
going to see anything as of yet
but we do want to place everything in
the center
and when i say everything i'm actually
talking about the button so favorite
item and then we want to go with text
align and
center save that and now let's make that
image quite small so favorite
hyphen img and we're going to go with
width
60 pixels
so now it's going to be small i mean it
should be
favorite img
and then let's check
we have poor radius
or radius
50
and for some reason i don't see the
result
let me try one more time again still
it's massive so let me double check in
the favorites
so that should be favorite item
and this is favorites mg maybe i'm
selecting it wrong so apps yes yeah
should be favorites img my bad so now
notice we have
image with border radius as well as the
width so now it looks a little bit
better then let's add a border and that
one will be equal to 5 pixels solid
and we're going to look for the css
variable with a value of white
and then let's also set up a cursor
pointer since remember once we click
eventually we'll
add it to a model and now let's worry
about the remove button so that one
is the last thing we want to style
essentially for the entire project
so let's go with remove iphone btm
and here we'll go with margin
top and we'll set it equal to
[Music]
0.25 rem
then we want to go with background
transparent we want to set the color
equal to white
so r and hyphen white after that we want
to do the same thing with the border
so let me copy this one
let's just set the border so borders
equal to transparent as well cursor is
going to be equal to a pointer
and what else what else what else we
have transition since there's going to
be a hover effect and also a font size
so let's start with font size that will
be equal to
0.5 rem so i'll basically make the text
smaller and then after that we want to
go with that transition
so let's go with transition and the css
variable with the same name so
transition and let's quickly add the
hover effect
so we're looking for a move button and
we want to change the color essentially
as we're hovering so remove button hover
and then let's just go with color
bar and then red
dark let's save it
and now notice
we have the favorites we can only see it
if we add the meal and you know what
i think you can place it already there
and once we add
to the list
we have more meals
if we want you can remove it as well and
once i remove all the meals then of
course we cannot see the component the
favorites component okay and next let's
refactor select meal
see eventually i want to add the same
logic
to the image
so every time we click on a favorites
image
we also display the meal in the model
however we need to keep something in
mind
we have two arrays
we have meals and we have the favorites
and at the moment select meal is looking
where
it's looking
in the meals
so yes there's going to be some
situations where
the meal that you have in the favorites
is also going to be displayed on the
screen however if let's say i go with a
random one now as you can see if you
click on this
meal and try to find it in meals it's
not going to be there anymore
so
when
we set up the select meal we also need
to take an account that we'll call it in
two places
on the meals array and also in the
favorites and therefore we have right
now this favorite meal
and effectively we just want to add the
condition
so we want to add the condition that if
that is true
so
if we're calling it in the favorite
meals then we simply want to look for a
different array
so then we want to look in the favorites
one
now if
it's actually in the meals then of
course we don't need to worry about it
it's going to be right there in the
meals array
so therefore we'll set up the condition
we'll say if every meal is true
then we'll look in the favorites if not
then we'll look in the meals and then in
the favorites we already structured it
we just need to invoke it we need to
pass in the id meal so the meal id and
also true because in this case we're
calling it
from the favorites
i guess i'm going to start in the
context
and first i want to set up the logic
i'll say if
and then favorite meal
you know if it's true
then essentially
the logic is going to be exactly the
same the only difference is
i'm looking in the favorites
let's call it and we also want to place
the second one in the else condition
so now
depending on the value of favorite meal
we'll either check for the meal in the
favorites or in the meals
and now we just need to go to the
favorites we already have select meal
and we want to add the on click on the
image now let's pass in the function
first
the arrow function and then we want to
go with select
meal
then let's pass in the id
so we're looking for id
meal and second we'll pass in the true
so yes we're calling this from the
favorites and now let's check it out i'm
gonna go to my application so notice
now all the meals now i can add it to
the favorites and even
if my meals are right right now is
different i can still
display them in the model which is
awesome
all right and the last piece of
functionality we want to add to this
application
is adding favorites to the local storage
so at the moment everything works nice
but the moment we refresh the
application
again we start from the scratch
and instead we want to save to local
storage every time we add item to the
favorites
and we can do that
for both of them for add favorites and
remove from favorites so when we want to
add the item to the local storage we go
local storage again this is built in the
browser so we don't need to install
anything we go with set item in my case
i'll call it favorites and remember that
we can only
uh save strings so therefore we need to
go json stringify and then updated
favorites
so this array over here and then once we
want to remove
again basically we'll overwrite
so we'll go with local storage set items
favorites and then we'll overwrite the
existing value with the new updated
favorites and then once the application
loads we want to grab it from the local
storage
now there's
various ways how we can set up the
functionality that grabs the items from
the local storage but in my case i went
the long way
since that way um
in my opinion it's more straightforward
now
can you make this code shorter
absolutely
but
initially i wanted to make it
uh easy to follow so here we're looking
for the favorites
we try to grab the favorites from the
local storage we go with get item now
there are two possibilities if
the favorites exist then this is going
to be true and then we just need to
parse it because remember we stringify
it so now we need to parse it and again
we go with local storage get item
favorites so we parse it back into array
and that is if
it exists if not if this is false
then we'll set it equal to an empty
array we return the favorites and then
we invoke this
where we have used it again
i'm fully aware that there are shorter
ways how to write this logic but
at least when i'm setting up the content
i always want to start with more
readable code i think that is more
important than
having less lines of code
and i guess i'm going to go to the
context first
let's just add the functionality
where we want to go with that set
local storage
or sorry local storage and then we're
going to go to set
item we're looking for favorites at
least that's how i'm going to call it
and we need to use json
then stringify
and we want to pass in the updated
favorites
now once that is in place
we want to copy and paste then
essentially we're doing the same thing
when we remove the item
and here it's actually
a bug because there's a missing letter
and then let's scroll up
and let's set up that function
so we want to go with that
get favorites from local storage and i'm
going to set it up above the app
provider we're going to go const get
favorites
from local
local storage it's going to be a
function and right from the get go it's
going to return the favorites
something we're going to set up right
here we'll go with let and
favorites now that is equal to a local
storage
get
item
and now of course we're looking for that
favorites
all right
favorite if it exists
awesome
we'll have one logic if
it doesn't then of course
we'll just return an empty array so say
favorites is equal to an empty array
effectively the functionality we already
have
but if it does exist
then it's going to be different we're
going to go with favorites
then json parse so we need to parse it
again we are saving it as a string so we
need to parse it and then local storage
and essentially we just want to get this
code
over here let's just set it up
and the last thing we need to do is just
invoke it so where we have the favorites
let's go with
get favorites from local storage let's
invoke it so now let's take a look at
the application
essentially once we add the item to the
favorites it's displayed and also it
stays there even once we refresh the
application
with this in place we're done with
application hopefully everyone enjoyed
it and i'll see you in the next one i
hope that project helped you gain a
deeper understanding on how everything
fits together and react
in this next section you'll use what
you've been learning and also learn
about new react features
sanjeev is your instructor for this next
section
hey everyone for this next project we're
going to be building out a stock trading
app where users can keep track of their
favorite stocks they could see what is
the current price as well as historical
prices as well
now for this application on the main
page you're going to see a list of all
of the stocks the user has decided to
watch and it's going to list out the
last price or the most recent price as
well as what was the change the change
percentage the high low open and the
previous close so just some relevant
information about that specific stock
and how it's doing in addition to that a
user can go to the input field up here
and search for companies to add to their
watch list so if the user wants to
search for tesla they can just search
for tesla and this is going to send a
request to our api
and it's going to result in a list of
companies that match that specific query
we can then pick the specific company
that we're interested in and it's going
to add it to the watch list so now we
can keep track of tesla and if we want
to we can remove any one of these so if
we want to remove microsoft we can do
that as well
and the nice part about this is this
watch list here is going to be
remembered because we're going to store
this information in the local storage so
if the user navigates away from this
page and then comes back to it it's
going to remember all of the companies
the user is interested in
now when we select on one of these
stocks it's going to take us to the
detailed page for that stock so it's
going to render out a nice chart that's
going to show historical data not just
the current price so right now you can
see that it's selected the past 24 hours
if we want to we can also see the past
seven days and then if we want we can
also see the past year and the nice part
is it's going to color code it depending
on if the stock improved or if it went
down
and then beneath that it's also going to
include some relevant information about
the company so things like what
exchanges are part of when was the ipo
date what's the website for that company
how many shares outstanding as well as
market cap and a few other details
now for the technologies in this project
we're gonna be working with a lot of
different technologies we've got all of
the core hooks like use state use effect
but in addition to that we're also going
to be making use of the context api so
that we can pass data down to the
various different components in our
application we'll get a chance to work
with local storage and in addition to
that we'll also be making use of the
finhub api so that we can get data about
these stocks and for the charting
library
we're going to be making use of apex
charts so in the detail page when we
draw out that historical data we're
going to be making use of this library
and you'll see that this library is
actually very easy and intuitive to use
and so that's what i've got in store for
you guys hopefully you guys enjoy this
project
and i'll see you in the next section
while we get started in bootstrapping
the project
and just a quick note before we proceed
any further because we are using a free
account on finhub api uh you'll see that
we won't have access to certain data
points so when you're looking for
companies uh and if you're searching for
something like microsoft in this case
you want to make sure you just see
microsoft you don't want to see
microsoft.sw or mi these are not
supported with the free tier and you'll
see that it'll actually break our
application just because we don't have
the specific error handling checks for
when the user doesn't have the privilege
to access the information so just make
sure you don't select on these and get
the the main
stock symbol
before we get started bootstrapping our
application i want to go over how we're
going to handle navigating between the
different pages in our application
and so in our application we have two
main pages when the user navigates to
the root path and if you aren't familiar
with what that means if you take a look
at a url we have http colon slash and
then we have a domain so this is gonna
be whatever domain name you've purchased
for your application uh and so if you
own google.com then this is gonna be
google.com if you're just working in
development mode for your react
application it's gonna be localhost
colon 3000. so that's a domain and then
you have a path following that so in
this case this is called the root path
because it's just forward slash so
there's no specific path after that and
so when the user navigates to the root
path it's going to take him to the main
page here where we're going to have a
list of all the different stocks that
they're tracking
and when they select one of these
specific stocks it's going to take them
to a detailed page and that detailed
page is going to reside at this
following url so we have the same http
colon slash we have the domain name and
then the path is going to be detail
slash and then the name of the specific
stock so if they wanted to see microsoft
it would be msft uh inserted in for
symbol
and so that's how we want the routing
working in our application
and the way we're going to actually
accomplish this is through client-side
routing and we're going to make use of a
library called react router and react
router is actually very simple and the
main idea behind react router is you
tell it what are the different urls for
the different pages that we want so
these are going to be the two urls and
all it's going to do is it's going to
load a specific component for each url
so the way we're going to structure this
is when the user navigates to the root
url we're going to have a react
component and this is a regular react
component there's no special
componentry needed within react router
just makes use of regular react
components and we're going to have a
component called stockoverviewpage.jsx
and so when they navigate to the root
path it's just going to load up this
component and this component is going to
have all of the individual components
that make up this page so the way we're
going to actually break this down is
we're going to have a component for the
auto completion and then we're going to
have a component for the list of the
different stocks
and then when the user selects one of
these specific stocks it's going to
route them to this specific url
and this url is going to load up a
component called stockdetailpage.jsx
and so this component is going to
contain the graph as well as the
detailed information down here and so
that's how we're going to handle
client-side routing within our
application and you'll see when we get
started coding this out it's actually
going to be very simple
so let's create a new application in
replit i'm just going to select the plus
button right here and we're going to
scroll down and we're going to select
react javascript and i'm just going to
give this the name of react
demo so our projects have been
bootstrapped i'm just going to hit run
so we can just make sure everything's
working
and we can see our application was
successfully loaded so it looks like
everything's working i'm just going to
do a little cleanup we don't actually
need this text here
and in addition to that if we go to our
app.css we can either delete this or
just comment it out we'll be adding our
own styles
now for this project we're going to make
use of bootstrap just for styling only
because i don't want to spend too much
time uh having you guys copy all of the
css properties and things like that i'd
rather just add in a couple of bootstrap
properties so that we can have a nice
finished polished looking product
without having to spend too much time on
css so if you go to getbootstrap.com and
you just scroll down to include via cdn
we want to get just the css only we're
not going to be making use of the
javascript so we can just copy this to
clipboard
and if we go back to our application and
we can just go to our index.html
and inside the heading we can just put
this under the title you can just paste
that in there
we'll save that and then just to make
sure that everything's working i'm going
to
re-add in some text or i'm going to add
a h2 tag and just make it say hello or
something
we'll save that
and we should see it in there and i'm
just going to add some
um classes from the bootstrap library so
i'll do class name equals and then i'm
just going to say empty
dash 2 so this should add or i'll do
mt-5 this is going to add in some margin
to the top and so we can see it moved
down so it looks like bootstrap was
successfully loaded
and after we get this set up the next
thing that we have to do is we have to
go to the api that we're going to make
use of so we're going to be making use
of the finhub stock api this is a free
api you will have to register but it is
completely free and if you just select
get free api it's going to take you to a
window where you can register and then
once you've registered it'll then
provide all of your api keys and so the
one you want is this top one right here
so you just grab this you can copy it
and then just store it in some
documentation so you can refer to it
later
now as i mentioned we're going to be
making use of a library called react
router so the first thing that we're
going to do is we're going to install
that so we can set up the routing and so
if we select the package manager here
and under here we want to search for
react router and then more specifically
we want react router dom and make sure
you get the react router dash dom
because there is a react router but
that's a different package we want this
one specifically here so we'll select
react router dom
and we can see that it's installing
react router dom
all right so we'll go back to our files
and what i want to do is i'm going to
create a new folder in our source
directory
and i'm going to call this pages so this
is going to have the two different pages
there's going to be the summary page as
well as the detailed page
and so i'll create our stock detail page
dot jsx
and then we'll have our stock overview
page
as well
and so react router dom is going to
actually route to one of these two uh
components and keep in mind these are
just plain react components
and so i'm just gonna
do export
const
stock detail page
and for now this is just going to return
a div
that just says this is the stock detail
page
i'm going to do the same thing for my
stock overview page
so now that we've got our pages defined
i'm going to go back to our app.jsx
component and i'm going to import all of
the things we need to get react router
dom working
and so there's going to be three things
that we need
i'm going to say import and we want
browser router
we also want routes with an s as well as
route singular
and we want to import this from react
router dom
and so we've got these three things i'm
going to delete this h2 tag
and what i want to do is i want to call
browser router
and within browser router i want to call
in routes
and then within here i want to call
route so
route is going to define the rules right
and just to jog our memory
and what we want is when the user
navigates to the root url so that's
going to be just a forward slash we want
to load this component the stock
overview and when the user navigates to
slash detail
and then the name of the specific stock
so the symbol of that stock we want to
go to stock detail page
so how do we do that under route we have
to provide two things the specific route
or path that the user navigates to and
then the component should load so for
the first one
we want to go to the root path so we say
path equals
and then the specific path so it's just
the forward slash and that's going to
load up the stock
overview component so we have to import
that in here first of all so i'll do
import
stock overview page
and this is going to come from the pages
folder
and then we have stock overview page
and to load that component
we say element
equals
and then curly braces and then you
provide the component that's going to be
stock overview
and that's all you have to do
and so when the user navigates to this
specific path all react router dom does
is it loads this component onto the
screen that's it react router is
actually one of the simplest libraries
and that's all it's there to do
and we have to set up our next route
we'll say
route and then we'll say path equal so
what's the path for this specific route
well we want to do slash detail
and then you know whatever symbol
now i can't hard code a symbol right
because if i say you know msft for
microsoft then if they try to check any
other
company's stock it's not going to work
it's only going to match on msft so we
need a variable here that can be dynamic
and it can be anything the user selects
and the way we use variables in
react.org is you just do
colon
and then the name of the variable so i'm
going to use symbol but you can call it
whatever you want if you want to call it
stock you can do that but i'm going to
use symbol and it's important to name it
something that you can reference because
we will need to reference that variable
and so when the user navigates to this
we want to load a specific element so
we'll say element equals
and then we just do the same thing
and we have to import that component
first
and then we can just pass that into here
and then we'll close off this tag
and so now all the routing should be
done
and if we go back to our components uh
we've got everything loaded so let's
actually test this out so if i go to the
root path which we're already at so the
root path is just the forward slash we
can see we have stock overview page
and what i'm actually going to do is i'm
going to open this up in a new tab
and this will make it a little bit
easier to handle the routing so now if i
go to uh if we see the the root path we
can see the stock overview component
gets loaded and if i go to detail and
then just put in some random text it
doesn't matter because it's a variable
we should see that it should load the
stock detail page so our routing is set
and everything's good to go and we
really won't have to touch too much from
the routing side of things because uh
we've kind of got all of that said
already
and so i want to add one quick class so
if we go to our app.jsx i just want to
wrap this in a container class this is
just part of bootstrap everything kind
of has to be within a class called
container it's going to help with the
layouts
and once we get that set what i want to
do is i want to create a new folder
and i'm going to call this component so
this is going to contain all of our
react components that are not pages
themselves so these are just regular
react components
and if we take a look at the summary
page
you can see that we have three things we
have a logo then we have the
autocomplete bar and then we have the
table with the list of all of our stocks
so the way i'm going to
kind of divvy this up is that i'm going
to have two total components i'm going
to have an autocomplete component and
then i'm going to have the
table component
and so i'm just going to call this
autocomplete.jsx and i'm going to call
this one
stocklist.jsx
and so i'll create stock list
dot jsx
and then the other one is going to be
autocomplete
dot jsx
and i'm just going to copy these
components into there just as a baseline
and inside our stock overview page i'm
going to import both of those components
so we can load them onto the screen
and then now under this div i can just
render out both of those components
and we can see that in the stock
overview page we've got all three
components now or or two components plus
the page
and so
getting started with the stocklist
component this is where we get to have a
little fun where we can actually finally
start working with the finhub api and
fetching some data but before we do that
we want to
store a list of all of the
companies or the stocks a user wants to
track and we're going to start off by
just using the regular use state hook to
track that and you'll see that later on
in the project we'll actually refactor
that and actually make use of the
context api so that we can share this
data amongst multiple components
and so from the react library i'm going
to import
use state
and i'll also go ahead and import use
effect because we will have to use that
as well
and that's going to come from react
and i'm going to do use state
and then this is going to default to an
empty array so uh when you whatever you
pass into the use state hook this is
going to be the default state so it's
going to be an empty list of stocks
and then i'll say this equals
and then we'll say const and then we'll
we'll call this a watch list so it's
going to be a list of all the stocks
that the user wants to the user wants to
watch and then the function that we're
going to get to modify this list will be
called set watch list
okay and so this variable called
watchlist is going to return all of the
stocks they want to watch and if we ever
want to update it we make use of this
function
and actually instead of defaulting it to
an empty array just for development
purposes i'm going to hard code a couple
of different stocks so that we don't
have to manually go in add in a couple
and then
and then be able to fetch the data that
would just require too much work so
we'll add in a couple stocks at first as
a default and then we'll clear this out
once we're done with our project
and for now i'll just say maybe the user
wants the track of google
and we'll say microsoft
is the other one and then
amazon
okay
so when the user navigates to this
application they'll see data for these
three stocks by default
and i realized i actually made a mistake
um when we actually send the requests to
the finn hub api it expects everything
to be capitalized so i'm going to change
this to be gogl
and msft and
amzn
yeah that actually got me for a little
bit i forgot to capitalize it and i
think we should actually go to the
documentation
so if you go back to the fin hub website
and select documentation it's going to
open up a new tab
and it's going to show us how to
actually work with the api
and the first thing that we have to
understand is that
from an authentication perspective we
have to provide the token
as a parameter so we have to say token
equals api key for every single request
and that has to go
in the url or you can add it as a header
whichever one you prefer i'm going to go
with the first option
and the url that we have to send a
request to is going to be this https
colon slash finhub dot io slash api v1
so all of requests will go to this base
url and then we provide a specific path
depending on what data we want to
retrieve
and if we actually go down to the
documentation what we want to do is go
under stock price and then get quote
this is going to be the first
endpoint that we're going to access so
once again we take the root url and then
we go to slash quote and this is going
to give us information about a specific
stock and it specifically gives us
what's the current price what's the
change percent change what's the high
the low what was the open price as well
as the previous close
so it's going to give you everything we
need for our table and all we have to do
is just go to the slash quote endpoint
and then we have to do a question mark
and then here this is going to be
the uh query parameter so everything you
see after the question mark is going to
be a query parameter so this is kind of
providing the api uh specific data that
we're looking for so we say symbol
equals and then the name of the stock
that we want data for
and then we want to provide another
query parameter and you separate the two
with the and sign and then you have to
provide the token so for every request
we're going to have to add the token and
then for the specific quote endpoint we
have to provide the symbol so we can
just send this as an example and then
just update our token and that's going
to be the request that we need to send
in you can see that the documentation
actually pre-fills it with my token so
you could just copy this directly from
your
from your computer and it should work as
well
so let's work on getting this set up now
we can fetch data using the fetch api
that comes built in or we can make use
of a library like axios and um
i prefer to use axios there's no issue
with using the standard fetch api but it
does make it a little bit easier to work
with you know path parameters and query
parameters as well so i'm going to
install axios and i've actually already
got it installed but you can just search
for axios
and select the first one so this is the
one that we want
and you can see it's already installed
for me so i've already done this so go
ahead and do the same thing or if you
want you could just do it through the
standard method of just doing npm
install axios whichever one you prefer
now once we got axios installed what i'm
going to do is i'm going to create a new
folder
called apis
and this is going to contain all of the
files for our api and within this api
folder we're going to set up for one for
the finnhub api i'm going to call this
finhub.js
and here we're going to set up axios and
so i'm going to import axios from axios
and then we're going to do export
default because i'm going to export this
instance of axios i'm going to say axios
dot create so this create method creates
a
axios instance
and here we provide some configuration
options and the first one is going to be
base url
so you do base and you can see it's
going to auto complete and you want to
make sure that the ur and l are
capitalized
and here this is going to be the base
url for the finn hub api so if we go
back to the documentation
the base url is going to be from v1 all
the way to https so we'll copy that
and paste it in here
and make sure you don't have the forward
slash at the end you want to delete that
we just want it to end at v1 so by
default when we use axios now or the
spinhub.js api
it's always going to
set this as the base url and then we can
add in whatever specific endpoint we
want so if we want that slash quote
endpoint
we could basically just do a plus slash
quote and then uh axios will combine
them together so that you don't have to
retype this entire url out
and for now this is going to be all that
we need uh we'll make a few changes for
uh to this a little bit later
but we can go back to our components and
go to our stock list component
uh we can then oops it looks like i
accidentally deleted my use effect hook
so now we're going to use a use effect
hook so that we can fetch data and i'm
going to import my axios
so i'll do import
binhub
from
dot dot slash so we're gonna go up a
folder
api slash
and then
binhub
and so now we'll call the use effect
hook
and we'll pass in a function
and right here we want to specify the
dependency array and the dependency
array is going to determine when this
hook runs
if i don't pass a dependency array
what's going to happen is this hook is
going to run every single time the
component renders which would mean we
would be fetching data every time it
renders and that's not what we want we
only want to fetch data when the
component mounts so the component mounts
we fetch the data that's all and to make
it so that it only runs when the
component mounts you pass in an empty
array and that's it
and i'm going to define a function in
here called fetch data
and this is going to contain all of the
logic for fetching that specific quote
and i'm going to wrap everything in a
try catch block in case we get any
errors
and in here we can then do finhub
dot get
and for the url it's just going to be
slash quote
right because if we go back to the
documentation right we just want to do
quote
and since we already specified the base
url it's our it's automatically going to
add that and then we want to specify the
symbol and then our token of course
so i'll say
question mark
symbol equals and then just
we can grab microsoft
and then we'll do and and then we'll do
token equals and then we'll copy our
token
and paste it in here
and then we will save this to a variable
and i'll just call this response
and remember this is a asynchronous
action so we want to await it
and because we're making use of a weight
here this function has to be an async
function
and then down right below that i'm just
gonna do a console.log response
and then we'll actually call this
fetchdata function so that we can
actually fetch the data
and it looks like there's a typo this
has to be a capital h
all right and it looks like
it did fetch something so let's take a
look at the data
and if we take a look at the object this
is uh what axios return so it shows us
the original config which is under
config the data is actually going to be
the response we get back from the api so
that's usually what we're most concerned
with and if we go under data you can see
we did the closing price the change
price the high low so it looks like we
were successfully able to get this data
and moving forward um we'll i'll
probably just show you everything we get
back from the api in the console in a
separate window just because it allows
me to make it a little bit bigger and
easier for you guys to read so we can
see that the data was shown up here as
well
all right so that's great
uh now we were able to fetch this data
however i don't want to have to copy and
paste the token into every single
request because this isn't going to be
the only component that has to
get data from the api and i don't want
to have to copy this token around all
over the place so what we can do is
first of all
uh what i would prefer to do is go under
our apis
and here for our axios instance we can
already pre-bake our token so i'm going
to create a variable i'm going to call
this token or key whatever you want to
call it i'll call this token
and i'm going to paste my token in there
and what i can do is i can add in
another property called params
and then here i'll say
token
is going to be set to token
okay and so now when we send requests i
don't actually have to include this
token parameter
because it's going to come built in with
the finhub axios instance
and so we could see that it was actually
able to get the data again and on top of
that the great part about axios is that
i can more dynamically add these query
parameters without hard coding it into
the url
by removing this and i can actually just
add in an object so i can pass in an
object here
and i can say params
and then i can provide the symbol
which is going to be set to
microsoft
yep and looks like it worked so now once
again we got the data
from the api server so this is just a
different way of configuring axios and i
think it's a little bit cleaner and
easier because now we don't have to
provide the token on every single
request and now our request is
pretty simple we just have to provide
the symbol
okay so now that we can fetch data from
the api let's save this in some state
variable so i'm going to call the use
effect hook the use state hook again
i'm just going to leave this empty
and we're going to store this in a
variable
and i'll just call this stock so this is
going to contain all of our stock data
and then we want set stock so we want to
manipulate that
and so after this console.log i can just
do a
set
stock
and then we want to set it to response
dot data
and the reason why i said response.data
is if you take a look at the response
remember the response is going to
contain the config which is the axios
config is going to contain the headers
request we just want the data so that's
why i said response.data
now one thing to keep in mind when
fetching data with the use effect hook
is there's a possibility that you know
after we sent this response out
that our component actually got
unmounted and so what we don't want to
do is end up calling set stock on a
component that's already unmounted so
how do we prevent that well it's
actually very simple what i'm going to
do is i'm going to define a variable and
i'll say let and i'll just say is
mounted this is going to be a boolean
and i'm going to say this is set to true
so what happens is when the component
mounts right this is going to run when
it mounts it's going to set mounted to
true
and then before we do set stock
we just do a little check
and i say if
is mounted is set to true
then we can move this up into that if
statement
that's all and all we have to do is then
when the component unmounts
we call a return to the use effect hook
so this is uh this function that we pass
to return is going to run whenever the
uh the component gets unmounted so i can
say
when the component gets unmounted
i would just want to set
is mounted
equals false
and so that way when we get a response
back and the component got unmounted
this check will run and it will not pass
and it'll just skip right over it
because we don't want to accidentally
call set stock on an unmounted component
now the next thing that we want to do is
now that we're able to fetch some data
we want to fetch data for everything in
our watch list
right now we have three different items
and there's a couple of ways of going
about doing this
the first thing that we can do is i can
just take this
and just copy it
three times and then i can just change
the symbol to be
the specific
uh stock names so we'll have google
microsoft and then amazon
and i could maybe create a
array i'll just say const
responses equals empty array
and i'll just put a number after these
and then we can say responses
dot push
now do response one
and we can just copy this
three times
and just change this to be response two
and then response three
and then for set stock instead of
sending response that data we could just
send the array responses
and so let's test that out
okay so after i fix that little typo we
can see that
it printed out all of the responses and
i've got the responses for
uh this is going to be google the next
one is going to be
for microsoft and the last is going to
be for amazon so we were able to get all
three of these however there's a couple
things i don't like about this right
let's ignore the fact that i'm hard
coding all of the different companies
because this is going to be a dynamic
list that should be changed by the user
but what i don't like about this is this
is happening sequentially so what
happens is we send a request to get the
information for google and then once we
get the only once we get the information
back from google we'll then move on to
response 2 and get the data from
microsoft once we get the data from
microsoft we'll then go and get the data
all right this is very slow because
we're doing one at a time we're sending
one request to the api server and in
fact if you go to the
chrome developer tools
and you go to network
and so if you take a look at how long
these requests take we can see the first
request where we send the request to get
google it takes
all of this time only once we get the
response back
can we then go to the second request
and then only once we get the response
back can we go to the third request so
it's doing these things one at a time
and that causes this to be a very slow
process and if the user wants to see
um you know the data for 20 stocks
imagine sending each one of those
one at a time in series i would prefer
to be able to send all of these requests
all at once and then the api server just
responds them as they come in and that
way it should basically take the time it
takes to send one request because we're
sending all of them
concurrently so how do we do that in
javascript well what i'm going to do is
i'm going to delete all of these
or actually instead i'm going to leave
those
and i'm going to show you guys
a tool called
promise
dot all
when you call promise.all you provide a
list
you provide a list of promises and it's
going to
try to resolve all of them at once so
it's going to send a request for all
three of these guys all at once and so i
could just copy this config
starting from finhub
and paste it into here
and then just do a comma and then the
second one
and then finally we'll grab the last
response
so now i can delete all of these
and all we have is this promise.all
which has three different promises
getting sent to one for google one for
microsoft one for amazon and i can
delete these
and i'll set this to be const promises
equals promise that all
or actually let me just change this to
be responses
so we don't have to change anything else
and now if i refresh this
and it looks like it hit the api limit
so i'm going to give it a couple seconds
because we have at most 60 requests
uh per minute so i'll give it a minute
or two and then we'll run the request
again and we'll take a look at um how
quickly it works now
okay so um because of the way react
works uh it actually
runs that use effect hook twice it
basically mounts the component twice so
ignore everything from here down what we
care about is the first three and notice
the
the timing of the three requests they
all get fired off at the same time and
they all roughly complete around the
same time so look how much quicker that
is versus sending one and then only
after that's done we send the next one
and then only when that's done we then
send so this goes all at once and it
basically takes the time of one request
because we're sending it all
concurrently
and so that's all done because of this
promises promise.all
method
so that's great however we're still hard
coding all of the companies we don't
want to hard code the companies
we want to take whatever's in the watch
list and then create these dynamically
so how exactly do we do that
well it's actually pretty easy
what we're going to do is we're going to
make use of the javascript map method
and
what our main goal is right we have a
list of companies
and for each one of these we want to
take this string and we want to generate
a promise so we want to send a request
using this axios instance and we want to
do this for each one of these three
and so anytime you want to
make a change to every item of an array
uh you want to make use of the map
method i want to show you how that works
so here i have this uh
this uh array right here with the the
three stocks like we had before and
let's say that after each stock i just
want to add an exclamation so i want to
end up with an array where each stock
has an exclamation
how do i do that
well it's pretty easy using the map
method i'll say
all we have to do is i'll say map
i'll say well we call stocks
and then we call the map method
and what this is going to do is this is
going to iterate through every item
in the
array and so we have to pass a function
to tell it what do we want to do and
this function gets one argument
uh the well actually it gets multiple
arguments but we're going to focus on
just one which is
the element
and then we have whatever we want
the function to do so what is the
element well as we iterate through this
array the element
is going to be whatever the current item
is that we're iterating over so the
first time this runs it's going to be an
element is going to be set to google the
second time this runs the element can be
called microsoft and then the third time
it runs it's going to be amazon in fact
if you want to make this a better name
we can call this stock so this
represents one of the stocks
and then what this function returns is
going to be what you want to change it
to
so we have stock which is going to be
set to whichever one we're iterating
over so the first time it's going to be
equal to google so i'm just going to put
this in the comments so this is going to
be equal to google
or
google
and what we want to do is we want to add
an exclamation rate we want an
exclamation like that so all we have to
do is just return what do we want to
change it to so we want stock
plus exclamation that's it
or you could do string interpolation and
say um
stock
and then exclamation
and so when it iterates through google
it'll add the exclamation then when it
iterates through microsoft it'll add the
exclamation and then when it goes
through amazon it'll add the exclamation
and then we could set this to a value so
i'll say this is my modified
stocks because the thing about the map
method is that it returns a brand new
array
and if i do a console.log
modified stocks
save this and then do a node
test.js
all right you could take a look at the
result
it successfully added the exclamation
afterwards
so we get access to each item as it
iterates through it and then whatever we
return in the function
is going to be
entered into the new array
and so we're going to do the same exact
thing with this but instead of adding an
exclamation point we're going to
generate a promise or a request to our
api by calling the same thing
so i'm going to delete
all of this
instead we could just call
our watchlist array
i'll say watchlist dot map
okay and once again we're going to pass
in a function
we get access to the stock or the
element that we're iterating over
and then whatever we return from this
function should be a
request to our api so i'll say return
i will do finhub
dot get
slash quote
and then params
and remember we want symbol
and we'll set that to be stock because
stock represents the symbol that we're
currently iterating over and we just
pass that in there
so now if we test this out
and i realized i forgot to do an await
now if we take a look at responses
we should see that we have now
successfully gotten
all three of our requests and if we go
to our network section we can see that
all three of them gets uh got sent out
at the same time so that's exactly what
we want
and so i think we've pretty much done
everything we needed to do there if you
want to you can set the use state uh
hook to be uh by default just an empty
array it doesn't really matter however
um before we kind of wrap things up and
move on to rendering out all of this
information uh inside a table if we
actually do take a look at this
console.log right here which is uh
printing out all of the response objects
before we uh store it into our state
there's something i don't like about
this
and if we go to our console
and we take a look at what the output
looks like this is what's getting stored
in our component state and if i open up
the first one take a look this isn't
actually just the data that we get from
the api this is the response object from
axios so we get the configuration we get
the data which definitely what we want
we get the headers and the request and
most of this information we don't care
about why would the component care about
the configs of our axios request it
doesn't why would it care about the
headers it doesn't what about the
request it does it the only thing our
component cares about
is the data i don't want anything else
other than just the data so for each of
these three items
of these three requests i want to go in
and extract the data
and just delete everything else because
we don't want to store unnecessary
information in our state
so ultimately what i want to do is and
i'm just going to create a new file here
this is just for demonstration purposes
you don't actually have to do this
yourself i'm just going to call this
demo.js
what i ultimately want to do is i want
to store in our state for each one of
the stocks an object that looks like
this so we have the data which is going
to contain all of our you know stock
data whatever it's called
and that's going to come from
the data object here
and then the next thing i want to do is
notice how inside the data it says
nothing about what stock this data is
for
so that's something we have to assign
ourselves we can't just extract it from
here in fact the information about where
the stock is
is actually within the config so if we
go to the config under params we can see
the symbol
so inside here we want data to come from
data
and then we want to whoop data to come
from data
i'm just going to put this in quotations
because the autocomplete's messing it up
and then for the symbol this is going to
come from config.params.symbol
so i want to store this information an
object that looks like this so before we
save it into our set state i'm going to
call the map method to iterate over all
of these things and extract
an object that looks exactly like this
so we are already familiar with the map
method so we could just do that again
and i'm going to delete this demo.js
and we'll go to our stock list
and right here
before we call set stock
i'm going to do a responses dot map
and we'll just say this is going to be
response
and like i said what do we want well
we first want to get the data which is
going to come from
response.data right that's going to be
data so the response which is you know
in this case the first response we want
the data property which is going to
return this
uh object here
and then i want to store information on
what is the symbol
and that's going to come from the
response
and i already forgot where it's coming
from but i believe it's config
params
symbol so
config
params
symbol
and
remember we want to return an object so
right now i didn't actually put it in an
object so let me
create that object and then
paste that in here
and then we return that object
and we'll store it inside a variable
called data
and then change the set stock to be data
and we'll save that
we'll go back to here
and i'm actually going to print out what
our data looks like
just to make sure everything looks good
and so now we can see that data has just
the
data that we're looking for and then
symbol is set to google so that's
exactly what we want now our state looks
exactly the way it should
so now what we can do is work on
rendering out this information inside a
table
so inside our table for the headers we
want one for the name
of the stock we're going to have one for
the last the change the change
percentage the high low open and peak so
this is all going to go inside a table
element
so in our return statement i'm going to
remove stock list
inside here we'll do a table
and i'm going to add a couple classes
that come from bootstrap
is going to be table
hover and then mt-5
so this is just the usual styling for
the table this uh we'll make it so that
when we hover our over one of the stocks
it's going to change the color so we
know which one we're hovering over
and then this is just going to add a
little margin to the top
then we want to create our
t head right so this is going to contain
all of those headers that we just went
over
and i'm going to add some inline styles
which is nothing more than just changing
the color
and now we'll do tr
we'll do th scope equals
this is going to be the name
and i'm just going to copy this several
times
all right so now if we take a look we
can see we've got our table with the
different headers
now we can add the actual data
and the way we're going to render out
this data because remember all of our
data right now is stored inside this uh
stock
state uh is once again we're going to
use our favorite
map method
so i'm going to call uh
i'm going to do a curly braces so that
we can provide some javascript and we're
going to map through this so we'll do
stock.map
stock data
and we want to return
and so for the the row it's going to be
th
and here we're going to provide
the stock data
dot symbol
and for the tr i'm actually going to add
in a class
this is going to be table dash row
and remember because this is react we
have to provide a key for each element
we return in a list i'll say key equals
and this is going to be stock data dot
symbol we'll use the symbol as the key
and so for
this right then we can do td
uh the next one's going to be
stock data whoops
we want stock data dot
data dot c
next one is going to be stock
stockdata.data.d
i'm actually just going to copy this a
few times
next one's going to be dot dp
and then we have h
l
oh
and then pc
and it looks like i made a little typo
here this shouldn't be
dot symbol in the curly braces
all right and now if we go back to our
website
when i clear this let's refresh this
just make sure there's no errors
we could see that we now have our chart
and it's automatically going to get
updated depending on what is our stock
state
a couple of final things that i want to
do from an aesthetic purpose for our
stock list component is that first of
all we should color code the change and
change percentage value depending on if
it um if the stock went up or if the
stock went down so we're just basically
checking is the change negative okay we
want to make it red if it's positive we
want to make it green
in addition to that um we also want to
add in an icon showing the direction uh
that it moved so if the stock went down
we want the down icon if it went up we
want the up icon so those should kind of
go hand in hand
with the change value
so just to kind of hard code something
if we go to the
this td right here
this is for the
change and the change percentage if we
want to change the color using bootstrap
we can do class name
equals and then text
dash success
that'll give us a green color and then
if we change the bottom one to be class
name equals
text dash danger that's going to be the
red color
so now you can see under the change
where we have text success we can see
it's green and then when we see text
danger it's going to be red so we have
to define a function that'll check the
value
of what direction the stock went and
then update this specific class
depending on
if it was positive or negative
and so what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to delete
success
and danger so for these two we're just
going to have it say text dash
text dash and then what i want react to
do is call a function that's going to
contain the logic for determining
uh if the stock went up or down
and so first of all we're going to
provide some javascript
and we're going to use template literals
and here i'm going to
pass in a function that i haven't
defined yet
called change color
and what we should do is we should pass
in the stock
data.data.d so that's going to determine
the direction that
the stock went
and i'm going to define this function
now it's going to be called change color
i'm just going to define it right above
our use effect hook so it's going to be
const change color
and then it's going to get in some
variable and i'll just call this change
and we're just going to use the ternary
operator to do a return and we'll say if
the change was positive so that means
the stock went up
we're going to return the text success
and if it was not positive so that means
it's negative we're going to return
danger
okay and so now we can see that it's
automatically updating the color
everything was negative in this case but
if we have a positive stock then that
should automatically turn green i think
our entire stock market's going down so
everything's just red at this point
we're gonna do the same exact thing for
this guy right here i could just copy
this
and just paste it in
and we've got these updating dynamically
as well
next thing that we have to do is add the
icons and i'm going to make use of a
library
and so we'll go to the package here and
and we'll install a package called react
dash icons
and this is the one we want right here
so i'll add this
so for this library if we take a look at
the documentation we can see that it
supports icons from several different
um
you know frameworks uh we since we're
using bootstrap we might as well just
stick to bootstrap icons
and the way that it works is that all
you have to do is you do import the icon
name and then you do react dash icon bs
for bootstrap and all we have to do is
then find our specific icons so it's
going to be this one right here bs fill
carrot downfill
and if i search for carrot
we should also be able to find the up
one so bs fill carrot upfill as well and
so if you just select this it's going to
copy it into our clipboard which is
awesome
and now if we go to the top of our file
i'm going to do import
paste that in
from
react dash icons
slash bs
and this is just a regular component now
so i can go down here
and after this i can just put in another
component
all right and now you can see that
you can see that the component is right
there next to it so that's all we have
to do however we have to
select the right icon depending on what
direction it's going and so what we're
going to do is we're going to set up
another function just like this change
color function i'm going to create a
render icon function that's going to do
essentially the same thing
so here i'm going to delete this
and in here we'll pass in
our function render icon
and we'll pass in the same information
which is going to be stock data
dot data dot d
and then i'm going to define our
function
const render icon
get access to the change again
and we're gonna do the same thing change
greater than zero
we're going to return
and actually have to import the other
one as well
so we want the up carrot up fill
and if it goes down then we're going to
return the other one
and i can copy this
and paste it into this one as well
now if we take a look
we could see that all of them have an
icon
so i think that's a good stopping point
on the stock list component there's
still a couple more features we're going
to have to add to it but i want to take
a break from it for now and i want to
move on to the autocomplete component
and just to remind you guys what this
component does it's going to be a simple
input field where the user can search
for available stocks
so if the user wants to find you know
tesla you'll just start typing in the
letters
tsla
and you'll see that it should be able to
search through that and it's an
autocomplete so if you actually go slow
enough and i just type in ts it's going
to find all of the companies that start
with ts
and then i can just keep adding another
letter
and then it's going to keep narrowing
down the field until we get to what
we're looking for and then from there we
can then select the company and then
it's going to get added to the list
and i want you to take a look at the
network request right the for each
letter they type it's going to
automatically send a request back to the
api
so for the headers you can see that
uh in this case the query it just has
the letter t
and the next one has the s
l
a so we send a request for every letter
and you know we can obviously customize
this so we don't send it for every
single letter the user types however i
wanted to keep this component as simple
as possible so let's tackle creating
this component and so we'll go to our
autocomplete.jsx
and within here in this parent div i'm
going to add in a couple of class names
uh it's going to be the width is going
to be set to 50
i'm going to add some padding
i'm going to give make it rounded
and then the margin is going to be auto
so it centers
and within this div we'll now add our
input actually before we add our input
i'm going to add another div
i'm going to give it a couple classes so
it's going to be form dash floating
and then drop-down
and within this div we'll then add our
input
and for the input we're going to add
some inline styles
mainly just the background color
i'm going to give this an id of search
type is going to be text
and i give this a class name of form
control
this is coming from the bootstrap
library
and i'll also give it a placeholder
of search
and if we just take a peek at what this
looks like that's pretty much what i
want it to look like
and for my autocomplete
i'm going to disable the built-in
autocomplete
and then under the input i'm going to
add a label
we'll do html4 this is going to point to
search so this is going to match up with
the id of this
input field
and the label is going to say
search
all right and just to double check let's
just take a look all right everything
looks good
now the next thing is we want the drop
down so how do we make the drop down
well there's all this is going to be
pretty easy with the bootstrap library
for the drop down
under the label we can create a ul so
i mean we can really render anything in
the drop down and then i'm just going to
add a couple of
items
i'll just say
stock one
two and three
and for this ul we're gonna add in
some class names
mainly drop down dash menu
and that's all we really have to do so
this is our drop down and i'm going to
actually go back to my browser for a
second
okay so you'll see that right now
there's no drop down however if i
inspect this and go to elements we can
inspect this
and then go down you can see that the
drop down is there it's just right now
at the moment
if we go to computed we can see that the
display is going to be set to none
right now the drop down menu is set to
display none so you don't see it so it's
still actually on there but it's just
being hidden and that's because when you
assign drop down dash menu from the
bootstrap library it's automatically
going to give it a display of none and
if you want to show it using the
bootstrap library we have to add in a
class called show and so now the drop
down actually shows so this simple class
is what is what's going to determine if
we show the drop down or not so this is
something to keep in mind and make sure
you keep that on the top of your head
when we're implementing the logic of you
know rendering out all of the data once
we start searching for it
the next thing that we have to do is we
have to make this a controlled input and
this is going to be like with any other
standard input in react so i'm going to
import the ustade hook
and to make this work i'm going to
create a variable called search and set
search
so this is going to represent whatever
the user is trying to search and i'll do
use date
and default is going to be an empty
state
and then in my input field
we're going to set the value of the
input to be set to search
and then we're going to set a on change
parameter whenever the user types in
something
and i'm going to say we're going to pass
in a function
and we're going to say that
set search
set that to be the value of
e.target.value
okay so what we're doing here is
i'm saying that whenever the user types
in you know a letter it's going to
trigger this on change which is saying
uh get the value of that of the letter
that we just changed or whatever is our
input field and set that to the set
search function so that we can update
our state
and then the value of our input will be
synced to whatever
our state is so that's how we make this
a controlled input
and we can see everything types out just
fine
and if we can actually go back to the
browser
type here
and go to my redux dev tools
extension and go to the autocomplete we
should see that the state should match
up with whatever's typed
okay looks like everything's good
and now the next thing that we want to
do is implement the fetching data logic
so i'm going to import the use effect
hook
and then we're going to call the use
effect hook
and we'll do the same thing that we did
before we'll pass an error function
and before we get started sending a
request or implementing the logic let's
go back to the documentation
and take a look at what endpoint we need
for searching
and the one we want is under stock
fundamentals and under symbol lookup
so you send a get request that's going
to be the method
and you send it to the slash search
endpoint and you provide one query
parameter which is the letter q and then
whatever text the user searches for and
then this is what one of the results are
going to look like so it's going to
include the you know the type symbol
display symbol and then the description
and so that looks simple enough
so once again i'll do
we'll define a function called fetch
data
we'll put in our try catch block
and then below this we'll call fetch
data
and let's import our api our finnhub api
and now we can do a const response
equals and then we'll do
binhub.get
the endpoint is going to be the search
endpoint
and then params
well this is going to be set to
this queue and that will be set to the
value of whatever the user searches
we just say search
and this is an asynchronous operation so
we'll do a wait
and then i'll do a console.log
of response
so let's take a look at that
and so right away even though we haven't
typed anything it looks like it's fired
something and if i take a look at the
config
and get this is going to let's see
where's the params
yep params right here we could see that
we're sending it with a
empty
search and when it sends an empty search
to the api it returns everything so we
got an array with 11 000 results so
that's obviously not something what that
we want and so right there what i think
we should do is um
[Music]
we should first run a check
and say that only if
search
dot length
is greater than zero so if there's only
if there's at least one letter
that the user has searched then we call
fetch data
okay so let's reload this
and so these these first results are
just from this table
um but we can see that we didn't
actually uh search anything it didn't
actually try to send a request to the
search api so let's try um sending one
letter
and we can see that
it did in fact
send a request and we could see that the
results as a whole bunch of stocks are
companies with the letter a in it
let's add another letter
and this time if we take a look at the
config we can see that the search is a n
and the data we know we now have 28
results
we do the letter e now we should see
that we now have
29 results
and let's try one more letter
and we can see that we have 25 results
okay so it looks like it's working
um but one thing
that is happening with the use effect
hook is that right now since there's no
dependency array it's going to run every
single time every single time the
component re-renders
and we don't necessarily want that we
only want this to run anytime the search
changes right
because
why else would we want this to run it's
all we only want to send a request
whenever the user has changed the search
either added a letter deleted a letter
or made some change or pasted something
in so what we can do is under the
dependency array you just say search so
now this use effect hook will only run
when search changes
the next thing that we have to do is we
have to store the results someplace the
results from the api so i'm going to use
the use state hook again and i'm going
to call this a results
and down here what we're going to do is
i'm going to set results
to be
results dot data
sorry response.data
and once again just like the previous
component that we worked with with the
stock list we also want to do this is
mounted trick where we make sure that
the component is still mounted
and so we also have to perform the
return operation where we set that to be
false so i'll copy this
and we just do a check here is mounted
okay so let's uh let me go to my redux
or my react dev tools again i'm going to
go to my autocomplete component and
we're just going to take a look at the
state so if i type in the letter a
we could see that the state was now
set and it looks like the way that the
object was set it's a it's returning a
count and a result i just want the
result
i don't want the count in there as well
so i'm going to do response.data
dot result
let's try this again a
okay we've got the results that's
exactly what i want let's see if it
updates
right now there's 42
now there's 24
perfect now let me
change that to an a
we get 42 again and then if i
set it back down to zero
what do you think is going to happen
so after i search something notice how
the state doesn't get cleared out
the state still has that a search result
so what's happening here well if we go
back to our code
you can see here if it says that if
search dot length is greater than zero
we'll fetch data and in fetch data we
set the results however what happens if
we have a length of zero
a length of one and then go back down to
zero so we delete a letter
well at no point are we updating
set results to be back to an empty array
so what we have to do is just put an
else statement here
and just say
set results
to an empty array
and so that way if i type in the letter
a
i'll get 42 results again
and then when i delete it
it's going to hit that else statement
and then it's going to remove all the
entries
and i'm going to delete the unnecessary
console.logs
okay so we've got all the data fetching
logic implemented now we have to just
show the drop down
and so how do we do that remember i
talked about how all we have to do to
show the drop down is add this class
called show
and then it's going to show this drop
down so what i want to do is uh
implement a function
that's going to figure out if
if search has or if results is not empty
then i want to add the show class if
results is empty then i don't want to
show it
so i'm going to define a function
called um
render drop down
so this function is actually going to be
responsible for rendering this ul
so i'm actually going to
uh comment this out for now
that didn't work
and i'm going to put in a little logic
i'm going to say drop down
class equals and then we check if search
is a true value so if search has um you
know any text in it
then it's going to return true if search
is an empty string then it's going to
return false so if it's true and there's
some search in there then we're going to
return the class show because that's
what shows the drop down if not we're
going to return null
and then the rest of this class is going
to be responsible for
returning that ul so it's going to
render out that ul
and for class name
what i can do is
add a little trickery and i can say drop
down dash menu
and then i pass in
drop down class
so it's going to add in show if we have
some sort of search result
and for now i'm going to hard code some
lis again
okay so i type in a letter
and i realized we have to actually go
down here
and call that function render
render drop down
so if i type in a
you can see that now since there's a
search result it renders out the drop
down if i delete it it goes away
so that seems to be working
now all that we have to do is we have to
take the results that we have and render
out that information
so we'll go to our render drop down
we'll just delete these lis
and once again we're gonna do
our favorite map method
so i will say results.map
we have our li
let me add in a class name
of drop down dash item
and then what i want is we have two
values there's going to be
result.description
and then result dot symbol so i want the
company name and then followed by the
result uh of the symbol of the company
and i actually want that
wrapped in parentheses
so i'll do parentheses
let's try this again
all right look at that so i got the
company name followed by the ticker
and we can see this is a massive list
and what i want to do is i want to
implement some scrolling and i want to
hard code the
height of this
uh of this drop down so it's not going
all the way down like that i don't like
the way that looks
and to change that under the ul we're
going to add in some inline styles
the first thing is going to be the
height i'm going to set this to be
500 pixels
overflow y
so this is going to set this to be
scroll
uh overflow
x i want to
i want to hide the scroll bar in the x
direction
and i also want to add change the cursor
to be a pointer
so the user is aware that he can select
one of them
let's try this again
that looks much better you can see we
can scroll through the results
and one other thing is that since we're
rendering out a list of items
just like with any other list in react
we have to provide a key so i'm going to
set the key to be
the symbol again so we'll say
result
dot
symbol
so now that we've set up the
autocomplete functionality the next
thing that we want to do is after a user
searches for a list of companies once
they find the company that they want to
add to their list they should be able to
select it and then it should show up on
this list
so we should set up a on click event
handler
so that when they click on a specific li
it should then add it to the list of
stocks that the user watches
now the problem with this is that the
list of
stocks that a user wants to watch is
currently in the stock list component
under the watch list state
so our autocomplete component does not
have access to the state of the stock
list component so we're in a little bit
of a pickle
and i've set up a powerpoint just to
kind of quickly show what the issue is
and how we can tackle
the
the issue and some of the different
solutions that we have at hand
in the stock summary page we have
basically three components we have the
stock summary page component itself
which is responsible for rendering out
the stock list component and the
autocomplete component
and the stock list component has the
list of stocks the user wants to watch
that he's storing in a use state hook
and the variable's called watchlist and
the problem with this is that
unfortunately the autocomplete component
does not have access to the watch list
so when the autocomplete component wants
to add something to the watch list at
the moment he cannot do that so we have
a couple of different options the
simplest solution to this is to
lift the state
of this watchless state up a component
specifically up to the stock summary
page that is a parent component to both
of these components
and then what we can do is then we can
pass that information down um as props
to stockless and autocomplete
and that would work just fine however
what i want to do is i want to make use
of the context api i think this is good
for learning purposes and you can take a
look at how we can create global state
using the context api
and the way that the context api works
is actually very simple what's going to
happen is we're going to create a
component called a provider component
and this is really fundamentally just a
regular react component that wraps your
entire application
and so by wrapping your entire
application in this provider component
what it does is it allows individual
components
to access its state so we can move the
watchlist state up to the provider
component and then the stock list and
the autocomplete components can then
query the state and get access to that
state directly
and any other components in our
application can access it directly
without having to pass it down as props
so that's what we're gonna do moving
forward we're gonna implement a
a context to store our watch list and
give us functions uh that'll manipulate
being able to add and remove items from
our watch list
so let's go ahead and implement our
context i'm going to create a new folder
in our source directory called context
this is going to store all of our
context we just have one for this
project
i'm going to call this
watchlist
context
dot jsx
and to create a context we're going to
import create context from the react
library so i'll do import
create context
from react
and then to actually create the context
all we have to do is export cons i'm
exporting it because we're going to have
to import it in another file
and then just provide the name of your
context so i'm going to call this watch
list context
and then we call create context
and we have now successfully created a
context
after we create the context what we have
to do is we now have to create that
special provider component to wrap our
application in that provider's component
that provider component is responsible
for passing data down to any components
that's interested in receiving that data
and to create this component it's just a
regular react component almost 100
identical we just do export const and
then i'm going to call this watchlist
context provider
you can call this component anything you
want but i usually just like to grab the
name of the context and then add the
word provider afterwards
and then we'll pass in the props
and then we have to
return
and this is the only difference
so we're going to return
a special component called watch list
context
so we're grabbing the context right
and from there we can grab something
called a provider component
and that's all you got to do
and this needs the dot provider as well
okay and so what we can do now is we can
take this provider component and wrap
our entire application and our
application can have access to any data
they want
and when i say any data at once it means
what i mean is any data within this
component
because like i said
this component is just a regular react
component
that can make use of the use date hook
the use effect hook any other hooks that
you want
and so the stock list has access to the
watch list and i want to make this watch
list accessible to all components what
i'm going to do is i'm actually just
going to take this from here remove it
from here and i'm going to move this
exact use state hook into my context
because remember my provider component
is just a regular react component so i
can just paste that in there and i can
now manage my watch list within my
provider
so how do i actually pass this data down
to my other components well inside this
component here i have a value prop and
here i can pass down whatever i want so
if i want to pass down watch list i can
and this is perfectly fine but i'm going
to in the future pass down a few other
pieces of information so the data that i
want to pass down in the value prop i
actually want it to be an object
and this is just an example of what i
want it to look like it should be an
object
obviously watchlist
should get passed down
and i will also have an extra function
to add a stock to the list to the watch
list as well as delete a stock
from the watch list as well so that's
what i wanted to look like so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to remove this
instead of just passing watch list i'm
going to pass down an object because i
want an object and right now i just have
a watch list but we'll implement the
logic for those other things in a second
and i'll remove this
so our
context and our provider component are
done we now have to take our provider
component and wrap our entire
application so if we go to myapp.jsx
and it looks like it already got
imported but
i'll just type that in real quick for
you so it's going to be import
watch list context provider we want the
provider not the context
from
context
watch list context
and now we have to take this special
component and wrap our entire
application
so technically you don't actually have
to wrap your entire application you just
wrap it in whatever subset of components
should have access to that provider so
i'm just going to
wrap my entire application just to keep
it simple and i'm going to call my watch
list context provider
and i take the bottom one and then just
move it under browser router so now if
you actually take a look at our
application
our actual application is this
and all of these components within this
watchlist
context provider have access to that
value prop that we're passing down
and i'm it's it's throwing an error and
that's just because i'm using this use
state hook but i never imported it so
we'll import it
okay so everything's done
no errors but interestingly enough
nothing is being rendered onto our
screen what's happening well we know
that we changed the watchlist context
provider and we added in here so that's
obviously breaking it but let's
understand why it's breaking
so notice how our application starting
from browser router is now being passed
into our watchlist context provider as a
child prop right it's no different than
you know if i had like a an h2
and then i'm providing
you know some text right some text is a
child prop i'm passing it in between the
tags
so if i go to my context provider
take a look at what we're rendering we
get the props but we're not doing
anything with it right we just have our
context provider and that's it so we
have to tell our context provider hey
let's render all of our child props
normally like they should be so all we
do is just do props dot children so this
is going to render all of the context
between our provider tags
okay and now if you take a look
everything is working as it should
if we take a look at our app it's
working and more importantly if i go to
my watchlist context provider in my
react dev tools
we can see that
our state is being there and is working
and we can see that
everything looks to be good and now our
next task is going to be how can we make
it so our components have access to the
state within our provider
okay so now to make it so our stock list
component actually grabs the watch list
from our
um from our context instead of storing
this himself we're gonna actually remove
this
i'm gonna delete this it's gonna break
our application that's okay
and to retrieve
the data being passed down in this value
prop what we have to do is we have to
make use of a specific hook called use
context
so i'm going to import use context
and then we just say use context
and then we have to pass in the a
reference to the actual context
which is watchlist context so we have to
import that as well
i'll say import
watch list context remember this is the
context not the provider
okay and then we store this in a
variable
you know const value
but that's going to return
this entire value prop
if you want we can just do a
console.log a value
and if we take a look you can see that
we get access to an object with the
watch list
so that's perfect
that's all we have to do to get access
to anything passed down from a provider
now we don't need access to the entire
value we just want access to watch list
at the moment so i'm going to
destructure out watch list
and now our app is going to work exactly
as it should
and i need to remove that console.log
all right perfect
so now we can actually go back into the
autocomplete
component and implement the logic
for
adding a new stock but
what i want to do is i don't want to
store that logic within the autocomplete
component i want to store that in my
context and i want the context to pass
down a function so that the only thing
the autocomplete
component has to know what to do is just
call that function
so let's go back to our context
and i'm going to define a couple of
functions so the first one is going to
be add stock how do we add a stock to
our watch list
so this is going to be
function
and this function the
autocomplete component is going to pass
the name or the symbol of the stock and
all we have to do is say
if
or
and all we have to do is just say set
watch list
and then we
spread the current so we copy over the
current watch list
and then we add in the new one and the
new stock and that's it however this is
going to create one issue
and that is that what happens if we try
to add a stock that's already in this
list right let's see google's already in
there and then the user searches google
and then tries to add it well now we're
going to end up with two googles and
that would look stupid in our
application we don't want to have the
same stock listed twice so we have to
perform a check to make sure that the
stock that's passed into this function
doesn't already exist in the watch list
easiest way to do that we could just do
an if statement and just say watch list
and then we call the index
of and then we pass in the stock and if
this equals equals equals negative one
that means it's not currently in that
list so only if it's not in the list
will we
add it in
and so that's all the logic for adding a
stock let's now implement the logic for
deleting a stock
and to delete
a specific stock from a list we can call
watchlist
dot filter
and this is going to iterate over the
array and we'll get access to the
specific element it's iterating over
and we'll just say we want to return if
element
does not equal equal
stock so that means it's going to go
through the list
in our current watch list and it's going
to find all of the entries that do not
match the stock that's passed into this
function and if they do not match then
we will keep it but if they do match
we'll delete it that's all
and then this is going to return a new
array and so all we have to do is just
then call set
watchlist
and then pass the result of that into
set watch list
and then we're going to pass these down
so i'll do
add stock and delete stock
so now that we have the functionality
for adding stock i'm going to go to our
autocomplete component
and actually it looks like i have an
error hold on let me
yeah i'm not sure what happened there
but i just saved this file again and
seems to fix the issue so it doesn't
look like there's anything wrong but
let's go to our autocomplete component
and let's set up that uh use context
hook
i'm going to say
const
which i'll just say use context
and this is going to be the watch list
context and let's just copy the imports
from the other one so i'm going to copy
this
and then we'll import use context
and then what do we want
we just want to destructure out the add
stock
and once we get that what we want to do
is on the specific li
for the result we're going to set up a
on click
event handler
and here
we're going to pass an anonymous
function
that's going to call ad stock
and we're going to pass in the
result.symbol
so this is just when the user clicks on
one of the results
it's um
let me find an actual stock uh when it
clicks on this
it's going to pass the symbol
of that specific company to the add
stock function that we get from the use
context which will then go to the use
context and then i'll add it to the list
so i'm going to go to inet we'll search
that
and then we'll click on this
okay and this thing still stays open but
that's okay we'll fix that
and i don't think it actually worked
so let me actually go back to the
website
okay so let me try this again
okay so it looks like there's some sort
of issue
let's go back to my autocomplete and
figure out what i did wrong
i did an on click
we call ad stock
and
it looks like i figured out the issue so
what's happening here is that when i
select
anet it is technically getting added to
the watch list
and i can actually see that by going to
my react
dev tools and going to my watchlist
context provider we can see anec got
added but the problem is is that
once it gets added if we go to our watch
list context
sorry our stock list component so this
is the component that renders out the
table
it runs this use effect hook
and this use effect hook is responsible
for getting the quotes of all of the
items that are in the watch list
however if you take a look at when this
use effect hook runs it only runs
when the component mounts so after it
mounts it does not matter how many items
we add to the watch list it's never
going to run again so we want this to
run every time watch list changes so all
we have to do is just pass that into the
dependency so we'll just pass in watch
list and so now anytime watch list gets
updated
a stock will get added and we can see
that it already got added in there
so that's why it wasn't getting updated
so i'm going to refresh this and we'll
test this out again so i'll type in a
net
select it there we go it gets added in
perfect now i do want the drop down menu
to go away
after i select an item
so i'll go back to my autocomplete
and this on click event handler
i'm going to actually
remove this shorthand notation i'm going
to add in two steps so
it'll be
add stock again
result dot symbol
and then afterwards what we want to do
is we want to clear out the search and
when we clear out the search it'll
automatically remove the drop down
so i'll say search
set search
so we're calling that hook right here
and we're gonna set the search for our
input to be empty and when it's empty
the drop down will lose or it'll get the
uh extra it'll lose the show
class which means it'll be hidden from
there on out so let's try this again i'm
going to save this
select this and we can see the drop down
goes away
so the last thing that we have to
implement from the summary page is the
delete functionality so we're removing
an item from the list however there's
something i want to
show you guys
when it comes to
event propagating within react and the
only way for me to show you guys the
issue would be to first implement the
detail page
so we're actually going to take a break
from the summary page we're going to the
last thing of removing the item we're
going to cover that at the end of the
project
instead i want to move on to the detail
page and just to kind of reiterate how
this is supposed to work when i select
on a stock when i select in a row take a
look at the path right now it's the root
path i select this it then goes to
detail then the name of the stock and
then it loads up the detailed page so
let's implement that this is going to be
done through react router and you'll see
that it's actually pretty easy
and we made use of the apex charts
library to build out the charts and
you'll see that it'll actually be dead
simple doing that as well
so let's go back to our app
and let's go to our stock list component
and let's find our
uh our specific row so when a user
clicks on a row we want to call an on
click event handler
and right now i'm just going to have
this call a function
and this function is going to be called
handle
stock
select so let's define this function
and what we want to do is when we select
a specific row we want to tell react
router which is our routing library to
route to a url of slash detail slash
stock name how do we do that well react
router comes with a built-in hook
that makes it very easy so let's import
this hook from react router
we'll do import
use navigate
from
react dash router
dom
and now we'll just do a const
navigate equals
use
navigate
okay and so now if we want to go to
another path or url we just use this
navigate object
so i'll say
navigate
and then all i have to do is just pass
in the url that we want to for the user
to
so we want to go to detail
slash and then the stock name so we have
to get the stock name so we'll say that
um
the event handler has to accept it as an
argument so we'll say um
symbol
so the symbol of the stock and then
we can just do string interpolation and
then just pass in symbol
so now when we actually call this
when it gets selected we have to pass in
the symbol so where is the symbol it's
stock
data dot symbol
i'm just copying what's here
and that should be all we have to do
actually
so let's go
take a look
okay so if we take a look at the url
right now
we can see it's at the root url so this
is the equivalent of just a forward
slash
and so i'm going to select google
and we can see that it routes to slash
detail google and we can see the stock
detail page so everything is working
exactly the way we expect it however one
thing is
um
i want to be able to get the clicker
icon instead of the regular pointer
because i want to give the user a little
bit more feedback
and we can easily do that by passing an
inline style
and i can just say cursor is set to
pointer
now can see that we get a pointer
perfect
okay so let's go to our stock detail
page
now in our stock detail page the
page has to be aware of
the specific url because the symbol or
the the stock that we want to see detail
is in the url so how do we extract that
information from the specific url like
how do we get it
how do we get this value from the url
well once again we're going to make use
of the react router library
and we're going to use a hook
called use params so let me import that
so now i'll just do
[Music]
const
x equals use params so this will get all
of the parameters however we don't want
all of them i just want the symbol
right and that parameter
where that comes from the name is going
to come from our
original route so whatever we passed
here where it says detail and then the
variable this parameter we can just
extract out symbol
so here i can destructure out symbol
and
let's render out stock detail page
and then let's just
render out the
symbol to see if we can actually get
that information
so now if i select google we can see
stock detail page google so we were able
to get
that parameter
for the stock detail page what i'm going
to do is i'm actually going to fetch the
data within the stock detail page
component and then i'm going to pass
that data down to the chart component i
want to keep the chart component as
simple as possible i just want the chart
component to be responsible for
rendering out the data i don't want it
to be responsible for fetching the data
so i'm going to have the page actually
fetch this information so to do that
we're going to make use of the use
effect hook again
and i'll define my function for fetching
data
and let's import axios so i'm just going
to copy the import from another file
well actually i might as well just type
it out
now we can do a const response
equals and then we can fetch our data
but we have to find out what data point
do we actually want to fetch or what
which endpoint do we want to fetch so if
we go under stock price
you want to go under candles so this is
going to return historical data
and to get the information you send a
request to stock
slash candle
and then the parameters are going to be
first of all the symbol like you would
expect
then the resolution so what's the
resolution if we go down here
resolution is going to be what is the
gap between each data point that we want
to plot
so this is um every minute so we'll get
a data point for every single minute
every five minutes 15 minutes 30 minutes
60 minutes uh one data point per day one
per week one per month so
if we're going to chart out um you know
one day's worth of history we may want
to do every five minutes or every minute
however if we're going to chart out one
year worth of historical data you don't
want to do every minute that's too many
data points i would instead prefer
either every day or even every week
so that's what the resolution is then
from and to so from is going to be
you know what is the earliest time that
we should get a data point from and two
should be what should be the last data
point time stamp from
i worded that incorrectly that should be
the last
time that we should grab a data point
from so if we want um one day's worth of
historical data the from would be the
unix time stamp for exactly 24 hours ago
and then the two would be the current
time
and then if it's a year then the from
would be moved back a year and so on
so let's go back here
and i'll do a weight
binhub.get
and this is going to be
stock candle
and then params
well we we're gonna pass in the symbol
then we need the from
the to and the resolution
okay so
how do we get this information
well we're gonna make use of the date
object so i'm going to go
and say const date
equals
new date
so that's going to get
the current date and if or if i want to
get the current timestamp i'll do
uh const
current time
equals
date dot get time
so at that point we can take the current
time and pass it into the two because
that's the last data point because we
want the the current time to however the
api i found out and this took me a a
quite amount of time quite a bit of time
trying to figure this out but this get
time returns it in milliseconds the api
expects it in seconds so to convert this
to seconds what we want to do is we want
to divide it by a thousand so that's
going to give us seconds and then we
also want to do a math
dot floor
so that's just going to truncate any
extra decimals
and in fact i think it might actually
help if i just kind of lab this up real
quick so we'll say
const date
equals a new date
and then if i do a const current time
equals date dot get time
and if we run
node
test.js
and i should have console logged it
now if i run this
this is going to be the unix timestamp
for the current time
in milliseconds
if we want to convert it to seconds
current time seconds
and then we do a console log
so you can see
that this is now being represented in
seconds let's just move the decimal over
three places so that's really all that's
doing
and if we ever want to get like if we
want to go get the timestamp for one day
ago how would we do that well
we can take the
current time in seconds
so i'll say
current time in seconds
and we want to subtract
24 hours right that's one day so how do
we get to 24 hours well this number is
in seconds so we have one second how
many seconds are in a minute we have 60
seconds in a minute we have 60 minutes
in an hour and we have 24 hours in a day
and so this is going to be
we'll call this one
one day
ago
so this is going to give us the time for
one day ago um how would we do one week
ago well we can do
which is going to be current time in
seconds
minus
this represents one day we already know
that
and then we just multiply it by seven
because a week is seven days
and then what's a year it's going to be
a year is just going to be 365.
so that's all we got to do
to get the to and from time
so we have the current time let's get
the time for one day ago so i'll say
const one day
equals current time
minus 24
times 60
times 60.
and so the from
is going to be one day
so from one day ago to the current time
so the two is going to be
current time
and then the resolution
we can do every
30 minutes
and now let's fetch this data
and we actually want to do this only
when the component mounts so fetch
data and then we'll console.log the
response
okay so if we take a look at the
response something interesting is
happening
it says that
data under data it says no data so i'm
not really sure what's going on
but as a test i'm going to change this
to be three days ago and i want to see
if this fixes the issue
and now if i take a look at the data
oh look we get some data back so for
some reason if i do one day ago nothing
happens but if i could do three days ago
something happens
and
i actually noticed this when i was
laughing this out and i only noticed
this issue right before i started to
record and that is that
i'm recording on the weekend this is a
saturday well technically it's sunday
now um and the stock market's closed on
sundays so there's no actual data points
for one day ago because if you're on if
it's sunday one day ago saturday you're
not going to get any data points
so this is something to keep in mind so
we have to fetch data and get calculate
the time uh depending on what is the
current day
so if i want to get basically just one
day's worth of uh of data so if i want
to get friday's data well if it's
saturday i have to go two days back and
if it's sunday i have to go three days
back that's all so i have to put in a
couple of if statements uh when
capturing the time this is just one of
the
uh kind of the pain points of working
with with this kind of data
um i didn't even think about this issue
when i first coded it out so
all we have to do is do an if statement
and i'll say if and then we grab date
dot get day
so this is going to return a number
depending on what day it is and saturday
it'll return a 6. so i'll do equals
equals equals 6. so if this is a
saturday
then
i'm going to make
one day
first of all is going to be a variable
that i can change so it's going to be
let
if it's saturday then i'm going to do
get two days worth
of data so i can get friday's data
and then i'll copy this
and then if it's sunday which is going
to be a zero
then i want three days worth of data
so now our application's smart enough to
figure out that hey if it's saturday
we're to have to get two days worth of
data if it's sunday it's going to be
three days worth of data
and then if it's not any one of these
days and actually this should be in if
else
i'll say if and let me move that
up
and then finally else
one day is just going to be
just one day so we'll remove the three
okay so back to our application
and now we've got some data
so to understand what how this data
works is pretty simple so t stands for
timestamp
so at this specific time this is a unix
time and if you ever want to
convert this pretty easily there's a lot
of tools online like this epoc
converter.com you just take the time
you paste it in there
and then it tells us hey this is uh this
is the timestamp of that data point so
this is august 25th at 8am
so this is the timestamp and then these
are the values that we saw before at
that specific timestamp so what was the
close what was the high what was the low
what was the open
and what was the
the volume i guess
so now that we've got this data
let's also get
the data for one month sorry one week
and one year
and i'm going to define a variable so
i'll call this const one week
which equals
current time
minus 7 times
24 times 60
times 60
and then for one year we'll just change
this to 365
and then we can just copy this
and we'll change the
from to be one week
and the resolution to be and we'll just
call this response
week response day
and the resolution can be
you know every hour so we just need a
data point every hour
and then we have response year
it's gonna be one year
resolution can be i don't know
you know every week that would give us
52 data points if you wanted every day
you could do
every i think it's every day what was
the
yeah d stands for day so it just depends
how detailed you want it to be i'm just
going to do one week just because
there's no need to grab 365 data points
for this demo
so this is going to fire off three
requests get all that information
and then i can just do a console.log
of all of these
okay and so now we've got
uh this is going to be
the day
this is going to be the year
of the week and then this is going to be
the year
however if you've noticed that this is
all happening
in series sequentially so this one has
to complete first then we send the
request for this and then we send the
request for this and we can confirm this
by going to our network tab
and there's a lot of networks so let me
actually clear this
refresh
so notice how one
i hated that one complete
one
one completes
then the next one completes and then the
next one completes so we don't want that
so we're going to do the same thing that
we did
for
the
um stock list component where instead of
fetching it one by one we do the
promise.all method so we could just fire
off all those requests at once
so here i'm gonna go up here and i'm
gonna do
const responses
equals await
promise.all
and then we provide a list
and i can just copy
these into there
and then we can just do a console.log
responses
all right and we see all three fired at
once
perfect perfect perfect
and i think something's actually
erroring out hold on let me see if i can
find this out so let me put this in a
try catch block
which we should have done anyways
okay never mind okay all of them are in
there that's good everything's working
now the next thing that i want to do is
i want to format the data because if we
take a look at the data this is not
exactly in the most convenient format
because this is still the axios response
so it's got all of the extra config
information that i don't care about it's
got the headers the request i don't care
about that i want the data
but in addition to wanting the data i
also want to format it a little bit
differently
and the format that i actually need this
in is going to be a little unusual but
you can see right now we have a
object
and then for the closing value it's a
list of all the values and then for the
t is going to be a list with all those
values and so the first item in here
matches up with the first item here with
the time step here the second one second
one and so on and instead of doing it
like that i need it in a specific format
for my chart and i want the data to look
like this
so i'll say constant data and it should
be
an object
with an x value
of the t value of the t right that's
going to be
you know this here
and then the y
should be the closing value so what was
the closing value at that time
and then i want a list of these
so it would actually be a list
and then i would have a couple of these
so that's that's what i want the data to
look like so we're going to have to
transform this data ourselves
and let's define a use state hook so
that we can save our data so i'll say
const
we'll call this chart data
and then we have
set chart data
equals use state
and i showed you what we wanted the the
data to look like
and i'm actually going to save that in a
file actually don't worry about that and
actually what i want to do is i want to
store in our um
in our
in our hook in our chart data
i want to store it like this so in our
cons chart data it should look like this
we should have an object
with a property of day
and this is going to have
data for one day
and then we'll have a week
and then we'll have a year
of data for a week
data for year so that way our chart can
just pick whichever one it wants and
then the date the data for each one of
these should be the way i showed you
guys so that was the data equals object
that's going to be a list
an array
with uh multiple objects
with an x
of some value
and a t
and a y
of some value
and there's going to be multiple data
points so that's what i want the data to
look like so this is going to go
in the value here so hopefully this
makes sense
this is kind of the most confusing part
is just manipulating the data for the
chart but i want to get it into that
format
so down here after we fetch the data
i'm going to call set chart data
and we're going to pass in the object
with the day property
with the week property
and the year property
and we're going to call a function which
we're going to define in a bit
format data
and here
remember the responses
for the responses the first one is going
to be for the day the second one is for
the week and the last ones for the year
so i could say
responses
and then we want to grab
zero
so the first entry and then within the
zero we want just the data right we only
care about the data we don't care about
the configs
so i'll say data
we're going to do the same thing for the
rest of these guys
and then this is going to be 1
is going to be 2.
so let's now define this uh function
outside of our component we don't really
need it in the component
so it's going to receive some data
which is going to be an array and guess
what we're going to do we're going to do
uh the map method so say data dot
and so right now we're getting this data
object right here so we want data dot
and then we want to iterate over t
t dot map
and we'll get access to two things now
you know normally when we did the map
method we get access to just one
which is the element that we're
iterating over but we can actually get
another
value which is going to be the index of
the item that we're iterating over so
i'll grab the index
and so i'll say return
so x is going to be
the element so that's going to be the
specific time stamp
right so this could be this time stamp
but we have to multiply it by a thousand
because
uh the
the api does it in seconds and
unfortunately our chart does it in
milliseconds so just multiply by a
thousand
and then we have to get the
corresponding y value right so for the
first item in the
t array we want the first item for the c
array so we just say whatever index
we're on just grab the same one from c
i'll say y
data dot c index
and that's all we have to do
and let's refresh this
responses is not defined let's take a
look at where that is
oh yeah that's silly me so we're going
to move this into our try catch block
now if i go into my
react component
extension and we go into stock detail
page
and we take a look at our state
our state looks exactly the way we
expect it to look
so we've got one for day with x y
we've got one for week with the x y
coordinates and then the y
and then the year
perfect
and for the dependency array um
technically this will work the way it is
however
if the symbol changes we should run the
use effect hook again so we're going to
add this to the dependency array
and for
returning data uh we're going to do a
couple things first of all let's create
our
chart component
so i'm going to call this
add file we'll call this
stockchart
dot jsx
and i'll say export const
chart
and then in our stock detail page
under this div
i'm going to actually do two things so
first of all we don't want our chart to
render until we have
our chart data set so if it's still
fetching data we don't want to render
the chart because there's nothing to
render
so i'm going to say
if
chart data
and then i'm going to do and and
and render out a div
and then within our div
i can call my stock
chart
component
and we'll import our stock chart
component
and so what exactly is happening here
this is a nice way of saying if chart
data is not null then i want you to
render out this data if it's not
if chart data is null then it's going to
return null and it's going to render
nothing so it's basically just doing a
little if statement if chart data is a
value we'll render this out if it's not
then nothing will get rendered out
so let's test this out
no errors and you can see it loads up
there's nothing there and then stock
chart comes up after we get chart data
perfect
okay so let's work on our stock chart
component the first thing is we're going
to receive some props and mainly it's
going to be the chart data so i'm going
to destructure that out and then when i
actually call this in my stock detail
page
we're going to have to pass in that data
so i'll do stock chart then
chart data equals
chart
data
and i think we should also pass down the
symbol
because the chart should know that as
well so i'll pass down the symbol
and now in our stock chart what we can
do is
we can destructure out the day
week and year from the chart data
and now it's just a matter of
configuring the specific chart library
so we're going to make use of a charting
library called apex charts
so let's go to the documentation in here
and so all we have to do is do an npm
install apex charts so we can go back
and i'll go here and i'll search for
apex charts
and we want that first result
and in addition to that
if we go down to
integrations they have react
integrations that make it a little bit
easier to work with the charts and so we
have to install a second library which
is kind of like a wrapper for the apex
charts library to work with react so
that we don't have to do all of the hard
work ourselves
so this is just called react
apex charts
and i will install that as well
and if we take a look at the react
integration all we have to do to create
a chart is just pass in the chart
component that comes from react apex
charts and it requires a couple of
things first of all it's going to be
options so this is like the uh
configuration for your chart like what
color do you want it how do you want it
to kind of operate animations things
like that
series is going to be the data
that it should receive
uh the type that's going to be the type
of chart and then also the size of the
chart as well so only four props that we
need and we'll go over all of these
props in a bit
and let's go to chart types
and the chart type that we're going to
use is called an area chart so this is
going to be what we're using and if we
just take a look right same thing
so we know what we're going to set the
type to um if we take a look at what
else do we need
okay so
using the chart when we pass the series
like i said the data should look like
this
right the x is going to be the time
and the y is going to be the value or
the price of the stock and we already
configured that ourselves so we're
already good to go on that that's why i
format it ahead of time the other
properties that we need is the x-axis
should be set to type of date time so
that's going to give us the time so
let's just go ahead and just start
playing with it and then just work on
this one option at a time
and so i'm going to import chart
from
be act
apex charts
i'm going to render out a div
and let's define the options for our
chart so we'll do const options
so first of all let's give our title our
chart our
title and so if the configuration for
the title first of all it's going to be
the text what do we want the text
or the title of the chart
that's going to be the name of the stock
so we have the symbol that we can just
pass in we have to destructure that out
from props so the text is going to be
set to symbol
align so how do we want to line up the
text so it's going to be center
and then we're going to make it just a
little bit bigger so we'll set style
and we'll do font size
24 pixels
uh the next thing is going to be chart
specific configuration
so we're going to give this chart an id
so we'll say stock data
and then if you want you can also
customize the animations
and i'm just going to set this to be
speed of 1300
next thing is going to be configuring
the x-axis so we saw that in the
documentation we have to set that to be
date time because the x-axis is going to
represent a time so type
date time
so let's try this out i think that's
enough
options let's set up the series
so the series which is going to be the
data that we passed to the chart
is going to be an array
and then an object for the configuration
the reason it's array is because if you
go back to the documentation you can
have multiple series so multiple you
know different types of data sets we
just have one we just have one so that's
why it asks for an array but we're only
passing in one object
and in this object
we have to pass the name
so this is going to be the symbol
and then the data
which is going to be day we're going to
set it today for now just to take a look
and now i'm going to add some
style
to this div
to set the background color
and we'll also give it some extra
classes
so
add some margin to the top
some padding
shadow as well
background is going to be white
and i guess i didn't actually need this
style we can actually delete that
all right now we can pass in the chart
component
and so the options that's going to be
set to that object that we created
called options
and the series is going to be set to
series
type is going to be set to area
and width is going to be set to 100
percent
okay and we can take a look at our chart
and it actually looks pretty good
so it's able to plot the data points
however
right now it's not using the correct
uh time and that's because i wanted to
show my local time
so wherever i'm located i'm located on
the east coast i wanted to show the east
coast time uh and then when you know
when you guys are using i wanted to show
your local time and so to do that we can
go up to x-axis right here
set labels
date time
utc
that defaults
okay and that's better so that's better
now if you take a look at the the tool
tip
right it says 25th of august
i wanted to be a little bit more
detailed i wanted to include the
specific time stamp as well in the tool
tip
so we can go under x-axis here
and add a tooltip
configuration and the format i want this
to be for the x-axis
is going to be format
and then we want mmm for the month the
day
and then i want the hour
and then the minute
so now we got
the month day and the time as well
the next thing that we need to implement
is we have to provide the buttons for
the users that they can select if they
want to see uh the past 24 hours if they
want to see seven days or one year's
worth of data and we should be able to
change between these and also obviously
the color changes depending on
if the stock gained or if the stock went
down
so going back to our app we're going to
render out a couple of buttons
right under the chart
so i'm going to add another div
and we're going to add a couple buttons
and these buttons are gonna manage
you know which one they've selected so
we're gonna have to use uh we have we're
gonna have to define some state we're
gonna use the use state hook
and i can call this uh what about
i don't know date format i couldn't
think of a better name
and then set
date format
use date
and then it's going to be 24
hours okay and so uh when the user wants
to see one day's worth of data they're
gonna set date format to 24 hours uh if
they want to see um you know seven days
we'll do seven days and if they want to
see
uh one year they'll say one year
and so for these buttons we'll just set
up a on click event handler
and we'll say set
date format to be
uh the first button this is going to be
for um one day so i'll say 24 hours
and actually
let me
add the closing tag as well so now i can
say
24 hours
and i can copy this on click event
handler
and just paste it into the other two
and just change this to be
seven days
and one year
and then don't forget to import
the eustate hook
and so now we have these buttons and
obviously we can add some style to them
but now what we want to do is we want to
update the data
depending on which one is selected
whether it's
24 hours one week or one year
and i think the best way to do this is
to define a function
i'm going to define a function down here
it's going to be very simple it's going
to be called determine
time format
and we're just going to have a switch
statement where we're going to switch on
date format which is going to be the use
date hook that we just created
so whatever this is
and if it's set to
24 hours
we're going to return
day
so we're going to return the data
from here
and if it's seven days
then we're going to return week
and if it's one year we're going to
return year
and then we also have to provide a
default
and so if nothing is provided then we'll
just return day as well
and so now inside this series
we can just change this to be
determine
time format we just run that it's going
to return the correct data set
so if i try seven days we could see it
adjust one year
and for the year we can see there's
something goofy going on and that's
because
it added a lot of decimal values i think
i remember seeing that also
let me see if i can find that in the
actual data set
yeah so this data point right here so
we're going to have to truncate it maybe
we'll just grab you know two decimal
points
and so to fix this issue um what i'm
actually going to do is if we go to the
stock detail page where we fetch the
data and then format the data when we
format the value you can perform the
truncation here so you know i said i was
going to round to two i was going to
keep two decimals but i think it's just
easier just to remove the decimals so
i'll do a math.floor
and that's going to remove all the
decimal points if you want to handle the
logic for
keeping two decimals you would just
manipulate it right here
yep and now we can see we just get whole
numbers perfect
all right so let's style these ugly
buttons
and on top of that let's also provide
some feedback to the user which
uh which one they've selected right if
we take a look at the final app it
highlights the one they've selected
and to do this if we go to our stock
chart
we go to our button component
for styling purposes what we want to do
is add a couple of classes
we want btn
and btn-primary
and that's going to give us this look
and if we do btn
outline dash primary
right now we have the unselected look so
that's the difference between selected
and unselected is going to be this
outline right here
so how are we going to do this well i i
think we should create another function
to kind of handle this logic so i'm
going to say
render button select so this is going to
handle all the styling as well as
figuring out which button has been
selected
so all of the buttons are going to have
the following classes
they're going to have btn and then i'm
also going to add a margin of 1 so they
have a little space
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say if button
equals equals equals date format
then we want to
return classes
plus
btn-primary
and i want to actually add a space here
so what this is saying is if this button
is um matched up with the selected
button
or the selected data set then we want to
do btn primary which is going to give us
the filled in color
or else
we will do the unfilled in one so we'll
do return classes
btn
outline dash primary
and so for each one of these buttons um
i'm going to change the class name
and we're going to just render that by
calling render button select
and then we're gonna pass in you know
since this is the button for one day i'm
gonna say 24 hours
we'll copy this
paste it to here
this will be the seven days
and this will be the one year
and so what's really happening is um
we're passing in one year
so we're calling in
uh we're calling in uh render button
select into this button so button is
gonna be set to one year and it says if
one year equals equals date format
which is
whichever one is currently selected
then we are going to make that the
selected button however if they don't
equal that then it's going to be the
unselected button
i think that should be everything that
we need to do so we can see 24 is
selected
if i select one year one year selected
seven days seven days perfect
and the last thing that we got to do
is we want the color to change
based off of if the stock is going down
or if it's going up so in this case it's
going down it's red
down red
however it goes up that's green
and this gets a little tricky
but the colors
can be specified in the options
so here we would do colors
and then you would provide an array and
then here you would just provide your
you know your hex color okay so
uh we're going to first implement the
logic for determining are we going down
or are we going up
this is where the math gets a little
funky
so i'll say const color this is going to
be the color that we want
equals
so how do we figure out
if the
value is going up or down
so
to figure out how to do this i actually
want to take a look at the data one more
time
so take a look at stock not stock chart
chart data
so we can better figure out what this is
going to look like okay so this is what
chart data looks like we can see that we
get one for day week and year and the
logic is going to be the same regardless
of which data set we select
so remember
this is going to be the earliest uh this
is going to be
the
uh first data point so if it's one year
if we select one year this is going to
be one year ago and then the last data
point is going to be the current time so
to figure out if the stock has gone up
or down we take the current time
the current y value
and we subtract
the first y value if that number is
positive that means it went up
if we if that number is negative then
our stock went down simple as that and
we have to do this for all of them
so i'm going to define a variable
called color
now
this also has to be aware of
uh the
the different um day week and year
formats so
we don't actually know which one
selected so we have to run determine
time format
so that's going to return either day
week or year depending on whichever one
selected
so this function will return that data
set
and the first thing that we want to do
is we want to grab
the last item in that array how do we do
that
well we can call that same function
call the dot length
and then subtract 1. so that's going to
grab
the last
the last entry right so that's going to
go all the way down
and it's going to grab
well this is the wrong one but that's
because since we're typing this out
there's going to be errors
but that's going to grab the last entry
and we want to subtract
the first entry so we just run that
determine time format
we want to grab the first entry which is
0 and then we grab the y value
and i forgot we should grab the y value
on this one as well so hopefully that
made sense all is doing is grabbing the
last data point and subtracting the
first data point and it's going to use
this function to figure out which data
set to work on
so now we have color or now we have a
boolean and we can use a ternary
operator to say
if it's positive if this value is
greater than zero
we're going to return
this
but if it's not greater than 0 then
we're going to return this nasty
red
and then here we can change the colors
and just pass in the color variable
and
i made a mistake i'm going to move this
or actually i won't move this i'm going
to move this determine time format
function
above this because it's referencing that
so it needs to be above it
now we can try that looks like things
are working let's try seven days
one year okay well they're all going
down so let's uh
let's go back and find
i think what was the one we were looking
at
okay so that's going down it's red good
red
green perfect
so now let's implement the uh delete or
remove functionality so we should be
able to hover over one of the rows and
then remove it from the list
and like i said i wanted to save this
until we got the detail page working so
that i can show you a little issue that
we're going to run into
and i was trying to figure out the best
way to kind of implement a kind of a
delete button or icon and i kind of got
lazy so i just picked the simplest way
so if we go to our stock list
and you go down to the bottom where we
render out
the data
all i'm doing is just adding a button in
here
i could have picked something a little
bit classier but i was just
the the idea is that we want to
implement the logic that's what matters
uh and so the logic is gonna be same
regardless of what is the icon you use
and where you put it
so we're gonna put this button here this
is going to say remove or delete
whatever you want
and let's give this a couple of
classes so i'm going to say
class name
equals
btn btn-danger
btn-sm
ml-3
and then d-inline-block
and then we also want to add in a
separate class called delete dash button
so all of these come from the
bootstrap library except for the delete
button we'll implement this ourselves
and so now
we go back
there's a remove button however we only
want to show this
when the user is hovering over the
specific row
so how do we do that well i'm going to
go to our app.css
i'm going to define some rules so i'm
going to say we're going to reference
that delete dash button
and i'm going to say visibility by
default is going to be set to hidden
and then i don't think this is going to
do anything but i see this in my notes
so we'll just add it anyways
then when we hover over a row we want
the button to show so this gets a little
tricky
so we want to say when
table dash row and if you recall what
table row is
we got to go back to stock list
and table
row where is it
here we go table row right here so
this class that goes uh assigned to the
specific row
when table row is hovered
we want to select the delete dash button
and then here all we do is just set
visibility to visible
simple as that
and now if i hover
there you go now we got the remove
working
so the next thing that we have to do is
set up the
uh the on click event handler
so here's our button
i'm gonna set the on click
so here we're going to call the well
we're going to have to grab the delete
stock
from our context so we'll call it delete
stock
and if you forgot where that's coming
from that's just coming from our context
api where we have this function that
we're passing down that handles deleting
it from the watch list
so we'll say delete stock
and then we want to pass in the symbol
which is going to be accessible through
stock data dot symbol
and i think that should be it so let's
take a look
i'm gonna try to delete microsoft
if i hit delete
okay well something interesting happened
it routes me to the next page so why is
that happening well think about this
when i click on this delete button
technically i am clicking on this row
on the row that this button is assigned
to so if i go up to this row
well where's the row i think i scroll
too far the row this has a handle stock
select
uh on click event handler and if i go to
handle stock select that's what handles
the navigation
so what's happening is when i click the
button it's also triggering triggering
this
on click event handler and this is the
issue that i wanted to show you guys so
what's happening is that
i do technically click on the remove
button however the event bubbles up so
it starts bubbling up
all of these elements up to the to the
tr
and then it triggers this event handler
or this on click event handler so that's
the problem it's due to event bubbling
so how do we avoid this well react gives
us
a handy
thing we can call so we have to first
get access to the event so i'm going to
pass the event into the function and we
just say e dot stop
propagation so this is going to prevent
the event from bubbling up to that
parent component
and this is apparently an a i've been
mispronouncing it
so now let's go back
let's see can i remove microsoft
perfect and you see microsoft got
removed can i remove google
perfect perfect
and that's all we had to do for handling
the deletion of an item from that list
the next thing i want to do is implement
the stock data component which is going
to give out some extra information about
the
company uh like what was its ipo date
what's the you know what's its market
cap what's its website and things like
that
so let's go back to our
components and let's create a new
component
and it's going to be called stock data
we'll do export const
stock data
now the way that stock data works is
that it's going to fetch
data from a new api endpoint and i
believe it's called company profile2
and so yeah this is the one that we want
to use so we just send it to slashdoc
profile2 and then you provide the symbol
and it's going to give us all of that
information that's all we got to do
so let's handle fetching all the
information
and this component is actually going to
accept a prop which is going to contain
the symbol of the stock that we want to
get information for
so let's import the use date and use
effect hook
and then we'll call the use effect hook
and let's go ahead and set the
dependency array this is going to render
anytime symbol changes
anytime that prop changes
and then we'll do const fetch data
and let's import the api as well
and i'm going to go a little bit faster
for this um you guys have already seen
this enough time so
should already be second nature but here
we can fetch the data and i'm going to
do uh
let's get the try catch block
and so this is stock and then profile
two
and then the params is going to be the
symbol only
and if we go to our detail page
we want to render this component out in
the detail page
and so i'm going to just render it right
out
right below the stock chart so let me
import it
sorry this should be stock data
and i got some errors let's see
and i actually already know the error so
this should be apis
okay and let's take a look at
oh it doesn't look like it rendered out
or
no we need to i think i forgot to
console log it
no i logged that console logged it
yep and i forgot the parentheses okay so
we got that let's try this out now
all right and so now we have all of the
information
about the company and so we can render
that out now
and that's really all this component is
doing is just fetching a little data and
then rendering it out but we do have to
store this information in a use date
hook
so let me just do a const
stock data
set
stock data
that should be in the use effect hook
and then right after here
we'll say if
is mounted
then we want to set
stock data to be response dot data
and then we'll add the cleanup function
and now it's just a matter of rendering
rendering out um
all of that data
so this is now going to be changed to a
div
and i'm going to do that same expression
where i say stock data if that's set and
only if that's set will we then render
out the rest of this
and what we're going to render out let's
see we'll start out with the div
and we'll give this a couple classes
so i'll say row border bg dash white
rounded
shadow dash sm p dash 4 and mt-5
and then within here we're going to have
some divs
this is going to have a class name of
col and there's going to be three of
these
and then within each of these there's
going to be
three entries
for the individual data points so i will
say
and let me not copy that i think that
might confuse you guys
so we'll say div
and in this div we're going to have a
span
with the class name of
fw bold
and we're gonna have three of these
within each one of those parent divs
under call so i'm gonna add three in
there and three in here
and now we can just name the property so
this one's going to be name
this one's going to be the country
this one will be the ticker
this one will be the exchange
we have the industry
the ipo
market cap
shares outstanding
and the url
all right so now if we check this out
and go back to the main page and
okay so it's got all of the
headers but it's not
spread out the way it should be so i
feel like i'm missing a class or two
okay yeah i just had a uh a minor typo
um that got messed up with the divs but
now it's spread out across the three
uh the three columns that i've defined
and now it's just a matter of passing in
that data into each section and we
already have the different properties so
if we want country we just do country
currency exchange and so on so i'm just
going to quickly go through this we have
the stock data stored in this variable
and we can just access it
through that property so we'll say
for the name
we'll just do stock data dot name
and i'm going to just copy these real
quick across each one of them and then
we'll update it individually
we have the name the next one is going
to be the country
this one will be the ticker
this one will be the exchange
this one will be fin
hub
industry
next one will be ipo
and we have market capitalization
share outstanding
and then this last one is going to be a
url to their website so
i'm actually going to make this a a link
and the href
is going to be
stock data dot web url and then for the
the text you can make it whatever you
want i mean you could just do the same
thing if you wanted to just make it
stock data.web url
and let's give some spacing between
these like i did for the other ones
and i think that should be everything
that we need here we go so that's going
to wrap up the stock data component
so the next feature that we need to add
for this project is let's say that the
user navigates to our website the first
time we automatically populate these
three stocks for them
um and then let's say they go in and
they
search for a specific stock
and let's say they want mcdonald's and
then let's say they delete one of these
other stocks
if they navigate from this page or
refresh the page guess what happens
our website doesn't remember and it goes
back to google microsoft amazon if you
take a look at the final product
the final product will remember uh any
stock that we
it remembers our entire watchlist so if
i grab mcdonald's
and i delete google
i hit refresh
it remembers it and the way that it does
this is if we go to the chrome developer
tools
and we go into application
and you go under storage local storage
you can see that what i have done is i
have stored the list of stocks that the
user wants to keep track of in storage
in local storage so that when we
populate the website the next time they
visit it we could just pull this list
and then query that data
so this is the next feature that we're
going to implement and you're going to
see that it's actually going to be
pretty quick and pretty easy
so this is all going to be done in the
watchlist context because that's what
handles the watch list
and i'm going to
import a use effect hook
i'm going to add a use effect here
and i want this hook to run whenever we
change watch list so anytime watch list
changes
i want to go to local storage
and then i want to set something so i'll
do set item and the key is going to be
called watch list
and the data we're going to pass it is
going to be our watch list
now this use effect hook is going to run
every time this provider component
re-renders
we don't really want to do that we want
it to render every single time
the watch list gets updated so we just
say
we set the dependency array to be
watchlist
and this really is the main use case for
use effect so anytime something changes
in your application
and you want to update something kind of
outside of your application like the
local storage or a session
um or some other property outside of
your application you use a use effect
hook and this is the perfect use case so
this is going to set it
and i think i forgot a t wait item
so let's test this out
so i'm going to add in tesla
and now if i go to my application
tab
and we go to local storage we can see
google microsoft amazon tesla so now if
i refresh
it remember
well
it didn't actually remember it
but that's because we set it in our
local storage however it's not actually
pulling that information from the local
storage so where do we actually where
and when do we pull this from the local
storage
well it's going to be in this u-state
hook
so when this u-state hook runs
the first thing it should do is and i'm
going to copy this for a second
and i'm just going to paste it here make
this a comment
and i'm going to
put this across multiple lines so when
the the default state for our hook
should be when our application first
loads we should look into local storage
and we should call get item
for watchlist
so this is going to give us a string
and if we actually take a look at it it
just gives us this string so we have to
turn it into an array
so how do we turn it into array we call
a dot
split method
and we want to split it
every time we see a comma
and if we don't have anything in local
storage then we're just going to
default to this
does that make sense
right remember this is just a string
when you read and write to local storage
it's just a plain string right
and so when we call the split method
it's going to split it wherever there's
a comma and it's going to add that as an
entry into a list
so let's try this out now
i'm going to add tesla
okay tesla's in there let's refresh
and it remembers tesla let's remove
microsoft
does it remember that
it does in fact remember that and keep
in mind i have to refresh this so if i
yeah we could see microsoft's not there
now
i'm going to show you a bug in our
application
if i go to my watch list
and delete it
and i hit refresh
nothing shows up what's going on well
let's see if there's something in the
console
and we can see the air says cannot read
properties of null so what happened
well our application loads the provider
loads and then it runs this uh you state
hook where it sets the default value so
it does so it looks into local storage
it tries to get item watch list keep in
mind if we go to our application in here
we can see there is no watch list so
this returns nothing
and if you try to uh this returns
undefined and if you try to perform a
dot split on an undefined that's the
exact error that we're getting right
cannot read properties of null reading
split we can't we can't call split on
null
so how do we get around this issue very
simple
you just put a question mark right here
so what this question mark does is
it's going to check to see if this
actually exists if it doesn't it's just
going to return a null and it's not
going to run this code
i think this is called null coalescing
i can never remember the terms but yeah
so all this does is check to see if it
exists if it exists perfect we'll just
run the next code if it doesn't exist
it's going to return null
and if this returns null then we just
default to this
so let's try this
again okay and look at that it defaulted
to the three despite the fact that
we had cleared the local storage and we
can just test this out once again
and that's perfect so it looks like it's
working
i'm going to remove this stack overview
page we don't need that let's see where
is that
stock overview
okay guys so that's going to wrap up
this project we've implemented all of
the features uh that i wanted we've
gotten a chance to learn a lot of
different features and functionalities
within the react ecosystem things like
the context api react router
we've gotten a chance to work with
different libraries and apis like the
apex charge library as well as the
finhub api and uh hopefully you guys
enjoyed this project and i will see you
guys in the next one
we've reached the end of the course not
only have you learned the basics of
react you also coded three react
projects
good luck to using this knowledge to
create your own react applications